Nice!
Hallo.
Test, Test.
Und, exzellent.
Gut.
Oh, ich muss kurz husten, warte mal
So
Excellent
Also, Erkältung ist wieder gut
Hat schon alles erledigt
Oh, ich hab grad richtig viel gefressen, Leute
Muss aufpassen, dass ich nicht einpenne
Das ist ein sehr
Nices Emote, das gefällt mir
das da. Das werde ich, glaube ich,
auch. Ist das ein 7TV-Mode?
Zufällig?
Nee, ist es nicht. Gut.
Dann kann ich es mir nicht.
Kann ich es nicht dem Channel hinzufügen.
Moin.
Was ist jetzt los, ey?
So.
Was trinken?
Also.
Jaja, ich erzähl gleich was dazu.
Ich krieg da auch kein Geld für oder so.
Wobei, ich krieg heute Geld für.
Deswegen ist das heute eigentlich ein ganz guter Tag.
Ich hab heute Bereitschaft
und kassier da wieder
für nichts tun.
Hm.
Machst du auf der Arbeit auch 90% der Sachen mit KI?
Ne.
Na toll.
Dann viel Spaß mit den Problemen, wenn es mal nicht funktioniert.
Also ihr wisst, dass ich nichts davon halte, irgendwas zu Vibe-Coden,
absolut keine Ahnung davon zu haben, was man eigentlich gemacht hat.
Aber das ist ja im Kommen.
Das ist ein witziges Emote
Warte mal
Add to
bei uns schreiben die leute mittlerweile echt kaum mehr code selbst von hand bin ich mal
gespannt wie das bei euch vielleicht in einem halben jahr aussieht wenn dann irgendwas nicht
richtig funktioniert ich warte ja noch darauf dass das zum maintenance albtraum wird das ganze
vibegecodete Zeug.
Ich mein, ihr wisst's, ne?
Im Street, wir benutzen das ja auch oft mittlerweile.
Aber was wir eigentlich so gut wie
gar nicht machen, oder gar nicht machen, was heißt
nicht so gut wie gar nicht, gar nicht machen,
wir machen keine irgendwelche
agentic Geschichten mit.
Ich brauche das und das, erstell mir mal
das und das und jetzt lass ich dich mal zwei Stunden
laufen und dann kommt was bei raus.
Das nicht. Kollege von mir,
der hat, äh, ein Tool
ge-vibe-coded.
richtig umfangreiches Webinterface
zu managen
von
Getränkeautomaten.
Und das will er jetzt verkaufen.
Mal gucken,
wie gut das dann
unter täglicher Userlast
funktioniert.
Das hier findest du gut? Okay, kann ich mich trauen,
das aufzumachen, Chat?
Ups, warum mach ich das weg?
Das ist auch nett. Ja, das mach ich auch.
Das kommt auch noch dabei.
Wir haben ja, ich habe noch so viel
Seven-TV-E-Modes frei und noch viel schlimmer.
Ich habe noch so viele Channel.
Ich habe noch 21 Channel-E-Modes.
Die ich hier zufügen kann.
Also auf Twitch selber.
Na, wenn das nur irgendwelche Boilerplate-Sachen erstellt sind und einer guckt drüber, dann ist das nicht so krass gevibe-coded, was ich meine.
Also was ich meine ist, wenn irgendwie einer die Idee hat, so keine Ahnung, ich will jetzt eine Webseite bauen oder noch irgendwie was, ich will irgendein Tool bauen zum Checken von Rampreisen oder so.
So, das gibt er dann ein, lässt dann irgendwie Cloud Code oder so drei Stunden dran rumwurschteln, da kommt dann irgendwas raus, was so aussieht, als funktioniert es und das erste, was die Leute dann machen ist, die pushen das auf GitHub, posten das in irgendeinem Subreddit und am besten direkt noch mit Spendenlink und allem dabei und im Endeffekt macht es überhaupt nicht das, was es soll, es sieht nur so aus, weil eins kann KI wirklich gut vortäuschen, dass es das ist, was du haben willst.
Genau, das ist ganz wichtig.
Zweite Ereignisse.
Do not make any mistakes
und think extra hard.
Ganzer Beispiel.
Dann ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann ist alles okay.
Dann kann nichts passieren.
Max, hast du mitbekommen, dass man bei System D jetzt sein Alter angeben soll?
Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht.
Das Einzige, was System... Also ich hab das verfolgt.
Leute, habt ihr auch die Diskussion der letzten Tage mitgekriegt,
wegen Altersverifikation und sowas?
Was die gemacht haben ist, die haben die Möglichkeit geschaffen,
dass du in irgendeinem Jason-Feld dein Alter hinterlegen kannst
und über System D, dass du quasi eine gemeinsame API hast zum Abfragen.
Du musst weder dein Datum dahinter legen, dein Geburtsdatum,
noch ist es eine Altersverifikation in dem Sinn.
Das ist höchstens was, was irgendwelche Distributionen benutzen können,
wenn sie konform mit, was ist das, Kalifornien, Brasilien und New York oder so,
Laws konform sein wollen.
Ja, wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Falls irgendwelche
Distributionen mit den Gesetzen
in
Kalifornien, New York
und glaube ich Brasilien
konform sein wollen, dann muss das
Betriebssystem ja eine Möglichkeit
bieten, das Alter des Users abzufragen.
Es geht nicht wirklich um Altersverifikation
in dem Sinn,
sondern nur darum zu speichern, wie alt die Leute sind.
Da kann man wahrscheinlich auch irgendeinen Mist eintippen.
Aber, und deswegen sehe ich das auch kritisch,
also dieser einzelne Punkt jetzt selbst für sich genommen,
dass das System D da einbaut, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich sehe das trotzdem kritisch.
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz hier meine Logitech-Software starten.
Keine Ahnung, warum, das ist wieder ein Check.
Ich sehe das allerdings trotzdem kritisch,
Weil diese ganzen Dinger von Chatkontrolle bis Social Media Verbot für Jugendliche bis Betriebssystem, Alterscheck, Verifikation oder API anbieten und so.
Das ist ja klar, worauf das hin zielt alles.
Das ist also meiner Meinung nach, meiner Meinung nach, ja.
Also aus meiner Meinung nach zielt das dahin, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir tun ja mal wieder alles für den Schutz der Kinder.
Kann ja keiner was dagegen sagen. Und wenn wir das dann haben, diese ganzen Dinger, dann wird das Schritt für Schritt aufgebaut, äh, nicht aufgebaut, ausgebaut, oder aufgebaut kann man es auch nennen, ja, aufgebaut, ausgebaut, um noch weitere Überwachungsmaßnahmen und, ähm, Dinger zu starten, ja.
Zum Beispiel, dass man als nächsten Schritt sagt, ey, jetzt, wo das System schon da ist, da können wir ja auch anfangen mit, Leute dürfen auf Twitter nur noch mit ihrem echten Namen posten oder sowas.
und das
Beispiel, ja
und dass
man nichts drauf geben
darf, was gesagt wird
will ich bloß nochmal ein Beispiel
bringen, was mir auch
sauer aufgestoßen ist, das ist jetzt
nichts Schlimmes in dem Sinn
aber das ist auch was, wo man sieht, dass man nichts drauf geben
kann
während Corona
gab es doch diese Sachen in Restaurants,
wo du dich eintragen konntest oder musstest,
weiß ich gar nicht, dass du da gewesen bist.
Oder nicht, dass du da gewesen bist,
sondern diese wer, wie, wo, welches Restaurant besucht hat und sowas.
Dass man dann die Leute informieren kann,
wenn da Corona-Fälle sind und sowas.
Und das wurde damals angekündigt,
dass das rein ganz streng zweckgebunden
nur zur Nachverfolgung von Corona-Infektionen und sowas gedacht ist.
Und ein paar Wochen später kommt die bayerische Polizei um die Ecke.
Ja, aber wir hätten auch gerne Zugriff auf diese Daten.
Der Fall an sich ist jetzt nichts partout Schlimmes, aber dann sieht man, dass du nichts drauf geben kannst, was heute gesagt wird, dass das morgen noch Stand hat.
Noch Bestand hat.
Deswegen glaub ich da auch kein Wort,
dass es da irgendwie...
Den ist doch...
Den ist der Schuss von Kindern wahrscheinlich
vollkommen egal.
Denen geht es darum, um weitere Überwachungsmaßnahmen
und Kontrollsachen etablieren zu können.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach so.
Classic.
Seit wann haben wir das Classic-Emote nicht mehr?
Ach ne, das muss man klein schreiben.
So, äh
Jetzt bin ich ein wenig
side-getrackt geworden
Ja, sehe ich genauso
So wird es sein, ja
Gehe ich auch von aus
Ähm
Google Duplex, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Es ging um Age Verification für OSs.
Mit was programmierst du das Tool?
Ich weiß noch nicht genau.
Entweder Go.net.
Wir brauchen auch ein kleines Webinterface.
Deswegen müssen wir mal schauen.
Vielleicht stelle ich auch fest,
wenn ich mal ein bisschen geguckt habe.
Moment, warum mache ich meine VM auf?
Das ist kompletter Blödsinn, die brauche ich gar nicht
Dass ich doch keinen Bock drauf habe
Mal gucken, warte mal, ich mache mal kurz hier meine
Meine
Lidungskiste an
So
Dachte das verdammte Spiel
Äh, es ist nicht gestartet, obwohl ich
einen Startknopf gedrückt habe, was ist da los?
Ja, also Leute, es kann sein
Und ich gleich dazu sagen
dass ich jederzeit... Oh, ich muss mal kurz mein Handy
bisschen lauter machen. Wartet mal. Handy lauter?
Äh, hallo?
Muss ich wieder meinen Code
eingeben, Alter. Was ist das denn?
So, jetzt. Darf ich jetzt das Handy lauter machen?
Okay.
Gut.
Kann nämlich sein, dass ich jederzeit weg muss.
Ich habe heute Bereitschaft.
Also heute und morgen.
Allerdings wird es wahrscheinlich heute
abgesagt und ich kriege morgen keine
Bereitschaft, krieg trotzdem die Kohle für.
Also, pepo burn money.
Also, aber nicht meins. Ich krieg's ja. Also, soll mir
recht sein.
Und die machen grad irgendwelche
Wartungsarbeiten und wenn irgendwas schief geht,
muss ich im Zweifelsfall
irgendwelche Ansible Jobs neu starten oder
Server neu starten oder irgendwie mal in die Logs gucken
und sowas. Also, es kann sein, dass ich mir
hier demnächst einer was schreibt.
Heute Morgen war schon mal was, zwei Minuten.
Heute Morgen wurde ich angeschrieben,
Ansible Job ist fehlgeschlagen.
Habe ich mich eingeloggt, habe ich reingeguckt, habe ich festgestellt, okay, wurde Leerzeichen vergessen beim Job starten.
Und dann ging es.
Gleich neues NAS, Leute.
Ich habe jetzt drei NASs plus meinen alten HP Microserver.
Ich glaube, das reicht.
Wobei, eigentlich kann man nie genug NASs haben, oder?
Was ist eigentlich die Mehrzahl von NASs?
Was würdet ihr sagen?
Ein Nass, mehrere Nasses, mehrere Nass, mehrere Nasse
Nässe, Nasse
Schwierig, ne?
Also streng, also korrekterweise würde ich, also ich glaube korrekterweise müsste man sagen
Ein Nass, mehrere Nass
Ein Netzwerkspeicher, zwei Netzwerkspeicher, oder?
Gibt's keine Mehrzahl von.
Musst du dafür vor Ort gehen oder kannst du auch per Remote...
Eh, Remote, Remote, Remote, alles Remote.
Alles Remote.
Ich hab mich vorhin auch Remote eingeloggt und den Ensemble John...
Das wäre ja noch besser, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie nach Frankfurt fahren müsste.
MonkaS.
Katzi.
Das Terminal, Leute, das könnte man noch ein Tick...
Was meint ihr?
Noch ein Tick weniger durchsichtig, das Terminal, oder?
Der Hintergrund guckt noch ein bisschen zu sehr durch, finde ich.
Opacity.
Guck mal, wir haben es schon hier.
Machen wir 99% Opacity.
Ja, so ist gut.
Das ist exzellent.
Jetzt scheint es nur so ein ganz kleines bisschen durch.
Aber man erkennt alles wunderbar.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Exzellent.
Und umschalten funzt auch.
Was ist das für ein Emulator?
Was meinst du?
Was für ein Emulator?
Du meinst da, wo das Linux läuft, oder was?
Das ist kein Emulator.
Terminal-Emulator.
Das hier.
Das ist Westterm.
Beste.
Für mich beste Terminal, was es gibt.
Und es hat...
Wisst ihr, was noch besser ist?
Es hat keine KI-Funktion.
Hast du den 1-Minuten-Meme-Clip?
Nee, aber da gab es jede Menge zu.
Kannst du posten, ja.
Wie oft kommt das vor, dass du dabei angerufen wirst?
Das kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, was ansteht.
Also normalerweise ist Bereitschaft sehr ruhig.
Da wirst du, keine Ahnung, vielleicht zwei, dreimal im Jahr angerufen.
Wobei angerufen wirst du eigentlich gar nicht.
Also ganz, ganz selten wirst du wirklich angerufen.
Ich wurde samstags auch schon mal angerufen, als ich Bereitschaft hatte.
Aber du wirst meistens vom Monitoring alertet.
Dann kriegst du halt nachts um drei irgendeine Meldung.
äh, Service irgendwie XY ist seit 15 Minuten nicht verfügbar.
Du musst dann aufstehen, musst dich einloggen, das ist schon nervig,
aber das kommt zwei-, dreimal im Jahr vor, wenn's hochkommt,
also das ist, das ist wirklich, also das ist ganz gering.
Gibt's extra Geld, wenn die tatsächlich anrufen?
Es gibt, nee, wenn die, wenn die tatsächlich anrufen,
gibt's Arbeitszeit mal, mal irgendein Multiplayer, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab's aber, ich hab aber manchmal, wenn das so kurz war,
Weißt du, wenn du eine halbe Stunde nur geguckt hast oder so, dann habe ich einfach nichts eingetragen und habe einfach die halbe Stunde mehr Geld genommen.
Ayaya Enjoyer.
Da haben wir, glaube ich, ein paar, ja.
Ja, ey, ich sag gleich was zu.
So.
switchen wir mal hier rüber.
Ja, und das
MonkaS dich nachts ganz schön,
wenn dein Handy gebimmelt.
Wir haben da so eine komische Alert-App.
Ich push dir
erst mal
über... Oh!
Ich hab ja Bereitschaft. Vielleicht soll ich die Alert-App
auch mal starten.
Heckel.
Wär nicht verkehrt, oder?
aber hier
er will aber wir haben zwei sagen wir haben zu erlönt ab die push dir dann
gegen diese paar Informationen aufs Handy sowas und ich
Service XY Länger als 15 Minuten nicht verfügbar und unter Bimmels und man kann
auch in der Landshut einstellen und sonst was
dann rufen die dich auch an
und irgendwie ist es total verpackt oder ganz merkwürdig
oftmals kommt die Push-Notification und der Alert davon zeitgleich mit dem Anruf von denen.
Also man würde ja eigentlich erwarten, die pushen erstmal einen Alert,
gucken, ob du drauf bestätigst und dann rufen sie dich 5 Minuten später an, wenn du nicht reagierst.
Aber das kommt dann zusammen und irgendwie spackt dann immer das Handy richtig rum,
wenn diese zwei Sachen gleichzeitig kommen.
Es kann sich dann immer gar nicht entscheiden, was zusammen spielen soll.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
haben wir hier massig
massig cute
Emotes.
Ja, das sagt.
Es ist bei uns glücklicherweise alles ziemlich stabil.
Muss man wirklich sagen.
Es läuft alles ziemlich stabil.
Also es geht kaum was kaputt.
Dementsprechend machen auch viele Leute
gerne Bereitschaft, weil es einfach
fett Kohle gibt für in der Regel
nichts machen.
So, kann man sich das jetzt angucken?
Darf ich das aufmachen oder kommt jetzt da irgendwie
wirklich jetzt gerickrolled?
Ich finde das so schrecklich, ey.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, eigentlich, eigentlich, ne,
dachte ich ja bis dahin,
dass DLSS quasi
ein schöneres, oder ein schöneres
ist das falsche Wort,
eine Art von Anti-Aliasing ist.
Anti-Aliasing.
Ich kann das seit 20 Jahren schon nicht richtig aussprechen.
Aber ist es nicht.
Jetzt macht es auf einmal noch mehr.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Oh no.
Naja.
Ja, da ist schon was dran.
Da ist echt was dran.
Also, ich...
Bin der Meinung, man sollte nicht die, auch wenn das einige, gerade was AAA-Spiele angeht, bin mir nicht so sicher bin, ob sie das noch haben, aber man sollte nicht in die künstlerische Vision eingreifen, was die Grafik und das Design von Spielen angeht.
Mir ist es viel lieber, es sieht vielleicht nicht realistisch aus, aber dafür aus einem Guss.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, Mario Galaxy 1, und das kam auf der Wii raus, ja.
Das ist eines der schönsten Spiele, die es gegeben hat.
Ja klar, man kann das jetzt nicht in puncto Fotorealismus sehen oder das hat ganz schön pixelig.
Aber ich habe selten ein Spiel gesehen, was so stimmig aus einem Guss aussah.
Ja, oh, dann nehmen wir mal ein bisschen was Neueres.
Nehmen wir mal Expedition 33.
Ich finde auch, dass das
ein sehr...
Das hat zwar einen recht
realistischen Stil,
aber es hat schon eine eigene
Sprache, könnte man das glaube ich nennen.
Und das muss so aussehen, wie es aussieht.
Und ich hätte
wirklich keinen Bock, dass dann irgendwelche
KI
die die gesichter realistischer macht oder sowas also ich sehe da kein also
ich sehe da für mich kein großer anwendungszweck für und ich hoffe dass
man diesen ganzen mist in zukunft wegen uns ausschalten kann problem was ich da
drin ein bisschen sehe ist wenn wenn sich das etabliert
was soll dann die spielehersteller machen sollen die dann eher damit
rechnen dass die leute es einsetzen und komplett drauf scheißen dass ein spiel
schlüssig stimmig aussieht weil so nach dem motto kommt der elika ii filter
drüber oder auf der anderen seite okay wir sollen wir geben uns noch mühe aber
viele sehen es nicht das ist doch kacke also ich ganz ehrlich bin der meinung
sollen sie die finger von lassen das hat kein mensch gebraucht
ich verstehe den reiz davon und als optionales ding dass man sagt okay man
kann damit vielleicht alte Spiele,
ohne dass das irgendwie remastered
oder Texture Packs oder was auch immer, brauchen
noch ein bisschen schöner machen.
So optional und, aber
dann vielleicht.
Aber ansonsten finde ich es ehrlich gesagt
nicht so dolle.
Hast du schon einen Kommentar über
die gezwungene Age Verification gegeben?
Ja, habe ich. Weil irgendjemand
hatte geschrieben im Chat, ich glaube
der AF-Programmer wegen System D.
Ja, ich habe mich da am Anfang schon drüber
ausgelassen. Ich, also ich kann es nochmal
kurz sagen, ich bin der Meinung, diese ganzen
Diskussionen, die es aktuell gibt,
sei es hier um diese, also es geht
ja bei der Sache unter Linux, geht es ja
nicht mal direkt um Age Verification,
also da wird ja nichts verified, das hat
irgendein JSON-Feld, gibt es da, wo
drin steht, wie alt der User ist.
Da kann sonst was drin stehen, also es wird nicht wirklich
verifiziert, aber es braucht halt eine gemeinsame
API zum Abfragen, wie alt ist der User.
So, das für sich genommen ist ja an sich nichts Schlimmes, aber ich sehe das Ganze trotzdem kritisch, weil diese ganze Geschichte jetzt, die es in Brasilien gibt, in New York, in Kalifornien mit Age Verification oder auch bei uns mit Social Media Verbot für Jugendliche und solche Geschichten oder in Australien, in Australien ist das ja schon am Start,
oder auch mit Chatüberwachung, was es da nicht alles für wilde Fantasien von den Leuten gibt.
Meiner Meinung nach ist das alles nur vorgeschoben, dass die sich um das Wohl der Kinder kümmern wollen.
Das ist alles nur vorgeschoben und dient dazu, weitere Überwachungsmaßnahmen
oder irgendwelche Überwachungsmaßnahmen, trifft es eigentlich ganz gut,
Kontrollmechanismen zu etablieren.
so nach dem Motto, ey, guck mal,
wir machen was gegen Terroristen,
wir machen was gegen, äh,
wir beschützen die Kinder und alles,
das sind, das sind alles so Punkte,
wo keiner so wirklich was dagegen sagen kann,
ja, da sagen alle, ja, ja,
okay, mach mal, ja, mhm,
und wenn das Zeug dann da ist,
kommt als nächstes um die Ecke,
ach, wie wär's denn damit,
wenn wir jetzt auch noch kontrollieren,
Wer irgendwas
Böses auf Twitter gepostet hat
Das ist ja dann das nächste
Als nächstes kommt dann
Der nächste Schritt ist dann ja
Jetzt wenn wir das schon mal haben
Dann müssen wir ja auch gegen Hass und Mobbing im Netz vorgehen
Das ist ja auch eines der Lieblingsthemen
Der Politik der letzten Jahre
Hass, Hate Speech im Netz
Da müssen wir unbedingt vorgehen
Und da müssen wir jetzt vielleicht auch kontrollieren
Ob einer was Böses gepostet hat
Nicht dass einer wieder irgendein manipuliertes
schwarz kopf bild oder sowas auf twitter poste da muss natürlich sofort die
polizei vor der tür stehen und das wird immer weiter ausgebaut und am ende haben
wir dann komplette online überwachung schritt für schritt salami taktik
mäßig deswegen ist dieser einzelne punkt jetzt wenn man es mal genommen gar nicht
so schlimm aber insgesamt der weg der damit beschritten wird den finde ich
nicht gut
so chat gibt sich jetzt ein bisschen leiser oder
naja 1 lauter kommen
Also, dass Beleidigung eine Straftat ist, finde ich nicht schlimm.
Man muss aber mal die...
Den Schwellenwert sich da mal vielleicht ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Splexer, danke schön für den Sub.
Übrigens, ich habe irgendwas übersehen.
Vorhin gab es noch jemand.
Da habe ich gar nicht drauf geguckt, oder?
Ne.
Nichts zu übersehen. Sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Ich finde, das sollte man keinem in die Hand geben.
Und alle, die immer so krass dafür sind,
die müssen sich mal eins überlegen.
Also viele Leute sind ja,
ich weiß nicht, ob es ihnen bewusst ist,
aber
habe ich zumindest den Eindruck,
viele Leute sind dafür,
solange es
nicht gegen sie geht,
sondern gegen Leute, die sie nicht mögen
ja, also wenn jetzt irgendeiner
sagt, ähm
die und die Personengruppe, die
das machen, das denken, das sonst was
ja, gegen die
hab ich was, und jetzt schlägt einer vor
ah, man könnte die doch mal ein bisschen besser kontrollieren
und überwachen, da sind alle
sofort dafür
was aber vielen Leuten nicht klar ist, meiner Meinung nach
sobald es das gibt
dass du
anlasslos oder aus irgendwelchen
fadenscheinlichen Gründen andere Leute kontrollieren,
überwachen kannst,
wegen irgendwelchen komischen Begründungen
Hausdurchsuchungen anleiern kannst und sonst was.
Sobald sich das nur ein bisschen dreht,
ja,
sind sie auf einmal selber dran.
Deswegen bin ich der Meinung, man sollte mit dem ganzen Scheiß
gar nicht erst anfangen.
Und es kann nicht sein,
dass wegen
banalen Äußerungen
Leute teilweise die Polizei
vor der Haustür stehen haben, weil sie was
Falsches auf Twitter gepostet haben.
Das darf nicht sein.
Weißt du schon mal Weather gesehen?
Nee. Ich kenn weather.in
Es gibt's aber nicht mehr.
Was ist denn
Weather... Was? Wie? So?
Und nach was soll ich suchen?
Auf GitHub oder?
A Terminal Weather App with...
Ach ja.
Ne, das kenn ich nicht.
Oh, das ist ja nice.
Moment.
Ah, gibt's zumindest nicht im Stadt...
Kann man das hier runterladen?
Letzte.
Ja.
Linux AMD 64.
Dann mal runter.
Weather.
Achso.
Seher Mod.
Plus 6.
Wir führen das jetzt einfach mal blind aus.
Who cares.
Hey.
Das finde ich nice.
Oh, Chat.
Location liegt.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wo bin ich denn angeblich?
Äh.
Hallo?
Wo bin ich denn angeblich? Kann ich das hier nicht copy-pasten?
Doch.
Äh, ich bin in Hanau.
Ja.
Das ist, das ist, äh,
gar nicht so verkehrt.
Es trifft's zwar nicht ganz,
aber das ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Also sag mal so, es ist, es ist
hier,
es ist in diesem Umkreis, ja.
Exzellent und was sagt das jetzt das sagt dass es bewölkt ist oder
Das ist ein bisschen wind ist bisschen bewölkt also auf der kasse ist ja glaube ich bewölkt
Bei nach bei zwei nachkommastellern gps genauigkeit von 1 kilometer liegt ja das ding ist bloß das ist halt kein gps
aber das gefällt mir das ist nice kann man dem vielleicht auch irgendwie zum
testen mal andere wetter conditions imperial okay das ist für unsere kokona
friends wind ist miles per hour ich habe keine ahnung was das ist das niederschlag oder was ist
das ist prezip was ist prezip leute
was minus minus simulate a minus es clear
Was war das mit dem Komma hinten dran?
Ah, so sieht es aus, wenn die Sonne scheint.
Rain.
Ich finde das eigentlich cool.
Das ist nice. Das gefällt mir.
Exzellente ASCII-Stells.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird er versuchen,
das irgendwie von der IP aufzulösen oder so.
cool sehr schön das finde ich nice
max als trink erinnern sehr gute idee soll jetzt erzähle ich mal was ich
eigentlich machen will ich habe euch ja letzten schon erzählt
dass ich was gebastelt habe auf der arbeit und zwar also hintergrund ist
folgender. Kennt jemand dieses
Ding?
Passwortsave.org
Hatte damit
schon mal jemand die Ehre, boah, Alter, meine Augen.
Die Ehre, damit zu arbeiten.
Ich glaube, im letzten Stream hab ich schon mal gefragt,
da gab's ein paar.
Passwortsave.
Das ist irgendein
Passwortsave-Tool, was
frag mich nicht, 15 Jahre alt ist
oder so. So, und bei mir
in der Versicherung auf der Arbeit
benutzen die das seit
Auch 15 Jahre oder so.
Wir können ja mal kurz gucken,
wie alt das ist.
Wo gibt es das überhaupt zum Download?
Es ist alt.
History.
Leute.
2002.
Da war ich mit 15 Jahren,
naja,
nicht mal ansatzweise richtig.
Es sind eher 25 Jahre alt.
Okay, 25 Jahre alt, ungefähr, ist das.
Zumindest, die benutzen seit bestimmt schon 15 Jahren diese Passwort-Save-Software.
Jetzt sind sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, meiner Meinung nach auch vollkommen zu Recht,
dass es keine allzu geile Idee ist,
diese Software weiter zu verwenden.
Und jetzt wollen sie KeyPass verwenden.
Meiner Meinung nach die richtige Entscheidung.
Guck mal, die Badges hier unten.
XHTML 1.0 CSS.
Karl van der Gucht.
Na dann.
also jetzt wollen sie zu keepers umziehen und jetzt haben folgendes problem oder was heißt
problem probleme gibt es gibt ja nur herausforderungen sagen noch die amis immer
also es gibt es gibt folgende issues ja leute haben riesig große passwort selbst und also die
haben es glaube ich noch einen monat zeit zum umziehen und leute haben riesig große passwort
Also sag mal Passwortsaves, die seit 25 Jahren sich angehäuft haben.
Sachen mit, keine Ahnung, 800, 1800, keine Ahnung, Passwörter drin.
Wahrscheinlich die meisten davon outdated, overrated, jebaited, aber noch da.
Du hast eine Umfrage vorgeschlagen? Echt? Wo denn?
Sehe ich das hier irgendwo?
Go oder C...
Die Umfrage mache ich nicht.
Die mache ich nicht, weil ich weiß genau, dass C++ rauskommt.
Das gebe ich mir heute nicht.
Ich mache kein Web-Backend mit C++.
Das könnt ihr komplett vergessen.
Und auch nicht mit Rust.
So, jetzt muss ich aber erstmal fertig erzählen.
Also, die haben 25 Jahre alte Passwort-Saves, wo sich, keine Ahnung, 2000 Passwörter oder so angesammelt haben.
Und jetzt ist das folgende Problem.
es gibt keinen Migrationspfad von Passwort-Safe zu KeyPass.
Das Einzige, was es gibt, und das war bisher auch so gedacht, ist,
man kann das als CSV exportieren von Passwort-Safe
und das CSV dann wieder importieren in KeyPass und dann das CSV löschen.
Das funktioniert. So war das auch gedacht.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass irgendjemand festgestellt hat, dass das eigentlich nicht security-konform ist, dass Passwörter kurzzeitig im Klartext gespeichert werden.
Ist halt schon ein bisschen blöd, ne?
Und jetzt gibt es keinen Migrationspfad von Passwort-Safe zu KeyPass und den einzigen, den es gäbe, den darf man nicht benutzen.
So, das ist das Problem.
Was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe ein Tool gebastelt in Go,
was Passwort-Safe-Dateien einliest.
Da habe ich irgendeine uralte,
Moment, muss ich mal gucken,
irgendeine uralte Library gefunden auf GitHub.
Äh, Go?
Ich glaube, das da.
Von 2015, ja?
Ich habe eine Library von 2015 gefunden.
die Passwort-Safe-Dateien öffnen kann.
So, und ich habe eine Library gefunden, die Keypass-Dateien schreiben kann.
Das heißt, ich habe ein kleines Command-Line-Tool gebastelt,
dem gibst du einfach die Keypass-Datei und gibst dein Passwort ein
und dann erstellt er das Passwort-Safe-Datei und dein Passwort
und dann erstellt er dir quasi eine Keypass-Datei mit dem gleichen Namen,
nur mit einer anderen Dateiendung und dem Passwort, dem gleichen Passwort wieder.
Das funktioniert.
So, aber das fanden die auch sehr nice, dass es dieses Tool gibt.
Haben auch extra nochmal nachgefragt, ob das nicht...
Ups.
Äh, Chat-Gel.
Haben auch extra nochmal nachgefragt, ob das hier nicht passiert.
Das darf nämlich auch nicht sein.
Ich weiß, es ergibt keinen Sinn, aber es ist okay, die Passwörter im RAM zu entschlüsseln
und dann wieder zu schreiben.
Das ist okay.
Was nicht geht, ist ein RAM-Disk.
Also es ist nichts, was in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Laufwerk ist, darstellt, darf verwendet werden.
So, da haben sie sich gefreut, haben gesagt, es ist eigentlich mega nice,
haben nachgefragt, ob das auch so ist, dass da nichts im Klartext gespeichert wird und sowas.
Ich habe gesagt, ne, wird nichts im Klartext gespeichert, passiert alles im Arbeitsspeicher
und immer nur jedes Passwort einzeln, also sicherer kann man es eigentlich nicht machen.
Fanden die nice.
Das Schöne ist, ich habe das in Go programmiert, das heißt ich kann da ganz easy eine Echse für Windows rausfahren lassen und eine ELF-Datei, also eine Linux Binary Executable Datei für Linux.
Funktioniert wunderbar und ich habe auch schon drei Passwort-Saves bei uns im Team konvertiert damit.
So
Ah, guck mal, da gibt es sogar ein Plugin für
Nice
So, ja Moment, Moment, Moment
Moment, Moment, Moment
Du glaubst doch nicht ernsthaft, dass wir irgendwelche random Plugins
Aus dem Internet runterladen dürfen
Und da drinnen laden
Und wenn es nur für Keepers 1 ist
Bräuchte ich bei Keepers 1 auch
Ne, ne, ne, so einfach ist es nicht
So, und jetzt ist aber
aufgefallen ja gut wenn wir jetzt das verwenden wollen dann müssen wir das
jetzt hier als offizielle neue software zertifizieren als effizienz das falsche
wort prüfen und intern zertifizieren lassen dass eine neue windows software
eingesetzt werden darf sonst kann das tool ja keiner benutzen
auch toll oder das heißt wir haben jetzt ein tool was das problem lösen könnte
Das kann aber keiner verwenden unter Windows, weil es nicht offiziell zertifiziert und zugelassen ist.
Was ich natürlich machen kann, auf irgendeiner Linux-Kiste mein Tool ausführen, weil da interessiert es nicht, ob die Dinger zertifiziert sind oder nicht.
So, und jetzt hatten wir die klarreiche Idee.
Kann schon, nein, kann nicht.
Kann nicht.
Auf den normalen Arbeitsgeräten, wenn man keine Admin-Kiste hat, läuft im Hintergrund irgendein Software-Scanner, der Binaries, die ausgeführt werden, checkt gegen eine Whitelist.
Und wenn du ein Binary ausführen willst, was nicht Whitelisted ist auf dem normalen Arbeitsrechner, dann wird es nicht ausgeführt, dann wird es direkt geblockt.
Also es ist nicht so, du kannst, du darfst nicht und du kannst nicht.
so und jetzt hatten wir jetzt hatten wir die glorreiche idee man könnte doch einfach das
tool linux only lassen und web interface daran basteln wo man seine passwort save datei hochladen
kann und dann konvertiert das und gibt einem einfach die kippas datei als download da habe
ich mir gedacht, das ist ein gutes Projekt,
das können wir im Stream machen.
Ja.
Und nachdem, wenn ich mir jetzt im Stream
angeguckt habe, wie das
funktioniert, dann programmiere
ich es auf der Arbeit nochmal ordentlich zur
Arbeitszeit.
Aber ich dachte mir, das ist gut, weil
da können wir endlich mal ein bisschen was
programmieren wieder.
Passwörter abtippen ist tatsächlich erlaubt.
Passwörter copy-pasten ist auch erlaubt,
aber copy-pasten mal 2000 Passwörter.
In welchen Sprachen
programmiert man sowas ordentlich?
Also das kannst du in nahezu jeder
Programmiersprache programmieren.
In dem Fall ist die Frage, wo gibt es die
besten Libraries für Passwort-Safe-Dateien
und für
Key-Pass-Dateien.
Also ich hab das in Go gemacht,
das letzte Mal, und da hab ich
diese Library hier verwendet. Ja, und ich hab die
andere, ich hab die hier auch gesehen, das Problem
ist nur,
die ist kaputt, die geht nicht.
Die funktioniert nicht. Wir können das, wir können das gleich
ausprobieren, ja? Wir können das
gleich ausprobieren, aber die hier war kaputt, mit der
hat es nicht funktioniert. Mit
der hier, mit der
quasi elf Jahre alten Library
die sagenhafte
zwei Sterne auf GitHub hat,
mit der hat es funktioniert, aber mit der hier nicht.
Also mit der aktuell maintainten
und wahrscheinlich insgesamt auch besseren Library,
keine Ahnung, hat es nicht funktioniert.
Mit der alten, 15 Jahre
alten hat es funktioniert.
Altes Security, das hat ja mit
Security nichts zu tun. Solange es das auslesen kann, ist gut.
Es gibt für Go, gibt es noch
ein Keypass, Golang, gibt es eine Library?
Sehr nice.
Kann man
Easy-Keypass-Dateien mit Go erstellen.
Ja, also das Tool
habe ich ja schon gebastelt. Das sind 120
Zeilen Go, also es ist wirklich nichts
großartig kompliziertes gewesen.
Kann ja auch nur eine Sache, dass das funktioniert
an sich, ja.
Aber jetzt, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
können wir doch bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal gucken.
Suchen wir mal
nach pw-save.
Doch, doch, es wird schon decodet.
Ein Passwort, da müsstest du es ja einmal entschlüsseln.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Du hast ja den Passwort-Save schon.
Entweder kannst du es auslesen oder kannst du es nicht richtig auslesen.
Zeig uns mal das.
Das kann ich euch nicht zeigen.
Das habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Ich habe auch den Source-Code nicht hier.
Will ich auch nicht.
Das habe ich auf der Arbeit programmiert.
Das bleibt doch da.
Aber die drei Zeilen, die kriege ich auch so.
Oder die paar Zeilen Go kriege ich auch so jetzt wieder hingewurschtelt.
So, also guck mal
Es gibt, oh, es gibt, ah ne, das ist das offizielle Tool
Also gucken wir mal
Passwort save C++, nur just for fun, okay
Scheiße, das gibt es ja wirklich
Das benutzen wir aber nicht
Ist mir egal, ob es das in C++ gibt oder nicht
Also gucken wir mal, was es beispielsweise
ich weiß nicht. Lass uns doch mal gucken, ob es was
in C Sharp gibt, was funktioniert.
Och, GitHub,
come on, please.
Warum ist GitHub
so kacke in letzter Zeit?
Shit, was mach ich denn jetzt?
Oftmals
kann man es ja austricksen.
Ich hab GitHub seit
zwei Stunden oder so nicht mehr offen gehabt. Was willst du denn
von mir?
Login, nee.
ich hab ja doch ich habe theoretisch mein login sogar hier auf dem zweiten
rechner kiepers ist das wegen den lms die den code farmen
das war schon immer so diese diese request geschichte hier aber das kann
sein dass sie noch erst tiefer geworden sind aber ich habe keine agents laufen
die da irgend ach jetzt geht's ich habe jetzt einfach nur mal fünfmal schnell
geklickt also was haben wir kommen passwort selbst die schar passwort safe
flip
das von 2017 okay das sagt auch mal richtig neun jahre da machen wir das
lieber in go ich habe kein carrier kreis ich habe eine echte public hoffe ich
dass ich die noch hab ich habe schon eine weile nicht mehr geguckt aber ich glaube schon ja ja
doch doch ich habe immer noch eine echte public ip also das in c sharp gibt es da irgendwie nicht
wir können mal kommen wir fragen mal die ki ich ich suche eine library in für dotnet die pw safe
files auslesen kann machen wir hier noch
kurs chat gpt sagt und mal gucken was die google ki sagt in rast gibt es in
rast ordentliche libraries für passwort safe und und keepers in go gibt es
zumindest für keepers eine gute dass das passt schon wir machen das in go ich
will mich jetzt nicht unnötig quälen mit rast wieder leider keine offizielle
Das ist mir auch klar.
Andere Sprachen.
Python, PW...
Nicht wirklich.
Du kannst ein Port nach C Sharp machen.
Äh, ich...
Wie...
Seit wann kann man das hier nicht mehr anklicken?
Wir könnten eine KI fragen
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen
Wir könnten eine KI fragen, dass er das portiert
Wir könnten mal OpenCode oder so fragen
Oder wir fragen mal
JLM5 gab es doch
Letztens for free zum Usen
Ich glaube hier, GLM5
Das ist China
Neueste China-Chinesen-Model
Okay, machen wir
Wir fragen das jetzt, wenn es doch so easy ist
Okay
Hat es auch hier
Warte mal
Portiere mir
Zu go
Oh, jetzt haben wir es kaputt gemacht, Leute
Broken
Kaputt
Oh, oh, es denkt
Es denkt
Massive
High IQ denkt
Denkstells
so richtig, ich glaube, ich hab's
echt kaputt gemacht.
Ich glaube, es ist kaputt.
Okay.
Dann Chat-GP. Oder wir können auch
Open-Code fragen.
Kein Legacy-Gefrickel.
Okay.
Portiere mir
zu go. Als Single File.
Das ist kein sinnvoller Mal eben Port.
Wie jetzt?
Der hat doch eben selbst gesagt, dass es easy ist zu portieren.
Minimaler Go-Reader.
Header lesen, Key-Apply in Struktur vorbereiten.
Äh.
Da fehlst du ziemlich alles andere
Okay
Wenn du es wirklich komplett willst
Ich kann dir das sauber bauen, aber sinnvoll in Schreistritten
Ja
Bau mir das sauber
Da kommt 100 pro
Ich wette mit euch, da kommt der übelste Schrott bei raus
Da kommt, ich wette mit euch
Der übelste Schrott kommt dabei raus
Das ist nicht wahr.
Okay, okay
Wir trusten meiner KI, okay
Ich copy-paste das jetzt in ein Go-Projekt
Aber das wird im Leben nicht funktionieren
Äh, was?
Was zum?
Was will der GLM5 von mir?
Ja, Moment.
Ich will das nicht selbst portieren.
Dann mach eine Projektplanung.
Portiere das für mich.
Und ganz wichtig, mach keine Fehler und denke extra hart nach.
So, jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt kann nichts passieren.
Sag mir kurz, willst du
funktioniert sofort richtig?
Zusätzlich schreiben.
Ich will erstens
und zweitens.
Alles klar, dann bekommst du beides.
Funktionieren plus komplett in einer Teilen.
Ohne externe Dependencies.
vollständiger
Go Single File Reader.
Leute, ich wette mit euch,
das funktioniert im Leben nicht,
was da rauskommt.
Aber können wir ja mal ausprobieren.
Das funktioniert
im Leben nicht. Egal.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Chat, Abstimmung.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Das von
ChadGPTFunst.
Ja, nein.
Schauen wir mal.
Warum sehe ich hier keine Abstimmung
mehr jetzt gerade?
Chad, wo ist die Abstimmung hin?
Gibt es hier eine Abstimmung?
Ist auch nicht.
Dann mache ich hier den Chad auf.
Gibt es hier eine Abstimmung?
Ah ja, hier.
Okay.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Okay, die meisten sagen, es funktioniert nicht.
Ich persönlich tendiere ja auch dazu, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Also, dass es kompiliert, denke ich tatsächlich auch.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es das macht, was es soll.
Also, wir müssen uns erstmal einen Passport-Safe-File anlegen.
Hat man nicht ein dümmeres...
Ja, aber du hast ein paar Fragen.
GPT-5-2 frei.
Müsste ich noch frei haben eigentlich heute.
Wenn ich was haben wollen würde,
was funktioniert,
dann müsste ich wahrscheinlich
Cloud-Code und einen API-Key verwenden.
So.
Ja, dann.
Erstellen wir uns mal...
Habe ich Cookie Cutter installiert?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Habe hier die Hälfte nicht drauf.
Habe ich überhaupt meine Template?
Template, ähm...
Template Repo?
Ich habe hier noch gar nichts drauf auf der Kiste.
Okay, Chatge.
Dann müssen wir mal kurz hier rüber switchen.
Die VM nochmal starten.
Die alte Linux VM.
und mal rüber kopieren.
Wir programmieren ein
Web, äh, ein Converter-Tool
von Passwort-Safe zu KeyPass,
was ein Web-Interface hat, wo du das drüber machen kannst.
Sollte jetzt nicht allzu viel
werden an Code
und auch nicht so kompliziert.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, wie man das in Go gescheit macht.
Mit hochladen und dann Datei runterladen und
mal gucken.
Ähm.
äh, SSH.
SSHD.
Okay.
Welche IP haben wir?
1, 4, 6.
Ach, guck mal, da hab ich ja schon kopiert.
Äh, SCP
minus R.
Äh,
Repos, ich glaub Templates
hieß das.
Okay, ich habe ganz viel Zeug kopiert
Templates
Jawoll
Excellent, okay
Dann können wir die
Vm wieder ausmachen
Stellenanzeigen, ja
Das wäre echt eine gute Sache
Ja, ja, ja
Cookie Cutter
Wie war denn jetzt nochmal der Aufruf richtig davon?
Ich glaube einfach nur
Templates
Go
Projektname
PwSafe
Wie können wir das Ding ordentlich nennen?
PwChamp
Okay
So
Hier haben wir unseren Kram
Wir wollen
Goland starten. Ah, Moment.
Oh, ich hab ja hier noch alles, ich hab hier noch gar nichts
großartig zum Programmieren eingerichtet, alles.
Ich hab auch
kein DevPod und so installiert.
Das müssen wir nochmal runterladen.
DevPod?
No such file. Okay.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Äh
Erstmal runterladen
Das Gute ist, dass wir das nur einmal machen müssen
Dann ist das, das hab ich ja alles drauf
Wobei, ganz ehrlich
Wir starten einfach die VM nochmal und kopieren uns das rüber
Fertig
Da haben wir ja dann alles
Ups, äh
Das war jetzt eine schlechte Idee
jetzt habe ich hier auch war auch mal also scp
das war weg scp so was war das jetzt download download ist das download
Dev Pod.
Hier hin.
Okay, Funds.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt auch an sich richtig funktioniert.
Wir wollen Golem starten.
Alter, was ist...
Wie? Warum findest du das nicht?
Was ist das denn hier?
Da ist es doch.
Command not found.
Ist es dumm?
Ich mach mal kurz die Shell nochmal neu auf.
Ich hab irgendwas nicht richtig eingerichtet.
Golem.
Oh, was ist das Problem?
Was findet er nicht?
Ähm, er findet...
Er findet Deathpot nicht.
Warum nicht?
Warum...
Ah! Kann das sein?
Weil Aliasse
in der Shell irgendwie nicht...
Aber warum geht das denn dann auf dem...
Warum geht das denn dann auf der VM?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Warum geht das in der VM?
Jetzt bin ich gerade überfragt, was für eine Magic habe ich in meiner VM gebaut?
Das kann nicht im Pfad sein, das Ding heißt überhaupt nicht so, das heißt DevPod CLI.
Und es ist auch nicht im Pfad. Aber warum funktioniert das denn auf der VM?
Warum hat das denn auf der VM funktioniert?
Äh...
Und außerdem Firefox Developer Edition
habe ich auch nicht installiert.
Aber die Hälfte da fühle ich mich drauf.
Oh, das wird jetzt...
Keine Ahnung, was ich da...
Da habe ich irgendwie super High-IQ-Zeug gebastelt.
Na gut, ich meine,
wir können es ja einmal anpassen, aber...
Da ist nichts outdated, das läuft.
Okay.
Äh.
Kann man?
Kann man hier drin eine Alias setzen?
Na, irgendwie sowas? Geht das?
ok das pack am moment docker fehlt auch noch doch gar nicht installiert doch
meine dokumentation ist die die die schelle ist
Devport provider use docker was weiß ich wie ich das eingerichtet habe
Alter, what the fuck?
Okay, quick start.
Provider add.
Das habe ich doch nie gemacht bei der anderen Kiste.
Äh
Wisst ihr was
Ah ich glaube ich weiß was ich gemacht habe
Warte mal
Downloads
Devpod
Ich habe das GUI gestartet
Alter
LibWebKit2GTK4.1
Okay
So ist es halt, wenn man eine neue Kiste hat
Und nicht eingerichtet
Da muss man durch
Chat
Warum hängt es jetzt?
Hallo
Okay, whatever
Aha
Alter, what the fuck
Was will
er jetzt von mir? Lip App Indicator
Cargo Registry
What?
Sag mal, wollen die mich verarschen?
Hab ich diesen ganzen
Shit, das letzte Mal installiert, oder was?
Ayaya
Indicators, Leute.
Die Ayaya Indicators.
Ah, okay,
schon besser. Next.
Nerv nicht rum.
Get started.
Äh.
Docker.
Ad Provider.
Das habe ich letztes Mal bei Squee gemacht.
Deswegen, okay.
Jetzt passt es.
So, und jetzt?
Und jetzt kann ich mich auf Go land.
Ah.
Okay, okay.
Muss man einmalig machen, dann funzt es.
Jetzt kriege ich nämlich einen Container,
den ich entwickeln kann.
Und wenn ich fertig bin, kann ich alles wieder wegschmeißen.
Und das ist rückstandslos weg.
Und das schönste ist, ich bin nicht so anfällig für irgendwelche, wie hieß das nochmal, Site?
Supplychain, Supplychain-Angriffe, weil alles im Container läuft.
Deswegen mache ich den Akt ja auch.
Excellent.
So, dann können wir uns den Kram hier nochmal copy-pasten, die das Chat-GPT daraus gefunden hat.
Achso und
ein Passwort Save
müssen wir auch erstmal anlegen
Äh PwSave
Gibt es das überhaupt für Linux das Tool
FlatHub gibt es
FlatHub
Okay auf FlatHub gibt es das
Da brauchen wir jetzt erst irgendeinen
FlatHub App Store
Bazaar ist gut das nennen wir
Gibt es auf der Internetseite
Ach komm wir installieren das hier von FlatHub
Was?
Ach, Open Code gibt es nicht.
Alter.
Erstmal das halbe Internet runterladen.
Open Code haben wir jetzt auch am Start.
Hack W.
Beste.
Dankeschön OpenCode.
So, please, please.
Jetzt einfach funktionieren, ha?
Okay, er lädt schon mal die IDE runter.
Das ist gut.
Ähm.
So, jetzt müssen wir Passwort-Safe installieren.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Refreshen, please.
Geht noch ein V und das ist normal.
Seht ihr das?
Guck mal, das wobbelt kaum.
Jetzt wobbelt es.
Das ist das allerwichtigste Feature,
dass die Fenster ordentlich wobbeln.
Alles andere ist unusable.
EW Save.
Get. Install.
Excellent.
So, wir legen uns jetzt
irgendeinen Testsave an.
Wie du durch deinen PC
manövrierst, gerade mit wobbly Windows,
ist einfach das Beste, oder?
Exzellent, das ist so nice.
Was hat er denn jetzt schon wieder?
Was will er denn jetzt wieder? Meine Güte.
Agent Dial Unix.
Was?
Holt mich schnell ab.
Was will er denn jetzt?
Warum habe ich das so kompliziert gemacht,
dass wieder keiner checkt?
Ah, kann das sein, weil ich
GoLand nicht installiert habe?
Habe ich GoLand nicht installiert?
Update, okay, go on and update
Please
Sind die 1 bis 4 oben links
Verschiedene zu einem Desktop? Ja, erster Desktop, zweiter Desktop
Dritter Desktop, vierter Desktop
Genau
Korrekt
Kann mir einer erklären, was er für Schmerzen hat?
forward agent style unix ok da machen wir das jetzt anders wir gucken mal was ich da
drin eigentlich mache also ich sage devpod up open ide gleich goland
So, das geht nicht.
Warum nicht?
Try using the debug flag to see more
verbose output. Okay.
Unix user
agent connect no such
file or directory.
Ne, ne,
get not found ist es nicht. Das ist nicht das Problem.
Ähm.
Was hat der jetzt für Probleme?
Also was, äh,
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum er nicht will.
Warum will er nicht?
Ich meine, er vor ihm geht alles wunderbar.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Muss Golem nicht vorher starten.
Was ist denn das Problem jetzt?
Kann ich Docker nicht ausführen vielleicht?
Hier, Docker, PS.
Warte mal. Docker, Run.
Debian, Trixi.
Doch, ich kann Docker ausführen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Haben wir vorhin ein Kernel-Update
oder irgendwie sowas gemacht?
Stimmt, der JetBrains-Gateway,
den habe ich nicht installiert.
Du hast recht.
Das könnte es tatsächlich sein.
Ne, hab ich installiert
Hab ich installiert
Tja
So viel zu, ich benutze jetzt die Lungs auf dem neuen
Neuen Mini-PC
Okay, probieren wir das mal kurz anders aus
Machen wir mal dieses komische Gui nochmal auf
Ob das dann funktioniert
Ja
Workspace
Löschen wir das nochmal
Delete
Okay
So jetzt machen wir nochmal
Keine Ahnung
Create Workspace
Äh
Folder
Ja hier
Was
Geh mal weg
Wo ist es hin?
Das funzt ja als erstklassig
Create workspace
Holder
Okay
Wir wollen starten
Mit
Wo ist Goland?
Das ist blöd
Da
Goland
Create workspace
Guck mal ob das jetzt funktioniert
Was?
Devcontainers Base Ubuntu?
No such...
Da ist irgendwas kaputt?
Leute, das liegt bestimmt an Wayland.
Im Zweifelsfall liegt es an Wayland.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat.
Das ist aber ziemlicher Sack,
wenn mein
DevPod-Geschichte
nicht funktioniert.
Da muss ich ohne DevPod
jetzt entwickeln.
Das sagt
ja mal richtig hart, ey.
Warum der von der Microsoft...
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Macht er hier, macht er das nicht?
Das ist echt dumm, dass das
nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine, wir können das alles lokal auf der Kiste entwickeln.
Das geht schon.
Ja.
Aber.
Forward Agent.
DevPod.
Volumon should be absolute.
Wo steht das?
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, was der da eigentlich versucht zu mounten, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
weil
Moment, gibt es
aber Open
Moment mal
Es gibt kein Open Code
Kann es das sein?
Ist das das Problem?
An dem Moment
.config
OpenCode. Gibt's doch.
Und dann mountet er sich das dahin.
Also sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
Ich meine, ich kann die Mounts mal rausschmeißen.
Ja.
Ne, daran liegt es
schon mal nicht.
Was ist das denn? Das habe ich noch nie
gesehen.
In deiner Konfig steht Home User?
Nee, macht's überhaupt nicht. Wo denn?
Wo steht da Home User?
Ich hab grad ein Kernel-Update gemacht, ja?
Jetzt eben, gerade.
Aber das gleiche Problem hat er vorher schon gehabt.
Mann, warum ist das so nackt schon wieder?
Ach so, bei den Mounds, ja.
Ne, bei den Mounds stand das auch nicht drin.
Bei den Mounds stand drin...
Ah, ich kann nicht zurück.
Docker, Funst...
Ja gut, dann scheiß drauf.
Dann machen wir es halt lokal.
Das geht ja genauso gut.
Also, zack.
Dann.
Goland.
So, open.
Na, nervt nicht rum hier.
Zack.
Open.
Was?
You're free.
Oh man, ich hab mich ja noch nicht mal eingeloggt.
Aber ich hab noch vier Tage left, Leute.
Puh, nochmal Glück gehabt.
Nochmal Glück gehabt.
Hab ich Go überhaupt installiert hier lokal jetzt?
Ja, natürlich nicht.
Weil ich das eigentlich im Container entwickeln will.
Na gut, installieren wir halt Go jetzt noch oben drauf.
Dass der nicht meckert?
Dass Goland nicht meckert, dass Go nicht installiert ist?
Komisch.
Ah ja, okay, okay, okay.
Jetzt starten wir.
Goland.
Das ist doch ein Dev-Container.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Das hat irgendwelche Schmerzen.
Go-Root is not defined.
Was will er mir denn jetzt sagen?
Brauchen wir doch gar nicht.
Wir brauchen kein Go-Root.
Das ist ein Module-Ding.
Okay, also.
Dann machen wir das mal hier schön groß.
Oh!
Leute, kann das sein, dass das Mausrad...
Doch, das Mausrad geht.
Eigentlich sollte man doch mit der Maus...
Mit der Maus hier größer scrollen können.
Text
oder Font. Font Size
müssen wir eben machen.
Achso, geht ja hier.
Okay.
Gut.
So.
Das können wir eigentlich hier alles rausschmeißen.
fmt print keck w gucken wir mal ob alles funktioniert app go run
ist western server drauf mir ist nicht klar dass dass ich das jemals zusätzlich irgendwie
installieren musste ist drauf aber was ist das überhaupt muss ich noch nie
irgendwie starten ist das was weyland spezifisches oder
keine ahnung das muss das das muss man anderweitig mal
Ja, Moment, was du meinst, ist das Dev-Container-Zeug in Visual Studio Code.
Das bringt mir ja nichts, wenn ich Visual Studio Code verwende.
Aber das verwendet das gleiche Format drunter.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was DevPod für Schmerzen hat.
Ja, aber das ist eklig. Ich mag das nicht.
Ich will das schön getrennt haben.
Ich will meine IDE haben und hier mal ein Terminal, wo ich dann per CLI auf dem...
NoDwarf5.
Was zum Teufel ist?
Node War 5.
Was?
Was bin ich sehend?
Was ist das?
Ja, genau.
Das wird gebaut.
Okay, Leute.
Also hier.
Node War 5.
Was auch immer.
So, also jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das funzt, was ChatGPT da vorhin gebaut hat.
Hier.
Im Leben nicht, Leute, sag ich euch.
Im Leben funzt das nicht.
Aber ein Kompilieren tut es schon mal.
Das Passwort-Save gibt es noch nicht.
Wie funktioniert denn das überhaupt?
Ich muss ein Fad angeben.
Äh, was? Open?
Wie soll ich das jetzt überhaupt starten?
OS-Args 1 und Args 2?
Ach, das Passwort soll ich als Argument hintendran angeben.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay, dann brauchen wir erstmal einen...
in einen...
Müssen wir erst mal das starten.
pw-save.
Library.
Open.
Dann legen wir mal... Alter, sieht das hässlich aus.
WTF.
Das sieht ja aus, man.
Okay, das sieht halt aus
wie eine Windows-Anwendung, irgendwie
umgewurschtelt auf Linux.
Okay, Passwort-Safe. New Database.
pw save p save 3 perfekt master passwort 123456 123456 ok use anyway
dass das ausschaut okay es machen wir mal at group chat und ob rename group und jetzt at
Add Entry.
Lolw.
Username.
Blub.
Passwort 123.
Massive.
Okay.
Save.
Exit.
Wo hat er denn, wo speichert er das denn jetzt?
Moment, was?
Home.
Max.
War.
App.
What the f...
Wo?
War.
App.
Waterfox.
Seit wann und...
Okay, ich hinterfrag das einfach mal nicht.
Data.
Na, das ist schon mal falsch.
Config?
PV-Save?
PV-Save-P...
Wunderbar.
Okay, ich hab's gefunden.
Close.
So, okay.
Und dann kopieren wir uns das Pfeil jetzt hier hin.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Okay, passt mal auf, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Go, run.
Minus, minus.
Ähm.
PW-Save.
Ne?
Hab ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Konnte man nicht irgendwie so hier?
Äh.
Konnte man dem hier hinten nicht sagen?
Ah.
Wo soll das Minus Minus weg machen?
Wrong Passwort.
Okay.
War klar, dass es nicht funktioniert, Leute.
Das Passwort ist nicht wrong.
Gehen wir mal ein falsches Passwort.
Okay.
Also das, was ChatGPT da generiert hat, ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Also das können wir uns hier gleich schenken.
Was hat das hier denn generiert?
Monk, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Okay.
Okay, mal gucken, was GLM5 da generiert hat.
Ob das funktioniert.
Okay, also wie Ordnerstruktur...
Okay, wir sollen einen Ordner anlegen.
Machen wir das doch einfach mal.
Wir sollen einen Ordner anlegen.
pw save
Haben das auch ein example wie man das benutzt
Verwendung
Okay nur dann
Dann haben wir das hier mal rein package main
Package main
So, pw-save.
Haben wir jetzt. So, und dann
sollen wir eine Datei anlegen.
Lass uns mal gucken. Das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt einfach
nur dreimal copy-pasted.
Crypto.go
sollen wir anlegen.
Leute, ich hab da so meine
Zweifel, dass das funktioniert, was da am Ende
rauskommt.
Crypto.go
What?
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Okay, ja, dann lad es runter
Please
Ach, ich habe volle Erstellen gemacht
Ups
Hat er jetzt was gemacht?
Moment, ist das...
Ist das hier schon...
Halluziniert oder was?
Ne.
Cannot resolve.
Fix missing dependencies.
Cannot find module.
Okay.
Das ist ja schon mal kom...
Was?
Hä?
Nee, nee, okay, das gibt's nicht.
Okay.
Fake, okay.
Das können wir schon mal vergessen.
Da gibt's schon mal die Libraries nicht, die es vorschlägt.
Okay, ich sehe, wir landen wieder bei der 10 Jahre alten Library.
Wir landen wieder bei der 10 Jahre alten Library.
Übrigens, diese Animation, da kriege ich Anfälle.
Das muss weg.
jemand eine ahnung wie man das ausstellen kann ist das ein kd ist das ein kd ding
das ist ein kd ding oder
weil das als extra fenster das ist schon in wayland geschiss wieder
Ihr seht ja dieses Aufgeploppe, ne?
Das ist übelster Abfuck
Das hier
Oder?
Chat, sagt mal
Findet ihr das Aufploppen eklig oder
Erträglich?
Geht, okay, dann lassen wir
Bevor ich jetzt da wieder 3 Stunden dran rumfuddel
Bis KDE das gecheckt hat
Dann lassen wir das erstmal so
Wir können einfach
Ich weiß wie man das KDE
KDE sagen
Und zwar sagen wir dem einfach
Wenn er ein Fenster öffnet
Ähm
Wie kann man denn die Animation zum Fenster öffnen überhaupt ausschalten?
Das Tool soll ein Webinterface haben, wo ich die Passwortsave-Datei hochladen kann und dann konvertiert es das in Keypass-File und lässt mich runterladen.
Also an sich nichts so super kompliziertes.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht bei Desktop-Effekts irgendwo
Aber anscheinend
Dann nicht
Ja, weil
Das macht er ja bei allen
Das macht er bei allen
Fenstern, wenn die aufploppen
Guckst du dieses Blub
Hadee des Elbe window open animation
workspace behavior desktop effects windows open close animation ich glaube die k.i. lügt
Close.
Nee, was?
Wohin?
Workspace.
Okay, das lügt.
Das lügt.
What?
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Soll die Konvertierung dann kleinzeitig laufen?
Nee, das einfach macht das.
window window management desktop effects animation speed to instant
What?
Animation.
Animations.
Ah, hier.
Windows Open, Close.
Äh, none.
Jetzt haben wir hier auch...
Ah, das ist doch gleich
viel besser.
Viel besser.
Excellent
Guck hier, das ist doch schon
deutlich angenehmer gleich, wenn es einfach so aufploppt
Okay, also, dann wollen wir mal
Ich bin ein bisschen eingerostet, was
Go-Web-Anwendungen angeht
Jetzt machen wir mal eine Go-Web-Anwendung
die auf Port 8080 lauscht
und
was auch immer
Blub zurückgibt
Go, Standardlib
Webserver
Das war simpel
Aber nicht so simpel, dass ich es mir merken könnte
Da muss irgendwie Mux genau hier
Sowas in der Richtung
Ja, das da
Das da brauchen wir
Wunderbar
Handle Function
Slash Handler, genau so geht das
Listen 8080
Go run
Äh
Achso, da gibt es natürlich nichts aus
Es wäre natürlich besser, wenn ich
Das print
Ähm, listening on port 8080
Ja, perfekt so
Okay, von uns
Gucken wir mal, curl localhost
8080, bam
Excellent
Gut
Das mag ich in Go
Die meisten, also so simple Sachen sind in der Regel
Simpel, kompliziertere Sachen können
In Go auch ausarten
Weil das halt teilweise so minimalistisch ist
Was mich in Go immer richtig nervt ist
Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie ein Array haben
Ich weiß, dass das keine Google Go Syntax ist
Dass es dann kein
Map oder sowas gibt
Sondern die Go Entwickler sagen
Just use for loops
For head
Also wir brauchen eine Webseite
Wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit?
Wir brauchen eine Webseite
Die
Chat, ich muss mal in mich gehen
Wir machen einfach eine statische Webseite
Wie macht man ein Go-Binary?
Wie inkludiert man eine statische Webseite
In einem Go-Binary
Und liefert die dann aus?
das ist interessant das war die go in klub web oder in klub text erst mal
text file oder so im bett im bett im bett package
embed
ah
ach ok verstehe
verstehe
da gibt es auch ein folder ich brauche eigentlich kein folder ich brauche nur
einen file das probieren wir mal aus das habe ich glaube ich noch nie gemacht
also folder legen wir mal hier als pwc schon mal weg das komische ding hier
Dann legen wir das mal was an.
www.data
oder www.
Wie heißt es bei .NET?
www.root.
index.html
Dann legen wir hier eine an.
html-file
index
lul
Go embed. Geht nicht.
Must import the embed package
Import embed
Kannst du das einfach so machen?
Okay, muss aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Ah, weil es nicht direkt referenziert wird
Sondern nur im Kommentar, verstehe
So, und jetzt kann ich dann sagen
FS open folder read file
Achso
Ah, Moment, dann ist das ja mit
Folder noch viel nicer
Da kann man direkt
Wobei, ne, eigentlich ist es nicht viel nicer
Ich kann jetzt einfach hier
Theoretisch sagen, fmt
hier, write
hier kann er
%s und jetzt
hier den
file string, hä?
Warte mal, run
curl
und, ja guck mal da
local host
port 8080
geht
jetzt ist die große Preisfrage
Ist Go schlau genug
Zu erkennen
Was das für eine Datei ist
Also checkt es, dass es HTML zurückgibt
So, so
Ähm
Äh, nicht minus V
Text HTML, ja
Oder ist Text HTML einfach nur default
Wahrscheinlich ist Text HTML Default.
Gehe ich jetzt mal stark von aus.
Okay, dann kannst du das mit einem JSON testen.
So gute Idee.
Blub.json
Tackle
Machen wir jetzt hier einfach mal
Blub.json
Textplane
Na immerhin, immerhin
Äh ganz
Egal, also das muss man dann wahrscheinlich explizit sagen
Okay, aber das ist doch schon mal ganz nice
Dass das so einfach funktioniert, den Go
Gut, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt eine Webseite
Bauen, wo ich den Passwort-Safe
Hochladen kann
Also dann müssen wir
Mal die Routen ordentlich machen
Also Händler
Routen-Händler, nennen wir das Ding
Einfach mal
Und dann
Brauche ich jetzt als nächstes
Du hast noch
ein Ausrufezeichen nach... Oh ja, das muss weg.
Tatsächlich.
Das geht doch bestimmt auch schöner, oder?
Unhandled Error. Handled Error.
Äh.
Ja, den Error-Handling kann ich mir an dem
Fall irgendwie auch sparen, oder?
Geht das nicht so?
Okay. Whatever.
Kann man das nicht... Konnte man das nicht irgendwie
diskaden?
Das habe ich doch das hatte ich doch gerade hat er gesagt es ist ein fehler
Ja in drei tagen expired das stimmt jetzt gar nicht in vier tagen lügt es lügt
So dann brauchen wir als nächstes jetzt einen
nennen wir das mal irgendwie
process oder so
Endpunkt
so wie
mache ich einen
Post Händler
in
Post. Gibt's nicht.
Go by
by example
Post
HTTP
Clients. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ähm.
Go HTTP Post Händler
Okay
Hey man muss da gar nicht sagen
Dass das ein Post ist
Das checkt der selbst
Ach man muss das selbst checken
Da drinnen
ach so
ah ja
okay das ist nicht schlecht
das ist so typische Go-Philosophie
dass das alles explizit dastehen soll
okay macht ja irgendwie auch Sinn
also
ähm
Process
Händler
ne ich mach das
mit Standard, mit der Standard Library
das heißt hier drin muss ich jetzt quasi
checken, machen wir das mal kurz
weg. Das heißt, hier drin muss ich jetzt quasi
checken, if
request method
gleich post.
Ja.
Okay.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schöner, ne?
Das heißt,
ich kann auch sagen, wenn das nicht post
ist, dann
return ich einfach. Fertig.
Ich will ja nur weitermachen, wenn es ein
Postes.
Und wie sage ich ihm mit welcher
mit welchem
Return Code er da returnen
soll?
Kann ich ihm dann irgendwie sagen, hier irgendwie
diese
Write
oder Request
Response
Status Code
so.
Okay, und das heißt, wenn ich jetzt
quasi hier auf Port 80
sage, äh,
Process,
dann sagt er
Invalid Memory Address.
Äh.
Okay.
Hahaha.
Ich kann auch Post-Process angeben,
um nur auf Post-Requests zu reagieren.
Wie, du meinst hier oder was?
Wirklich, das geht?
Nee, oder?
So?
Okay, das ist nice.
Aber, ähm...
Was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen?
Was mag er denn jetzt gerade nicht?
Was hat er denn für...
Invalid Memory
or Null Pointer D Reference.
Funktion gibt ja auch
nichts zurück.
Ähm.
Okay.
Ach, so muss man das machen.
Only post allowed.
Ach, man muss das ja in den Writer
writeen.
Ne, ne, das ist Blödsinn, was ich hier mache.
So muss man das machen.
Okay, macht Sinn.
Alles klar. Gucken wir nochmal.
Hier, only post
allowed. Okay, gut.
Alles kleinschreiben.
Only post allowed. Das ist okay.
Okay.
Und jetzt will ich das lesen,
was da gepusht wird.
Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt eine Webseite.
Die
machen wir mal kurz gerade ein Firefox
hier nebendran auf.
Geht das so?
Achso.
Naja.
Schön ist was anderes.
Achso, jetzt wird das ja
Jetzt wird das natürlich nicht geupdatet, das ist ja klar.
Ich will ja die Webseite...
Da muss ich die Webseite direkt drauf machen.
Wie würde ich denn das jetzt gescheit machen?
Dass ich...
Ich will leider so eine Art Upload-Knopf
oder sowas haben.
Ich hab eine Idee.
Wir probieren mal kurz was.
Ich hab doch hier sowas mal gebaut.
Wo automatisch die App
refreshed wird.
Gibt's nicht mehr.
Ich hab so eine Debian.
Gibt's hier nicht.
Na dann nicht.
Gab es nicht irgendwas für Go, Go Watch oder irgendwie sowas?
Go Watch?
Dass man die Anwendung neu starten kann?
Ja.
War das das?
Ne, das war das ganz bestimmt nicht.
Go restart if file change.
Da gibt es ja jede Menge solcher Tools.
Oh, Restart if file change.
Da muss doch irgendwas geben, was...
Ich will das heute mal ohne Svelte Kit und sowas machen.
das ist ja eigentlich nur ein bisschen html reflex dann meinetwegen reflex das
gibt was ist ein gutes programm ist reload
Restart, Programme.
Da gab es doch
eher
Live Reload for Go Apps.
Ah.
Ah ja, 20. Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, und was machen wir da jetzt?
If you want to...
Kann ich jetzt einfach nur sagen
R?
Äh
Ich bin im falschen Ordner, ne?
R?
Okay
Und wenn sich jetzt
Und wenn sich jetzt hier was ändert
Ne, guckt da checkt es nicht
Wenn sich hier was ändert, da startet nicht neu
Oder guckt da standardmäßig
Nur nach Go-Files
Und nicht nach HTML-Files
Kann ich dem denn sagen,
dass er auch auf HTML-Files
watchen soll?
Also, wenn ich hier was ändere,
dann wird er wahrscheinlich neu starten, ne?
Guck mal hier irgendwie so.
Hä, startet er auch nicht neu?
Hm?
Es gibt tausend Varianten, wie man das machen kann.
Äh, hallo?
Äh.
Ich würde das gerne...
Das hängt.
Wart mal.
Go, Air.
Web-Server.
OKS.
Was?
Nee, nee, Moment, Moment, das bricht noch nicht mal ab.
ETF?
Ich benutze das falsch.
Ich benutze das 100 pro falsch.
Use to restart GoHTTP Server after file change.
Ja, ja, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
GoInit muss man anscheinend machen.
Okay
Wirklich
Und jetzt
Alter
Wie viel Zeug
Bitteschön
Was ist das denn hier alles
Proxy
Das kann man alles löschen oder
Oder auch
drin. Also,
include extensions go html.
Ja, ist doch eigentlich alles richtig.
Go build.
Das ist eigentlich default.
Das Problem ist nur,
wenn sich die Datei ändert,
dann macht er nichts.
Ah doch, jetzt.
Jetzt war, okay.
Also, man hat wirklich dieses go init gebraucht.
Process.
Okay, funzt.
Sehr gut.
heißt, wir
changen jetzt mal das HTML
und er hat es gecheckt.
Okay, gut. Das funzt.
Und jetzt funzt das.
Okay, alles gut. Da kann ich das jetzt hier
reloaden und das
funktioniert. Gut.
Also, wir brauchen jetzt sowas wie
Wie macht man
das jetzt gescheit?
Eine Form oder sowas
brauchen wir da jetzt, ne?
Wie macht man sowas
in RAW HTML?
Upload
Hier HTML Upload File
Input Typ File
So
Also Label
Machen wir das hier mal zu
Accept
wir accepten mal alles ja type file id ist okay ja upload
hier kann man jetzt auswählen das ist gut mal eine blöde frage wie macht man das wieder
also escape drücken schluss profile picture netz jetzt vielleicht schuss pw save file
save 3 fall dann gehen wir jetzt mal dahin und gehen nach max repos pw champ app pw save 3 ok
Okay, das ist Funst.
Und jetzt brauchen wir einen Knopf, sowas wie Upload.
Das ging doch irgendwie, was soll man sagen?
Action.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt.
Form Programming.
Button.
Submit, glaube ich.
Lul we.
Genau, und jetzt kann ich hier draufklicken
und dann postet er das
theoretisch auch.
Ah, der postet das zu Slash Upload.
Ne, der soll das zu Slash
Process posten.
Only Post Allowed.
Moment, ist das
standardmäßig kein Post?
Muss man dann sagen Method oder sowas?
Post.
MonkaW.
TV-Safe.
Okay.
Das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Moin.
So, also das funktioniert so.
Das sieht natürlich jetzt absolut
ultra hässlich aus.
Aber was soll's.
wann haben wir zuletzt mal man hat ihr zuletzt mal breaks zum formatieren
verwendet 1995 lässt grüßen
Okay, so, perfekt.
Hübscheste Seite überhaupt.
Beste Seite.
Das ist hier richtig Chefs-Kiss-Webdesign.
Aber ich meine zweckmäßig, ja?
Okay, jetzt müssen wir dem Go-Gedöns noch sagen, was das machen soll.
Macht man das nicht mehr?
Ne, also was heute angesagt ist, dass alles irgendwie Flexbox oder Grid ist.
Und dann musst du das per Flexbox...
Bei einem Text...
Ja, das kannst du bei einem Text für einen Zeilenumbruch machen.
Ich glaube, das ist aber auch so ziemlich das Einzige, wo das noch benutzt wird.
Aber ansonsten machst du eigentlich gar keine Zeilenumbrüche, sondern lässt es halt...
Umbruch fließend selbst umbrechen.
Aber ja, wenn du wirklich was umbrechen willst im Text, kannst du noch BR machen, aber ansonsten benutzt das kaum noch einer.
Musst du da jetzt JavaScript zurückgeben, was die konvertierte Datei als Download startet?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal hier gucken.
Also wir tun jetzt mal so, als würden wir was machen, ja.
Printline.
Converting.
Wir können jetzt, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, dass wir das nicht immer über den Browser machen müssen, weil das ziemliche Abfuck ist.
Okay, Converting, guck, der macht hier was.
Weil das ziemliche Abfuck ist, können wir das mal mit einem Curl machen.
Curl minus V minus X Post.
Guck, der macht ja Converter, obwohl er nichts convertet.
Data, kann das sein?
ging das so mit curl?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, oder?
Data?
EW?
Mal add?
Ne.
EW save.
Punkt
.psave3
Content type
Urlandcode
Ne, das muss doch anders gehen
Guck mal, was der hier jetzt
Pasted beim Upload ist ja
Wartet mal, reload
Was der jetzt hier pasted beim Upload ist ja
Ein Post Request
Mit Form Data drin
Genau, Form Data
Da muss es ja Upload drin geben
Wie macht man einen Curl?
Curl Upload Form Data
Hier, minus F
Aha
Ach so
Das ist wirklich Next Level
Aber das geile an curl ist
Curl kann alles irgendwie
Upload
Und da müssen wir jetzt reinschreiben
Punkt slash hoffe ich mal
pw-save.psave3
Okay ich glaube das hat jetzt funktioniert
Was ist denn wenn ich da was angebe
Was es nicht gibt dann passiert nichts
Okay, ich glaube, das ist jetzt korrekt
Also, dann müssen wir mal schauen
Äh, okay
Dann müssen wir mal schauen, wie wir jetzt
Auslesen können
Was da geuploaded wird
Ähm
Request
Formdata
vielleicht?
Ich weiß, dass das Expired nervt nicht.
Add, Get,
Has.
Kann man
das Iteraten?
Kann man?
FMT, Brindeln,
S.
Was ist denn das hier überhaupt? Ein String.
Okay, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Uploaden wir mal.
Äh.
das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert da ist in das schon mal falsch und wenn ich
über den browser upload ist auch falsch also so funktioniert es schon mal nett
multipart form data das ist eigentlich schon richtig
multipart form data go lang
renner das neue video schon ja seit einem jahr und paar monaten
juni to use my multipart package ich will die form nicht bilden ich will sie downloaden
der kommt nicht hin moment ich mache ein return wenn die methode nicht post ist
aber die methode ist ja post sonst würde auch converting gar nicht gar nicht erscheinen
ich will es nicht ablohnen
Receive.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Pass Multipartform.
What?
Ah!
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Dann ist Form was anderes.
Only available after pass from
is
Okay, also das heißt, ich muss pass
Multipart
Form machen.
Max Memory.
Was soll das sein in dem Fall?
was ein abt total auf max memory bites of its file parts assorted memory
alles komplett bm in max was ist der max wie kriegt man den max value von einem in in in go
int
get max int value
go
äh was
max u int
Max Uint64. Bam!
Das heißt, es kommt alles in RAM.
Handle Error.
Da machen wir jetzt hier so was wie
Error
Put Not
Pass
Multipart from %s
Error. Ja, ganz toll.
unused result ach so ja moment aber ich
return ja gar kein error ich will auch
nicht fmt haben sondern
immer wind will ich haben
So, hm?
Ah, nee.
Print F.
So.
Warte mal, ging das nicht
irgendwie schöner, dass man direkt sagen konnte
Print
Print Error oder sowas?
Einfach so sagen?
Das muss er eigentlich auch
funzen.
Okay.
Multipartform
kann man nicht.
Cannot range.
Okay.
Pile value.
Ach, das ist...
Okay, okay, okay.
Moment. Wie iterated man das denn jetzt?
Muss man Key-Value-Pair iteraten?
Oder?
Cannot range over.
Multipartform.
Okay, ich printe es einfach mal.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Cannot use...
Alter.
Was? Warum nicht?
Weil...
Int...
Int64. Okay.
Max Int64.
Oh, geht's jetzt?
Okay, pork.
Converting. Okay.
Der gibt irgendwas aus.
Unsicher was genau, aber er gibt irgendwas aus.
Ähm.
Wie benutzt man das denn jetzt hier richtig?
Multipart Form.
Und dann?
Pile.
Value?
Hä?
Das ist ganz weird
Das ist so eine komische API
Also
Wahrscheinlich muss ich sagen
Value und dann hier
Upload heißt das ja
Und dann das mal printen
Gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
Ne
Das wäre jetzt auch
Zeuglich zu einfach wenn das einfach geht
ja was request content type ist ein multipart form data
ist es nicht ich dachte schon das macht mich mein web entwicklung aller
Browse, Passwort save
So, gucken wir mal hier
Network, okay, da muss man nochmal reloaden
Upload, okay, so
Post, was hat er denn
gepostet
Request
Upload, Form, oh mein, das ist
jetzt Formdata, das ist nicht Multipart
Formdata
Das ist jetzt normales Form-Data.
Monka ist...
Okay, normales Form-Data.
Heißt, wir müssen jetzt sagen,
Pass Form.
Okay, so, und jetzt Form.
Und das kann ich jetzt aber auch iteraten, glaube ich.
Form.
Print.
Okay, okay.
So.
Immerhin.
Hat das jetzt gecheckt.
Upload.
Boah.
Alter, wo ist das Problem?
Warum geht das nicht?
Upload.
Doch, geht doch.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Funktioniert.
Upload.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Dann will ich mit Curl
kein Form uploaden,
kein Multipart.
Curl upload Form.
Ich will nicht Multipart formen
Ich will anscheinend nur formen
Ich weiß nicht mal was der Unterschied ist
Ja, das funzt nicht.
Ähm.
Ach, das geht jetzt.
Okay, ich habe jetzt einfach random
einfach random minus d
geschrieben.
Was das heutige Sprintziel ist,
das müssen wir erst nochmal im Sprintplanning
gleich, ähm,
ersprinten.
Und, und dann, davor sollten wir
allerdings noch eine Sprint-Retrospektive machen.
Ob es irgendwelche Blocker gab beim
letzten Sprint.
Okay, es scheint zu funktionieren,
was ich hier gemacht habe. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum und was ich, aber es geht.
Also Upload, sollen wir nicht das hier?
Okay, das funktioniert.
Dann können wir das jetzt mal auslesen.
Also,
das da ist jetzt
ein String.
Aber ich will ja eigentlich nur Form
get
encode
get the first value
associated with, okay, get
s, das müsste
jetzt ja eigentlich funktionieren.
Da müsste jetzt irgendein Binary-Geschiss bei rauskommen.
Eigentlich?
Ja? Oder?
Oder?
Ne.
Moment
Der uploadet das nicht
Sondern
Wie macht man das in Curl, Alter?
Der liest jetzt da den String aus
Okay, wir fangen ChatGPT
Du hast recht
Du hast recht, das geht.
Ja.
Äh, hallo?
Ähm.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das in Firefox funktioniert.
Hier, fetch.
Aber fetch den Console sieht man ja auch, was er macht.
Guck mal.
Body.
Post.
Headers.
Hä?
Ich check das nicht.
Hm.
Okay, das ist ja prinzipiell schon richtig.
Und wie lese ich jetzt die Datei aus?
Wie lese ich da jetzt die Datei aus, wenn ich sage hier Upload?
Was?
Form contains
a file input, but it's
missing method post
and enc type. Ah!
Das ist das Problem.
Also, was?
method. Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen muss man das groß
schreiben.
Enk-Type.
So muss man das jetzt machen.
Okay, okay.
Äh, wo ist mein Firefox hin?
Da.
Nochmal hier.
Zack.
Aha.
So, jetzt, okay, jetzt muss ich den ganzen Kabel nochmal rückgängig machen.
Das ist ja nervig.
Also, richtig gut kriege ich es in KDE noch nicht hin mit dem Teilen.
Äh, what the fuck, warum?
Äh, hallo?
Nicht wirklich.
Ähm.
Ich muss jetzt dem im Go-Code...
Okay, jetzt muss ich das Kram nochmal machen.
Pass Multipartform.
Und jetzt printen wir nochmal.
Multipartform print.
Gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Upload.
Failed.
Not enough arguments in call...
Ach so, okay, das war jetzt mathint64.
Okay.
guck mal da ist jetzt was drin und da funzt jetzt auch hier mit dem minus f okay gut da
ist was drin wie ließ war das denn jetzt aus wie ließ man als multi platform richtig aus value
go example
eigentlich will es nicht senden receiving multipart genau hier vom form value form
File.
Ah, so.
Hm.
Was ich jetzt viel interessanter finde,
ist, woher weiß ich denn jetzt, was da
eigentlich alles drin ist?
Also ich meine,
es ist ja schön und gut.
Kann ich das nicht irgendwie iteraten oder so?
Aber ich weiß ja, wie es
heißt, ja. Ich will
File Receiven,
was Upload heißt.
ok ok dass das scheint das scheint was auch immer es macht es scheint irgendwas
zu machen und jetzt was kommt hier jetzt für einen fall oder f es ist ein was ein
Ein...
Ein was? Ein...
File Header.
Header.
Wollen wir mal hier in das Example gucken.
Form File.
Defer File Closed.
Ja, okay.
Ich will
Passwort-Save-Datei uploaden können.
Und dann soll er mir eine Key-Pass-Datei
daraus machen und runterladen.
Und wie lese ich das jetzt aus?
Moment, da gibt es noch mehr.
Wenn ich wirklich
paste bin.
Da gibt es noch mehr.
Hier, File,
Handler, Error.
Okay, File,
Handler,
Bool, what the fuck?
Alter, wie zum Teufel?
Was ist das denn für eine API?
Wie funktioniert das denn?
How to read file.
Content hätte ich noch schreiben sollen.
Das ist ein Slice von Datei-Headern,
da ein Feldname theoretisch mehrere Dateien enthalten kann.
Hier ist das Standard-Fick, um die erste Datei aus diesem Header zu öffnen und zu lesen.
Die eigentliche Datei öffnen Header.
Ach so.
Okay.
Also, ach du Scheiße.
Also, das sind im Prinzip, sind das hier eigentlich Headers, müsste ich das so nennen.
Ja, Headers.
Oh, dann machen wir jetzt hier nochmal den üblichen Check.
If, im Prinzip genau das gleiche nochmal, zack.
Weil Go besteht ja zu 50% aus diesen Error-If-Statements.
Und jetzt
Assign mismatch
3 gleich 1
Achso
Also gibt es dort tatsächlich nur 1
Oder was
Die AI hat sich wieder was zurecht
Halluziniert
Headers
Und jetzt könnte ich hier quasi
Sagen 4 range
Ach ok
Ok ok
Jetzt müsste ich den Inhalt ja bekommen.
Der Inhalt müsste ja irgendwelches...
Okay, das ist File Name nochmal. Können wir nochmal machen.
Okay.
Und jetzt müsste ich ja den Content irgendwie bekommen.
Size, Header, File Name.
Open.
Ach so. Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Öde.
Wir breaken einfach nach dem ersten. Easy.
Ähm.
Open.
Und wie funzt das jetzt richtig?
Ah, jetzt muss ich doch IO
Read All oder sowas machen.
Äh.
Read Text oder
String oder. Oh, wie ging das?
Read.
Ich bin zu dumm für Go aus dem Kopf.
Was macht der denn hier?
Hier, read all, doch.
Das ist doch richtig, was ich gemacht habe.
Hi.
Okay, defer, file close.
Das ist okay, das schadet schon mal nichts.
Was?
Okay, was?
Achso, ah, hier gibt es einen Error, ne?
Hier gibt es auch noch einen Error zurück.
das heißt ich muss hier noch mal den da machen
weißt du was dann close ich die Datei halt nicht
okay was
so und jetzt
read all
na nochmal diesen ganzen
Error Kempel
I.O. Read all. File.
Data. Zack, zack.
Genau. Und jetzt kann ich Data mal printen
und gucken, was passiert. Das dürften ja noch
Bytes sein.
Genau. Und man
konnte doch jetzt in Go sagen String,
oder? Konnte man nicht einfach so sagen?
Dann wurden die Bytes in String
konvertiert. Oder auch nicht.
Aber wurden schon.
Ah, hier. Bam.
Mein Terminal kackt ab. Das habe ich
erwartet. Genau. Bisschen Binary
geblubber hier.
Genau. Okay.
Das funktioniert. So kann man das auslesen.
Excellent. Also.
Passt.
Machen wir das mal zu.
Also, haben wir hier jetzt ein Post-Request
dahin,
die die Datei einliest.
Das heißt, jetzt,
damit haben wir unsere HTTP-Logik
erstmal abgeschlossen.
Jetzt brauchen wir
sowas wie
ähm
ja, äh, Function.
Nennen wir es mal
Convert.
Pw Save to
Keepers.
Und er kriegt
jetzt das, das, achso, das
Passwort müssen wir ja noch übergeben.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Passwort fehlt
uns ja noch. Okay, dann
kriegt er erstmal hier die Data.
Ne, der kriegt nicht, der kriegt den Reader.
Kriegt er.
Wobei, komm, der kriegt
Data, das ist okay
Und jetzt braucht er hier noch das Passwort
So, wie kriegen wir das
Passwort raus
Das Passwort
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt nochmal sowas
Hier, minus F
Passwort gleich
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert jetzt so
Und wie lese ich das jetzt aus?
Ich nenne es mal Pass.
Pass.
Das ist jetzt einfach nur so.
Und das lese ich wahrscheinlich aus, indem ich ihm irgendwie hier sage.
Warte mal.
R.
Chat, habt ihr eine Idee?
Multi.
Multipart Form.
Value, hä?
Value?
Wie fandst du das jetzt?
Pass.
So.
Dann printen wir es mal.
Okay.
Der liest irgendwas aus.
520 von 576.
Was auch immer mir das jetzt genau sagen soll.
Ich habe jetzt eigentlich gehofft, da kommt 1, 2, 3, 4 raus.
aber das ist so einfach ist es anscheinend nicht es ist ein ein was ein string array
Oh, ist das ein String Array?
Ah, weil
ein Feld mehrere Values
enthalten könnte, oder?
Kann das sein?
Wahrscheinlich.
Chat, seid ihr geistig noch am Start?
Oder ist mein Chat gefreest?
MonkaS?
Ah, doch. Okay, ihr seid noch da.
Das ist ja gut.
Warum sind das mehrere?
Dann, Moment, dann iteraten wir das mal.
So.
Orrloop.
Das ist jetzt natürlich...
Und da sollte jetzt 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 rauskommen, oder?
Ne?
0? Warum 0?
Ich check's nicht.
Null?
Auf was bezieht sich denn das Null?
Hä?
Ah!
Moment.
Das ist der Index gewesen.
Okay, passt.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Okay, wir haben es geschafft.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Also im Prinzip kann ich doch jetzt einfach auch so sagen.
Wir sind jetzt einfach mal stumpf.
Passwort.
Hier Headers.
Nehmen wir einfach hier Header 0.
Ja.
Header 0.
Da können wir nämlich diesen ganzen Kram...
Und ansonsten soll es halt crashen.
Das ist mir auch recht.
So.
Guck mal, da können wir jetzt die ganzen Schleifen sparen.
So, und das hier kommt jetzt dahin und dahin.
Convert Passwort
Safe to Keepers
So und zwar
Ist das jetzt ein
Was ist denn das hier nochmal
Ein Byte Array
Byte
Warte mal wir sehen in Go das muss ich so rum machen
Data
Und dann ist es einfach Save
Und das hier ist dann
Pw
String oder Passwort
Okay, gut
Nächste Frage
Wenn wir jetzt mal da theoretisch von ausgehen
Dass das funktioniert
Wie kann ich denn jetzt hier
Mit einer Datei antworten
Irgendjemand hat eine glorreiche Idee
Weil ich will jetzt ja quasi hier
Irgendwas converten
Und jetzt will ich dem ja im Endeffekt
Ähm, in die Response
Eine Datei reinschreiben
Also sowas hier dann
Wir können das ja mal so testen
Wie, aber ich muss dem ja sagen
Dass es eine Datei ist
Die ich runterlade
Redirect Download
Go
HTTP Server
Download File
Bodyreader? Print? Aha! Ne, Surf-File will ich nicht.
Surf-Content?
Serve content replies to the request using...
Ne, das ist eher nicht das...
Ada, set
Ja doch, so in der Richtung
ist das doch sowas, oder?
Was ich machen will
Ist das hier bezahlte Arbeitszeit?
Also
Ja und aus anderen Gründen
ist das bezahlte Zeit, als du denkst
Ich habe heute Bereitschaft
Den ganzen Tag, weil die Wartungsarbeiten
Machen, ich musste heute Morgen zwei Minuten was machen
Ansonsten gar nichts
Es könnte sein, dass sie jederzeit
Sich melden, wenn ich was machen muss
Und ich mache das dann nochmal
Ich mache das dann nochmal ordentlich
Auf Arbeitszeit
Ich habe mir nur gedacht, dass das ein praktisches
Dass es praktisch ist
Wenn wir das im Stream mal zusammen vorher ausprobieren
Weil wir sowas auch gar nicht gemacht haben
Also irgendwelche Go-Web-Sachen mit Convert und so im Hintergrund.
Das ist keine bezahlte Arbeitszeit in dem Sinn.
Also sowas hier in der Richtung will ich machen.
W-Header-Set, Content-Disposition.
Was auch immer es...
Ey, Leute, eins muss man mal sagen, gell?
Chat, können wir einmal
Poggen, einmal
Pogchampen in den Chat
für Jetbrains
Jetchamp bräuchten wir eigentlich noch
Guck mal wie schlau die sind
Die zeigen mir sogar beim drüberhovern an
Was Content Disposition bedeutet
Einmal Poggers
Please für Jetbrains
in den Chat
Oder Pogchamp oder was auch immer
Das ist richtig nice
das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass sie das also general heda ist content ist position ist der
händler der can be used on the multi part body give information about a field it applies so
dass so klasse ok ja dann kommen wir mal attachment file gleich file name
blubb.keypass x. Octet stream. So, serve file. Kann man serve file von irgendeinem x-beliebigen
Reader machen? Ach ne, hier. Serve content muss ich machen. Serve content. Serve content replies
Was? In was für einem Ding?
OS-File.
Äh.
Moment.
Ich hätte GPT mal gefragt.
Ähm.
Want to answer
with a string
from variable.
Something that implements IOZK.
If you don't need
surf content features, range request caching
you can do this.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Also einfach
einfach reiten oder was? Okay.
Write.
Byte. Data.
Okay.
Und jetzt? Okay. Und jetzt würde
Curl eine Datei runterladen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Tatsächlich?
Curl würde eine File runterladen.
Okay, was macht...
Mal umgedreht.
Was macht...
Was würde mein Browser machen?
Firefox?
Warte mal, mal kurz hier ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Local Host.
Browse.
Oh.
Ah.
Weil ich Passwort nicht setze.
Okay, das ist ein Problem von mir.
Ich setze Passwort nicht.
Es ist wieder Exquisite Error Handling.
Input Type.
Secret.
Moment, Sekunde, warte mal.
Wir kopieren das mal so.
Ähm
For secret
Type
Passwort, so genau
Chat
Sollte da jetzt nicht eigentlich
Okay
Ach, guck mal, es geht er kaputt
Ach, er geht kaputt, wenn es eine Exception wirft
Oh, das ist alles so
Und wie beende ich das jetzt?
So, es kann doch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache sein
Okay
Okay, choose Passwort
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Passwort, pw, save
Was hat er denn für Probleme?
Index out of range
Ah
Es ist nicht ID secret
Es ist ID pass
Wisst ihr?
Lul
Ja aber
Kann sich das nicht recovern?
Und jetzt lädt er die Datei runter
Es funktioniert, easy
Genauso wie es sein soll
Excellent, excellent
Funst
Also die eigentliche Sache, die er machen soll
Das Konvertieren, das funktioniert nicht
Also noch nicht
Aber genauso soll es sein
Du lädst die Datei hoch, gibst das Passwort ein
und dann kriegst du dann mal die neue Datei wieder runtergeladen.
Also ganz easy.
So, gut. Das heißt, unser HTML-Gedöns
funzt.
Right. Was gibt's bei Right?
Handle Error. Okay.
interessiert mich absolut nicht, ob das
einen Right Error hat oder nicht.
Äh.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was ich falsch mache.
Ich muss das da wegmachen, gell?
Ah.
Dismissen alles.
Okay, so. Und jetzt müssen wir noch
konvertieren.
Jetzt kommt das Eigentliche.
Wir müssen erstmal KeyPass installieren.
KeyPass CXC.
Um dann zu überprüfen, ob das auch funktioniert hat mit dem Konvertieren.
Sehr schön.
Gut.
Dann müssen wir jetzt hier drinnen weitermachen.
Also, jetzt müssen wir erst einmal eine Keypass öffnen.
Eine Keypass-Datei öffnen.
Wie machen wir das nochmal?
Das habe ich schon mal gemacht.
Aber.
Ich weiß es auch im Kopf nicht mehr.
Wo haben wir es denn hier?
Passwort save.
Go Keypass.
Das da.
Ne, das ist das falsche.
Das ist das, was nicht funktioniert hat
Was ich vorhabe
Kann ich dir erzählen
Und zwar
Ähm
Bei mir auf der Arbeit
Stellen sie um von Passwort Save
Das ist sowas hier
Oldschooliges Windows Ding
Oder nicht mal Windows Only
Aber es sieht alt aus
Wenn du dir die History anguckst
Die erste Version von diesem Passwort Save
kam 2002 raus.
Also das ist jetzt...
Ja, ich...
Ich denke...
Was ist jetzt los?
Was macht meine Maus hier für komische...
Virenzchen.
Ah, das liegt bestimmt daran, dass die VM da noch offen ist.
Also man kann jetzt nicht sagen,
dass das gerade Bleeding Edge Software ist, ne?
Von 2002.
Und jetzt wollen sie auf
Keypass umstellen. Das Problem ist
jetzt nur...
Es gibt keine direkte Konvertierung zwischen Passwort-Safe und KeyPass.
Der ursprüngliche Plan ist gewesen, man exportiert das einfach aus Passwort-Safe als CSV und importiert das CSV in KeyPass.
Das funktioniert auch wunderbar.
Das Problem ist nur, dass unsere Security-Leute dann irgendwann gesagt haben, nee, das geht ja nicht.
das geht nicht, weil das wird auf einem Laufwerk im Plaintext zwischengespeichert.
Und das ist nicht erlaubt.
Daraufhin habe ich mir gedacht, easy, wir bauen einfach ein Tool,
was das konvertieren kann.
Habe ich ein kleines Go-Programm gebastelt mit einer uralten Passwort-Safe-Library von GitHub,
aber die funktioniert von 2015 ganzen zwei sternen auf github habe ich so
command line tool gebastelt was das ganze konvertiert das funktioniert auch
für das dass ich das in zwei stunden zusammen gewurschtelt habe funktioniert
das auch erstaunlich gut so jetzt ist aber das nächste problem ich habe das
kompiliert für linux und windows das geht ja mit go einfach du kannst ja wenn
du ich zeig das jetzt mal für alle das nicht kennen wie nice das ist also man
kann ich sagen, go build minus o
blub zum Beispiel.
So, jetzt habe ich
mein Go-Programm kompiliert, wie ihr
hier seht, ne, das heißt jetzt blub
und Listing, also das ist das Go-Programm.
So, ähm,
was Go kann ist,
man kann bei Go solche Sachen
angeben wie goos gleich
Windows.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, wenn ich
jetzt kompiliere,
als blub.exe
und goos Windows gesetzt habe,
Ihr seht schon, das dauert auch ein bisschen länger.
Und jetzt gucke ich mir mal an, was Plup.exe ist.
Plup.exe ist ein PE32 Plus Executable von Microsoft Windows.
Also es ist ganz easy.
So, und jetzt machen wir hier Go OS Linux und nennen das Ding dann Plup.linuxamd64.
und zack, und schon habe ich
guck mal, schon habe ich
eine Linux Anwendung
und eine Windows Anwendung aus
einem Guss
quasi unter Linux erzeugt
also Go ist richtig geil
was diese Sachen angeht
also mir fällt, sagt mir irgendeine andere Programmiersprache
wo das so einfach ist, Self-Contained
Anwendungen zu bauen, Cross-Compile von
Windows nach Linux, mir fällt nichts ein, also Go ist
da wirklich pock
So, und
Wo bin ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
Ja, genau, ich wollte es mal kurz zeigen hier mit Go
Also, Leute, nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich würde zittern
Meine Maus spinnt manchmal ein bisschen rum, wenn ich hier diese Maus-Weiterleitung gemacht habe
Die macht dann manchmal so hier
Das bin ich, das ist die Maus, okay
Also, dann habe ich das kompiliert als Linux und Windows.
Ich habe auch unter Linux schon drei Passwort-Saves von meinem Team konvertiert.
Wunderbar, hat funktioniert.
Die Leute, die für diesen Passwort-Save-Umzug zuständig sind,
fanden das auch sehr nice, dass es dieses Programm gibt.
Da gibt es aber das nächste Problem.
Die wollen das ja unter Windows ausführen.
Beziehungsweise die Leute, die Passwort-Saves konvertieren müssen,
müssen es unter Windows ausführen.
und da hat uns unsere Security den nächsten Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht.
Die haben gesagt, wir können nicht einfach irgendwelche Software auf Windows ausführen.
Die Software muss erst unseren internen Zertifizierungsprozess durchlaufen.
Und das war allen logischerweise etwas zu viel Aufwand für so ein Ding,
was jetzt mal für ein paar Wochen gebraucht wird und dann nicht wieder.
Daraufhin haben wir uns überlegt, man könnte doch einfach...
man könnte doch einfach ein web interface ich schäme mich ja fast schon ein bisschen das web
interface zu nennen ja man könnte doch ein web interface programmieren wo man seine alte passwort
datei hoch lädt sein passwort eingibt und dann die neue passwort datei runtergeladen wird konvertiert
dann braucht man keine Windows-Software.
Und das wollte ich mal ausprobieren heute.
Und es funktioniert auch soweit schon,
bis auf den eigentlichen Konvertiervorgang.
Ja, ja, wenn man das so...
In welchem Chat bin ich denn da?
Bitte schön.
Wer ist das denn?
Habe ich den letztens mal gehostet oder was?
Den habe ich letztens mal gehostet.
Deswegen ist das hier noch drin.
Ich wundere mich schon, warum der Chat hier nichts
schreibt.
Als WebAssembly
komplett im Browser.
Oh Gott. Ja.
Das stimmt. Das wäre nochmal
Next Level.
das wäre nochmal richtig, richtig
high IQ.
Aber nur wenn der Netzwerk Traffic verschlüsselt ist,
sonst kriegt die Security den nächsten
Herzinfarkt.
Naja.
Da muss einfach nur
irgendein Reverse Proxy davor.
Oder wir müssen Go mit irgendeinem
Self-Sign-Zertifikat starten oder so.
Aber das
würde ich nicht zu meinem Problem machen.
Weil ich einfach sagen würde,
ey, weißt ihr was?
Ihr Software, die unter Linux läuft, um das Zertifikat kümmert ihr euch.
So.
War das ausführlich genug erklärt?
Napertox.
Ich erfahre nur das Passwort zum Passwort-Save.
Aber natürlich könnte ich das mitlocken.
Wenn ich die Anwendung so bauen würde.
Aber nachdem die Anwendung
der Source-Code
bei uns intern im GitLab liegen wird,
plus die Anwendung
über eine GitLab-CI gebaut wird,
würde ich mal sagen, die sind damit
fein, dass da kein
Keylogger drin ist.
Und wisst ihr was?
Selbst, wenn die sagen,
ist uns immer noch zu unsicher,
dann hatten wir wenigstens ein nice Projekt, mal
wieder für einen Stream zum Basteln.
Letztendlich ist mir das persönlich ja egal.
Ganz ehrlich,
wenn die das alles nicht wollen,
Dann gibt es da Leute, die 2000 Passwörter copy-pasten müssen.
Nicht mein Problem. Ich kann es unter Linux ja immer noch ausführen.
Über eine Dependency? Ja, das denkst aber auch nur du.
Selbstverständlich ist ja jede Dependency ausführlich reviewed.
Ne, aber das ist tatsächlich so, ich kann intern gar nicht irgendwelche Libraries von GitHub oder so ziehen als Dependencies.
Ich muss das über einen Proxy machen.
Und der Proxy, der scannt schon auf irgendwelche bekannten Schwachstellen und erlaubt dir es zur Not, nicht runterzuladen.
Also das geht über, kennt ihr Artifactory, Chatge?
auch in so ein business enterprise ding kennt das jemand da drüber muss ich
meine abhängigkeiten ziehen wenn die abhängigkeiten nicht darüber gezogen
werden geht es nicht oder naja sagen wir so ich bin admin und kann es das hart
tun also theoretisch wird es wahrscheinlich schon irgendwie gehen
ok machen wir mal weiter jetzt müssen wir noch die also eigentlich
müssen wir jetzt in Anführungszeichen nur noch
die Dateien konvertieren.
Also, dann brauche ich jetzt hier erstmal diese komische
Uralt-Library.
Die da.
Heatsinks PW-Save.
Elf Jahre
ist die Anwendung. Ist die Library alt?
Ähm.
Chat? Ich hab ein Problem.
Ich hab vergessen, wie ich das gemacht hab
mit dem Einbinden. Das war nämlich,
das ist nämlich schon so alt,
das ist keine
Go-Mod-Geschichte.
Das sind irgendwelche Krypto-Sachen
oder so, das juckt nicht.
War das einfach mit Go-Get?
Kann das sein?
Go-Get?
Ah ja.
Okay.
So war das. Und jetzt kann ich einfach sagen,
PW-Save.
Beat.
Äh.
Nee, Import.
Beat.
Oder so.
Und jetzt?
PW-Save?
Ah, hier, so hat es funktioniert.
Okay.
Genau, jetzt muss ich hier meine Passwortsave-Datei irgendwie öffnen.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal?
PW-Save?
Open?
Nee.
PW-Save?
Pass, File
Input, File
Moment
Ey, sag bloß, das kann nur
aus einem, nur ein File öffnen
Da muss ich das File vorher temporär
speichern, was nicht schlimm ist
Das ist ja immer noch verschlüsselt, das ist vollkommen
okay
Pass File
Gibt es nicht einfach
Das ist natürlich doof
Aber Pass File
Der muss doch intern
Ich muss mal angucken wie das intern programmiert ist
Open File und dann sagt er
Read
New Reader
Aber es geht auch noch mit File
Das ist ja dumm
Okay, ich sehe, dass wir doch etwas
Ey, New Reader
Okay
Aber das ist in der Tat ziemlich dumm
Und das ist klein geschrieben, da habe ich keinen Zugriff drauf.
Ähm.
Ich muss das hier verwenden.
Mit Input-File.
Aber ich habe keinen File.
Ich habe nur die Bytes im RAM.
OS Open Input File.
Kann OS Open auch...
Okay, ich brauche nur irgendwas, was File implementiert, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Es muss also gar kein...
...richtiges File sein.
Ja?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Also das heißt,
eigentlich
header open.
Eigentlich ist das hier genau das Richtige,
was ich haben will, oder?
Ich will da eigentlich direkt das Pfeil reingeben.
So.
So, den Rest können wir uns eigentlich sparen.
So, bam.
Hier, Pfeil.
Oder wie?
Warte mal, ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen verwirrt.
Was ist denn das hier für eine komische?
Es gibt ein
Pfeil zurück.
Ein Pfeil was? Ein Interface-Pfeil
gibt es zurück.
Okay.
Also einfach so?
Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Wie funzt das?
Es muss doch ein String sein.
Pass File.
Aber wo steht denn, dass es ein String sein muss?
Das steht hier doch nirgendwo.
Nee, es muss
ein String sein.
Okay.
String gilt für beide.
Oh, fuck.
Dann kann ich, okay, dann
muss ich es wieder rückgängig machen.
Okay, dann geht das doch nicht.
Boah, das ist ja reudig, Alter.
Das ist ja richtig dumm.
Das fangt mich jetzt aber ab.
Ich meine, das ist nicht schlimm, das ist ja noch verschlüsselt, aber...
Da muss ich irgendeine Datei...
Kann man...
Okay, kann man... Warte mal.
Golang named pipe.
Mit einem Pfeil.
Geht das?
Okay, es gibt was für Windows.
Oh, das ist ja schon wieder doof.
Das macht es dann schon wieder nicht mal richtig sportabel alles.
Wenn ich da eine Datei speichern muss.
Okay, Leute, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Ähm.
My Code Now
My Code Now, TriHat machen wir
TriHat
Ich kopiere mir den ganzen
Krempel hier einfach
Und füge da was hinzu
Machen wir einfach hier pw-save.
Wir klonen das uns hier einfach rein.
Git clone.
So.
Machen wir das mal kurz weg hier.
pw-save.
Genau.
Jetzt hat er das hier aus meiner Anwendung.
Und jetzt
pw-save-pass-file
Wir forken uns das jetzt.
So.
Nehmen das da.
Pass.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Stream.
Was weiß ich, wie man das nennt.
Und jetzt
io-reader
Ja.
Bam.
My code now.
Moment, das funktioniert ja nicht.
Moment, da muss ich ein bisschen anpassen.
Ein bisschen anpassen muss ich es anscheinend schon noch.
Also in File.
Es gibt kein File.
New Reader.
Hier, das muss aber funzen.
Genau.
Easy.
Unreachable Code.
Warum?
Achso, weil hier nirgends wo ein Break drin ist.
Soll mir recht sein, ich muss da jetzt gar nicht
so dran rumwurschteln.
Jaja.
Get it us.
Ich will die uralten Libraries.
Okay, zack.
Oh, sag bloß, das gibt's nicht mehr.
Was?
Hm.
Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Äh, irgendwie
funzt das Ding nicht. Warum?
Was ist, was ist das Problem?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
pw safe imports
ach gott das c
ganz ehrlich
das cmd
das kann ich komplett
wegschmeißen
das juckt mich überhaupt nicht
ich glaube jetzt hat das
ok
sehr gut
excellent
So, Pass, Stream
IO, Reader
Wie kann ich einen IO Reader von einem
Moment, eigentlich will ich doch hier selbst einen IO Reader
Reader
Und dann hier hinten
Pass
Einmal in den Pass-File, Pass-Stream.
Okay.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist gut.
Das hier wollen wir nicht.
Ich kann direkt File hier reinpacken.
Genau.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
So, stream
Save
If error ungleich 0, dann bam
Ups
Dann bam, so
Alles klar
So, also wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe
Dann sollte das funktionieren
Checken wir doch mal hier. Print.
Wenn er jetzt irgendwas ausgibt mit dem Save,
dann sollte es eigentlich klappen.
Wonkes.
Curl.
Geht.
Easy.
Way too easy.
Okay, erstmal schön den Kram geklaut.
Brauche ich das Vendor verzeichnet überhaupt noch?
Egal.
Das juckt mich jetzt nicht.
Ich lasse es einfach da.
Ähm.
Hä, da hat er es doch hinkopiert.
Kann das sein, dass er dieses Vendor-Ding überhaupt nicht...
Das muss ich jetzt gerade mal was checken, Leute.
Wenn ich das umbenenne, geht es dann immer noch?
Was?
Okay, Moment.
Ähm.
Move.
PW Save.
Vendor.
Nach, hier, besser Name.
So muss das heißen.
R.
Jetzt funktioniert immer noch.
Das geht ohne dieses komische Vendor Verzeichnis sogar.
Also easy.
Also können wir uns das schenken.
Das hier.
alles deleten. Weg damit.
Okay.
Also, so. Jetzt müssen wir
es konvertieren.
Wir lesen jetzt hier die ganzen Sachen
aus. Jetzt haben wir hier einen Save gepasst.
So, was können wir mit diesem Save machen?
Records
for each
Record
Index
Aha
Print
Okay, da können wir jetzt gucken
Also
Gehen wir mal das Passwort aus
Die Gruppe
Und den Username
Das ist ja glaube ich auch
Ist ja auch das einzige, was wir gesetzt haben, oder?
Oder haben wir noch mehr gesetzt?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so zur Auswahl?
Titel haben wir noch
Haben wir aber glaube ich nicht gesetzt
Okay, schauen wir mal
Doch, guck mal, haben wir alles jetzt
0blubqchat123 ist das Passwort
Sehr gut
Okay, auslesen funktioniert
Das heißt, jetzt müssen wir doch eigentlich nur
Eine Keypass-Datei erstellen
Also einfach nur
Wie geht das jetzt?
Das habe ich schon mal gemacht, aber ich weiß das jetzt nicht mehr.
Hier, Go Keeper Slip, das habe ich verwendet.
Da war auch ein Example drin.
Writing File.
Genau, so ging das irgendwie.
Diese komischen Funktionen habe ich gebraucht, warum auch immer.
Ich kopiere die mir hier einfach raus, weil irgendwelche Kunden brauche ich die.
Die zwei Dinger brauchen wir noch.
Fix missing dependencies.
Bam.
So.
Und jetzt müssen wir eine Keypass-Datei erzeugen.
Also.
Master Password File.
File.
Okay, okay, okay.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Ich glaube
Wie macht man das jetzt am besten
Weil ich brauche ja auch
File Name und so
Na gut, dann
Gibt es hier halt noch ein paar
Options
File Name
Was
Komm scheiß drauf
Warum sollten wir es ordentlich machen
Open, PW, Save.
Return, Save.
Wir machen das eigentlich einfach...
Wir machen das einfach hier drinnen.
Falsch.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Moment, das Return nichts.
Save.
Achso, ja.
Wir könnten aber natürlich auch
ein Save und ein Error returnen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser.
Error.
Jetzt returnen wir hier
einen Save und ein FMT.
Error.
Wobei, wir geben einfach den Error hier zurück.
Ja.
Ja, ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoller.
Und jetzt gibt es keinen Error hier.
Und wir können uns das hier copy-pasten.
Wie gesagt, Go-Code besteht zu 50% immer aus Error-Handling.
Save.
Okay, dann machen wir das einfach inline hier drinnen.
Ist doch viel besser.
also ein name für kippers ist eigentlich ganz einfach weil name oder wenn wir hier
kbdx fall name ist ein name kriegen wir doch hier oben schon guck mal heda im
heller steht das doch drin oder im fall selber müsste es auch schon drin ist
oder? File? Ne.
Header?
File name.
Plus
Punkt KDBX.
So machen wir das.
Das ist im Prinzip exakt das gleiche. File name.
Nur mit einer neuen Endung.
Für den Keypass.
So, dann brauchen wir jetzt noch
Master Passwords. Auch okay.
Master Password.
Haben wir hier oben schon. Passwort.
Passwort ist Passwort.
Wir könnten noch eine Sache checken.
Eine Sache sollten wir noch checken.
If
Passwort
leer.
Übrigens, Chat.
Was ist die
korrekte Variante in Go?
Um zu checken, ob ein Passwort leer ist.
So oder
Länge
gleich 0.
Ich persönlich bevorzuge ja
Das hier
Weil es irgendwie klarer zu lesen ist
Äh
Alles gut
Oder kann man
Kann man eigentlich auch so machen in Go?
Ne, ne, das geht nicht
Okay, save
Pfeil nehmen, Passwort, Hammer
Okay, weiter im Text
Jetzt müssen wir
Pfeil create
Ne, das wollen wir ja überhaupt nicht
Moment
Geht das auch wieder nur in den Pfeil rein?
Ich will das doch im Memory machen
machen.
Röhre ist auch gleich leer.
Ich auch.
Was noch passiert hier mit
Hood Group? New Group?
Okay, also
das erste Mal brauchen wir das hier.
Hood Group.
Hood.
Entry.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, Entry.
Entries wollen wir jetzt ja
eine Schleife hier drüber machen.
Save.
Records.
For loop.
Okay, so.
Jetzt wollen wir die Keypass-Datei anlegen.
Oder besser gesagt,
die Sachen konvertieren.
Also.
Entry. Hier.
Sowas wollen wir haben.
Keepers new entry.
Entry values.
Oh, das ist diese eklige
Go append Geschichte.
Das finde ich immer richtig abartig.
Aber geht halt nur so.
Append Title.
Title ist
Record Title.
So. Username
ist
Record Username.
Passwort ist
Record Passwort.
So, und was hatten wir jetzt noch?
Was gab es sonst noch? Record?
Group Titel.
Ah!
Die Group.
Wie kriegen wir die Group denn?
Das heißt, wir müssen hier drinnen...
Okay, das testen wir gleich. Erstmal gucken, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Wir müssen quasi noch hier drinnen
dann eine Gruppe anlegen,
falls sie noch nicht existiert.
Okay, das gucken wir dann.
Das gucken wir dann nach.
Jetzt haben wir hier für jeden
Entry Append.
So, wie geht es weiter? Subgroup brauchen wir nicht.
und jetzt wird es hier angehängt
Root Group Entries
Append
hier unseren Passwortkrempel
das brauchen wir nicht
keine Subgroup
und hier wird die Datei erstellt
so wie es aussieht
so wie ich das sehe
ah
hier wird es erst in die Datei geschrieben
Ich will es halt nicht in den File schreiben, ne?
Ich will es halt nicht in den File schreiben.
Ich will es in RAM schreiben.
Das Errorhandling macht mich teilweise schon fertig, Lingo.
Ja, es ist kein neues.
So, Masterpasswort.
Passwort wollen wir haben.
Hier.
Das gleiche Passwort wie beim anderen auch.
Bla bla bla bla.
Das kaufen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Das stimmt so.
Was genau wird das für ein Tool und welchen Zweck dient es?
Okay, ich erzähle es nochmal, weil es noch ein paar neue Leute dabei gekommen sind.
Also.
Wir haben jetzt aber schnell durchgegangen, weil ich habe es glaube ich schon dreimal erzählt, diesen Stream.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit verwenden sie dieses Tool hier zum Passwort storen.
Jetzt ist ihnen allerdings aufgefallen, dass es doch nicht so geil ist, weil die Software ist auch schon 20 Jahre alt, 25 Jahre alt und jetzt wollen sie zu KeePass wechseln.
Ursprünglicher Plan war, man exportiert das einfach hier raus als CSV, importiert es in KeePass und gut ist.
Man hat allerdings die Rechnung ohne die Security gemacht.
Die Security hat gesagt, ihr dürft die Passwörter nicht im Klartext exportieren, um sie dann zu importieren.
Das ist verboten.
Und jetzt hatten sie das Problem, wie machen wir das dann?
weil manche Leute haben Passwort-Saves mit 2000 Passwörtern oder sowas drin,
über 20 Jahre angesammelt.
Also bin ich hergegangen, ursprünglich eigentlich für mich selber,
und habe ein Programm erstellt in Go,
was eine Passwort-Save-Datei nimmt und eine Keypass-Datei daraus erzeugt
und das halt im Arbeitsspeicher entschlüsselt und neu verschlüsselt,
also ohne das irgendwie zwischenzuspeichern.
So, fanden sie eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich habe das Ganze kompiliert als Windows-Programm, als Linux-Programm.
Unter Linux habe ich auch schon drei Saves konvertiert.
Funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Tut, ja.
Unter Windows, achso ja, und dann habe ich es an die geschickt, an die Leute geschickt,
die zuständig sind für diese Passwort-Save-Migration.
Ich habe auch gesagt, richtig nice.
Problem ist jetzt nur, Security macht Ihnen wieder einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Sie können nicht einfach Windows-Software ausführen,
ohne dass die unseren internen Zertifizierungsprozess durchlaufen hat.
und da hat natürlich keiner Bock drauf und ich auch nicht.
Und jetzt sind wir auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
wir könnten doch einfach,
das auf dem Linux laufen lassen,
aber mit einem Webinterface,
wo man sein altes Passwort-Safe hochlädt,
Passwort eintippt
und dann die Datei als Download wieder bekommt.
Also quasi das, was man mit dem Windows-Tool hätte machen können,
nur über einen Browser.
Und das machen wir gerade
Jetzt sind wir gerade dabei
Passwort Save to Keypass zu konvertieren
Hat man das verstanden Stockbrot?
Das war jetzt wirklich die Kurzvariante
Weil ich schon so oft erzählt habe heute
So jetzt kriegen wir hier
Neuen Keypass
Neue Keypass Datei
Die müssen wir jetzt ja aber noch irgendwie
Speichern
Aber speichern in RAM und nicht auf die Disk.
New Encoder.
Aha, ein I.O. Writer.
Das ist gut.
I.O. Writer kann auch in RAM gehen, glaube ich.
Wie auch immer.
I.O. Writer.
Byte Writer.
String Writer.
Vielleicht.
Ne, äh, okay, keine Ahnung.
weiter
bytes buffer new buffer
new buffer string
ja und was macht das jetzt
Und das implementiert, das implementiert aber auch nicht Writer, Reader, oder?
New Reader.
Wüsste?
Okay, das heißt, ich sag jetzt hier einfach
Byte
Und dann
Jetzt
256, oh ne, wie ist da die richtige
Sonntagsführer-Frage
Ähm, warte mal, das war
Doch, ich weiß, wie das ist
Ähm
Oh, Scheiße
Make, make, genau
make
was ist denn da?
4.690? Keine Ahnung, das ist eine gute
Größe, ne? Das weiß ich jetzt halt
im Vorfeld nicht.
Ähm
Keine Ahnung, ähm
Ein Gig
512 MB to Bytes
So
Ich finde dieses Windows-Ding teilweise echt abfuck.
Ja, 128.
Genau.
Ja, da kann ich eigentlich... Moment, Moment.
Ja, ja, so.
So, das 128 MB für ein Passwort-Serv soll doch eigentlich reichen, oder?
Und das implementiert
Ryder?
Das implementiert Ryder!
Meinst du, man kann da auch null?
Das wäre auch interessant, ob das geht.
Ach.
Was machst du? Darf man das überhaupt?
Nein, das ist ganz
schlimm dafür.
Da muss man Strafe bezahlen, wenn man das macht.
Oder was meinst du denn?
Was darf man überhaupt?
Unschlau von dir.
Ja.
Schon ganz schön dumm, ne?
Quatsch, da muss man keine Strafe bezahlen
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was du meinst
Meinst du, dass ich im Stream was programmiere, was für die Arbeiten nützlich ist?
Oder was?
Ne, das ist nicht verboten
Das ist ja keine Arbeitszeit
Jeder kann auch deine Sachen nachmachen
Ja gut, das ist ja nicht...
Juckt mich nicht, ob das einer nachmacht.
Nichts Verbotenes dabei.
Zu sehen hier.
Vielleicht upload ich sogar auf GitHub.
Dann kann es jeder sogar direkt forken.
Ich glaube, Christoph denkt, du machst da auf Hackerman.
Achso, nee.
Mach ich nicht.
Wobei, eigentlich machen wir immer auf Hackerman, oder?
Was programmierst du?
Okay, ich hab's jetzt viermal erklärt.
Ich überlasse es jetzt dem Chat, das zu erklären.
Nochmal.
Ganz kurz, in einem Satz gesagt.
Ein Tool, was Passwort-Safe-Dateien nach Keypass konvertieren kann.
Mit Web-Interface.
Waffe.
encode db
Okay, so.
Und jetzt muss ich diesen Buffer
hier zurückwriten, oder?
Das geht aber nicht.
Ähm.
Und warum nicht?
Weil, ah, bytes.
Bytes.
Also muss ich jetzt sagen, I owe read.
Read all bytes.
Oder so.
Irgendwie so.
Weiz.
So.
Okay, dann die übliche
Go-Error-Handling-Geschichte.
Weiz.
Okay.
Und das...
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert, Leute.
KI hilft? Ich habe am Anfang des Streams versucht, über KI eine Go-Library zu... mir erstellen zu lassen. Das war eher Reinfall.
Na dann, wenn du meinst.
So.
Gucken wir mal.
Jetzt bin ich ja echt gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Achso, das sollten wir nicht beizen.
B, bester Benahmung, B.
Da weiß jeder sofort, was gemeint ist, oder?
So, dann wollen wir doch mal.
Best declared and not used.
Achso.
Ah.
Achso, Moment, Moment, Moment
File Name, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, hier, da
File Name
Echt, was habt ihr jetzt genommen?
Wenn ihr nicht Keypass habt
Also ich bin privat auch Keypass
Enjoyer
So, Chat
Chat, jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt, ob das
funktioniert. Also, ich
upload jetzt mein Passwort-Save mit
dem Passwort. Super highly secure Passwort.
Bitworn.
So.
Gucken wir mal. Error.
Error on write
auf 300...
1326 Bytes.
Okay.
Achso, wahrscheinlich, weil ich nirgendswo eine Datei angegeben habe.
Äh, Output.
Machen wir mal Output.
pw-save-dings-keydb.
Hat funktioniert.
Okay, Chat, jetzt kommt die Preisfrage.
Wenn ich das Ding jetzt mit Keypass öffne, meint ihr, es hat funktioniert oder nicht?
Meint ihr, da sind die Passwörter drin?
Nee.
Safe.
Dass es kompiliert heißt ja noch lange nicht,
dass es funktioniert.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Wayland does not support.
Ja, Wayland ist Wayland.
Bam.
Guck mal da.
Passwort.
Highly secure.
Titel steht drin, Username steht drin, Passwort steht drin.
Funktioniert.
Exzellent.
Exzellent, exzellent.
So, dann fehlt jetzt eigentlich nur noch eine Sache.
Schön ist es nicht, oder?
Schönheitspreis wird das Ding hier nicht gewinnen.
Vor allem wir.
Kleinste Funktion ever.
Wobei, es gibt durchaus Schlimmeres.
So, eine Sache müssen wir jetzt noch machen.
Und zwar,
das mit den Gruppen, guckt mal
ähm
es ist ja so
ich öffne nochmal das Keypass
Keypass-File
so, guckt mal, das ist jetzt alles in dieser
Root-Gruppe, das ist ja eigentlich falsch
wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich das
wenn wir uns das gleiche Passwort-File
nochmal angucken
im Passwort-Save
dann sehen wir, guckt mal da
eigentlich gibt es eine Gruppe
Cute-Chat
und da drinnen
sind dann erst die Passwörter.
So, also wir müssen jetzt noch eine Gruppe,
noch die Gruppe anlegen
und es könnte ja auch mehrere,
oh, das müssen wir noch testen.
Das könnte jetzt, oh, jetzt wird es eklig.
Warte mal, lass mal kurz chatten.
lesen
ja 50% error handling
okay wir müssen so was testen und zwar wenn ich das jetzt hier an passe wir
machen mal, wir machen mal hier
nochmal eine Gruppe,
die heißt jetzt hier
RF-Programmer. Das kann ich aber noch
am Start ist. Neues Entry,
Titel, Username, Passwort.
Okay, Passwort.
Mal sehen, was passt hier. Zack.
So, und jetzt
testen wir mal was. Untergruppe nämlich.
Untergruppe.
Kappa HD.
New Entry
ABC
Okay
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie er das
handelt, weil das wird nicht richtig
Der checkt das ja mit den Gruppen nicht
So, jetzt würde ich das nochmal kurz
Copy-Pasten
Dahin
Curlen
Die Pass öffnen
Ja, guckt
Der kopiert einfach nur die Passwörter
Und er interessiert sich nicht für die Gruppen
Also wie ich gedacht hab
Das heißt
Mr. Freezei, danke schön für den Sub
Ne, nicht Freezei
Doch
Free, easy
schön dass du da bist schön dass ihr alle da seid exzellent
genau ich mache nur die gut group genau da müssen wir gucken wie wir das wie wir das hinkriegen wie
viel interessanter wie macht er das denn mit nested gruppen lasst uns das kann mal printen
Entry
Entry Punkt
Ne, Moment, nicht Entry
Record Punkt Group
Wir printen mal kurz die Gruppe
Ob das jetzt Nested Group sind
Oder wie der das macht, müssen wir mal schauen
Ah ne, guck mal
Der macht sich das Leben einfach
Der macht die Gruppen einfach
Mit einem Punkt dazwischen
Also man weiß gar nicht
dass das hier die Untergruppe davon ist
und sowas.
Ah ja, soll mir recht sein. Ganz ehrlich,
soll mir recht sein.
Wir bauen da jetzt nichts ein, was
nestet Gruppen irgendwie kann.
Das ist mir zu dumm.
Das machen wir nicht.
Wir legen jetzt
für jedes dieser Dinger
eine eigene Gruppe an.
Und...
Wie machen wir das jetzt eigentlich
gescheit?
Guck mal hier.
Subgroup.
Wenn ich jetzt hier einfach
eine Subgroup anlege, ja?
Mit, ähm...
Record.group.
Dann legt er ja im Zweifelsfall die Gruppe mehrfach an.
Das müssen wir auch noch kurz checken.
Ob er das macht oder wie er das macht.
Wir erstellen jetzt hier mal unter Kappa HD.
Erstellen wir jetzt mal ein weiteres Entry.
Oh, machen zu, kopieren das.
Curlen das.
Öffnen das den Keypass.
Da sieht man ja noch nichts.
Hier sieht man es. Guck mal.
Der würde das wahrscheinlich
einfach überschreiben. Ah, das ist
natürlich doof.
Der würde es dann einfach
überschreiben.
Also, brauche ich eine Map, oder?
Ich brauche
eine Map. Ich brauche
einen Dictionary.
Mit den Gruppennamen.
Und als Key...
Ne, als Key den Gruppennamen.
Und dann immer jeweils nur einmal anlegen, falls es das schon gibt.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Jaja, genau.
Ja, so in so einer Richtung habe ich mir das jetzt auch schon gedacht.
Also.
Ähm.
Warte mal.
Groups.
Make.
Ne, wie geht das? Map, oder?
So. Oh, guck mal, der ist richtig schlau.
Der weiß ja schon, was er haben will.
Und jetzt.
For.
Machen wir nochmal das hier.
Record in Records.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht fällt euch ja was ein,
wie man es besser machen kann.
So, also, vor
ist noch die Records nochmal.
Record, Group,
so, Groups,
so, und da fügen wir jetzt ein,
wie war das hier mit Subgroup,
Subgroup,
Groupname,
nochmal so,
und dann
Subgroup. So, jetzt
kriegen wir einen Array, wo nur alle
Gruppen einmalig drin
sind.
Äh, by the way, wo ist
das Problem?
So. Ah ja.
Als Pointer. Ist auch sinnig.
Werden C-Sharp WPF-Programme
in der echten Welt genutzt? Ja.
Ja, ja. Total viele.
So gerade so viele Business
business alter business enterprise windows und die stelle ist das teil viel
mpf wpf ist ja auch wenn man ehrlich ist das letzte usable windows toolkit das
gefrickelt danach kannst ja komplett knicken
wpf ist aber halt richtig outdated aber funzt eigentlich ganz brauchbar
solange interop mit neuen sachen brauchst ist schwierig ich hab mal ich
habe mal versucht ein video anzuzeigen in wpf und das ohne touring und alles das war richtig eklig
du musstest irgendwie dem dem sagen weil wpf selbst rennt hat ja glaube ich auf directx basis
und muss es dann irgendwie sagen on refresh musste sich den neuen frame pullen oder war
abartig aber aber muss ehrlich sagen also windows also wpf das das funktioniert ja aber das ist alles
das ist richtig alt ich persönlich mag windows forms wenn man einfach nur fenster braucht und
darin irgendwas malen will wenn man deshalb beispiels war auch nicht diese ganzen alten
Windows Forms Controls und so braucht, ja.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich
ähm, bleiben wir mal
bei Video abspielen, Video, Video
Overlay oder so, da ist
Windows Forms gut, das kümmert sich ums
Window Management, da machst du den Hintergrund
transparent und dann renderst du da rein
und gut ist. Die
ollen Windows Controls, ja,
dieses, sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Und wirklich schön stylen kann man
Windows Forms
nicht, das geht mit WPF besser,
aber WPF, wie gesagt, ich persönlich finde WPF
auch nicht so geil ich krieg anfälle bei diesem xml kram was das gleiche problem
auch bei avalon ja ist aber in der heutigen zeit wenn ich in windows oder
sagen wenn ich ein dotnet gui machen würde dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich
in avalon ja machen weil avalon ja ist das einzige was es gibt windows only
könntest du WinUI von Microsoft verwenden, aber das benutzt Microsoft nicht immer selbst.
Gescheit.
Es bleibt dir eigentlich nur Avalonia, so richtig.
Und Avalonia hat auch gleichzeitig den Vorteil,
es läuft unter Windows und Linux und Mac.
Und ich habe gelesen,
mit Avalonia kannst du mittlerweile auch
Maui unter der Haube verwenden,
für Mobile Apps.
Ob man das wirklich machen will,
lass ich mal dahingestellt.
Weil ich mach um alles, wo Maui dran steht,
einen ganz großen Bogen.
XCapt.
Dankeschön.
Pog Subscription.
Schön, dass du am Start bist.
Ne, Windows Forms.
Die können Windows Forms nicht sterben lassen.
Was ich damit meine ist, Windows Forms ist ja keine eigene Technologie in dem Sinn.
Windows Forms ist ein Wrapper um die Native Win32 Controls.
Und die wird es immer in Windows geben. Immer.
Weil sonst Windows nicht mehr funktionieren würde.
Das heißt dementsprechend kann Windows Forms gar nicht sterben.
Weil die zugrundeliegenden Controls nie sterben werden.
Weil Windows dann nicht mehr funktionieren würde.
Avalonia ist schwer mit Third-Party-Support.
Damit kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Ehrlich gesagt,
also ich bin ja auch kein, nur falls das den Eindruck
entweckt, muss ich das jetzt nochmal sagen.
Ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Anwendungsentwickler.
Und ich habe auch noch keine
größere Avalonia-App programmiert.
Nur ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt.
Ja, Microsoft ist ja hart dabei,
Windows-Sachen in React weiterzuentwickeln.
Weiter.
Sorry, ich nehme das zurück.
Weiterzuentwickeln ist...
Ich meine mit Weiterentwickeln einfach,
dass das ist, wo sie gerade dran entwickeln.
Von einer Weiterentwicklung kann man da nicht wirklich sprechen.
Also für alle, die es nicht wissen,
ich zeige es nochmal.
Die Swinoss-Startmenü und die Taskleiste
sind eine JavaScript-React-Anwendung.
Nur dass ihr es wisst
Das hat nichts mit Native Windows mehr zu tun
Das ist React
Warum?
Weil Microsoft
Microsoft ist
Und wahrscheinlich weil
AIs besser sind
Im JavaScript generieren
Wie in Windows Native Sachen
Ja, es sind jeden Stream
Wenn ich das sage, sind Leute überrascht
Aber ja, es ist so
Die Windows Tasklist und das Startmenü
Ist eine React Anwendung
Dann würden sie ja mal ihren eigenen Krempel verwenden
Wo hast du das gelesen, das React
Dass sie erkannt haben, dass React dafür Trash ist
Das glaube ich nicht
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich es sehe
Ähm
Ähm, Chat
Vielleicht sollten wir das hier mal kurz
Weiter machen, warte mal
Microsoft confirms...
Was? Was? Moment.
Microsoft confirms Windows 11 Startmenü
Performance Boost
shifts to WinUI from...
Wer hätte
das sich nur vorher denken können?
Ich habe das
vorher im anderen Browser aufgemacht.
Ich kontrolliere die Links immer, bevor ich
das aufmache.
Wer hätte damit nur rechnen können, dass ein Startmenü in React keine so geile Idee ist?
Der hätte man nie, chat, niemals hätte man da im Vorfeld drauf kommen können, oder?
Das heißt, es wird jetzt zum wievielten Male das Startmenü in die Taskleiste rewritten?
Das ist der siebte Rewrite oder so in Windows 11?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Und dann funktioniert wieder die Hälfte nicht.
Ich meine, es funktionieren jetzt ja schon so Sachen wie Track und Drop nicht mehr richtig.
Dann funktioniert wieder nichts.
Reduce Latency und Make OS viel faster.
Das Problem ist, dass sie das Vibe coden werden.
das ist das problem die ich sage euch die microsoft das macht die staaten
irgendwie 50 co-pilot agents und please port this app from react to dotnet
windows and use native when you are 3 think extra hard and make no errors make
no mistakes do not make mistakes und dann schicken die das ab und das ist eine
Woche rödeln und fertig ist das neue
Startmenü.
Stimmt!
Rewrite in Rust. Ja gut, theoretisch
kann man WinUI ja mit Rust
verwenden. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendjemand
schon mal gemacht hat, aber theoretisch geht das.
Alfred, bring die nicht auf Ideen.
Das wird früher oder später eh passieren, dass Copilot nicht mehr ausblendbar ist in der Startleiste.
Ich wollte gerade noch irgendeine Frage beantworten, die finde ich jetzt aber gerade nicht mehr.
Sekunde.
äh
Map doch die Gruppennamen
auf Liste von Entries, dann kannst du hinterher
die Gruppe mit allen Entries einfach rausschreiben
Moment, was? Moment, was?
Map doch die Gruppennamen auf Liste
von Entries
Ja, das geht ja in Go nicht
In Go ist es
Just use for loops
äh, for head
In Go kann sie nicht einfach sagen
hier Punkt Map oder sowas
Ich glaube, gab doch nichts mehr.
Kannst doch MapStringEntry machen?
Ne, ich brauch doch ne Map
Mit, mit, mit, mit Subgroups
Achso, Moment
Meinst du, meinst du, ich soll sowas hier machen?
Sowas vielleicht
Group Entry
Aber dann finden wir die Gruppe ja nicht mehr
Ne, das funzt net
Aber mach ich doch, guck mal
Also, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal
Wenn ihr eine bessere Idee habt, könnt ihr mir das gleich nochmal sagen
Also, Groobs, jetzt haben wir
Jetzt haben wir hier
Groobs mit
Ähm
Ich mach das jetzt
erste mal und dann können wir gucken okay so also jetzt habe ich hier eine
liste mit 1 also unique liste mit allen gruppen drin
so und jetzt sage ich
groups
das da
punkt
Warte mal, ich bin verwirrt.
Ach nee.
Hier.
So.
So?
Moment mal.
Hier, so.
So.
So, jetzt habe ich
den Kram angehängt.
Ne, Moment.
Doch, das ist richtig.
Jetzt habe ich das, die ganzen Einträge,
also wenn man mehr als einen Eintrag hat,
wird das hier angehängt.
Und was brauche ich jetzt noch?
Was brauche ich jetzt noch?
Brauche ich jetzt noch so irgendwie...
Achso, Hut.
Hoot Groups Append.
Das brauche ich jetzt noch.
Also quasi sowas hier.
Hoot Groups Append.
Äh.
Kann man mehrere Sachen
appenden?
Geht sowas irgendwie?
Ne, oder? Das funktioniert.
Lass ich jetzt irgendwie sagen
Values oder so. Ne, okay, da braucht ich
Moment, da muss ich jetzt nochmal loopen.
Muss ich jetzt nochmal loopen?
Äh, nicht record.
Moment, Moment, das ist falsch.
Sekunde, Krups.
Einfach Krups
Punkt Punkt schreiben mit drei Punkten, was?
Wirklich?
Hm?
Nee, das ist ja eine Map.
Ich müsste erst mal alle Values extrahieren, oder?
Wir können einfach so machen.
Coop.
Vor.
Bam.
Coop.
So.
Das müsste so auch funktionieren.
Das ist bestimmt nicht die schönste Variante.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert, was ich hier gestrickt habe.
Zack, hat funktioniert
Öffnen
Oh
Hups
Ähm, da ist jetzt nix drin
Da scheint irgendwas nicht ganz zu stimmen
Was ich gebaut hab, okay
Ähm, oh, Moment, was ist hier jetzt?
Ah
Die Referenzen
Hier noch
Okay
Noch mal starten hier
Easy
Guck mal da, es funktioniert
Jetzt hat zwar jede Gruppe hier so ein eigenes
Es gibt, Leute, ganz ehrlich
Scheiß auf nested groups
Können die Leute ja von Hand aufräumen danach
Weil Nested Groups wäre glaube ich noch größerer Abfuck
So Nested Sachen
Brauchen immer übelst viele
Gehirnwindungen
Ja, der müsste jetzt quasi gucken
Also der müsste jetzt
Genau, das Ding ist
Der müsste jetzt quasi gucken
Wenn er das hier findet, ne
Wenn er das hier findet
müsste er gucken,
gibt es das schon?
Und dann da drunter
eine Gruppe anlegen?
Gibt es das noch nicht?
Dann muss er rekursiv durchgehen,
bis er was findet oder das
oberste anlegen. Ne, da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Ne, ne, ne Leute,
ne.
Das war ich jetzt nett.
Das ist, das schafft mein Brain heute nicht mehr.
Also die Worte einfach und rekursiv zusammen ist schon cringe.
Weil die meisten rekursiven Sachen sind nicht einfach.
Mach Anti-Gravity auf.
Jiminy macht das fertig.
Muss man sich da einloggen für?
Ich wollte das letzte Mal AI-Studio benutzen, aber das hatte kein ordentliches Free-Tier mehr.
Da muss ich einloggen, ne?
Guck mal!
Der J-Law ist am Start!
Da muss ich einloggen.
Ne, jetzt habe ich keinen Bock
Das habe ich keinen Bock zu machen jetzt
Ne, ne, ne
Aber wisst ihr was noch viel schöner ist, Chat?
Wir sind jetzt ja prinzipiell
Erst einmal fertig
Ich habe jetzt noch
Massig Zeit
Lasst uns doch nochmal irgendwie
Ein bisschen zum Entspannen
Runde Videos gucken oder sowas
Oder wir könnten uns auch, wir könnten uns auch 1-2 Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Jetzt noch Single-Page-Application-Bau mit nicem UI.
Oh, das haben wir noch gar nicht getestet, ob das mit dem Browser funktioniert.
Das Wichtigste haben wir noch gar nicht ausprobiert. Sekunde.
Jetzt erst mal hier checken, ob das mit dem Browser geht.
hier. Localhost starten.
Zack. Browse.
PwSave. Passwort.
123456. Upload.
Ja.
Angeblich hat das
funktioniert. Downloads.
Was zum...
Was war das denn für ein
Ordner, bitteschön?
Moment.
Ich hab einen Ordner in meinem
Heimatverzeichnis der Tilde heißt?
Was?
Jetzt bin ich ziemlich verwirrt.
Das hat Open Code vorhin angelegt.
Was wird gemacht?
Pass auf.
Massive, massive geiles Webinterface.
schönste web interface aller zeiten du uploadest oder du gibst dem eine alte passwort save datei
gibt es ein passwort für ein und dann konvertierte die zu kieper so lädt die kieper datei runter
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert hat.
Keypass.
Ist das React?
Das ist, ähm...
React Angular Native.
Chat.
Chat CN.
Es hat gefunden, Leute.
Konvertierung erfolgreich.
Wobbly Windows.
Excellent
So, erstmal durchgedreht
Bisschen
Ne, kann ich dir nix
Kann ich dir nix empfehlen
Hast du Alter schon verified mit SystemD?
Du wirst ja nicht gezwungen dazu, das stellt ja nur eine Möglichkeit zur Verfügung, dass man das speichern kann und abfragen kann, falls Apps das machen wollen.
Kann man die Files nicht schon direkt als KDBX exportieren?
Ja doch, mach das doch.
Du uploadest das, der wandelt das um und downloadet es direkt als KDBX.
Oder meinst du, ob der Passwort-Safe das nicht schon direkt exportieren kann?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Aber da habe ich mich ja vorher schon drüber ausgelassen.
Da war es noch nicht da.
Also, ich sehe das auch kritisch, ja.
Streng für sich genommen ist diese Sache mit SystemD stellt eine Schnittstelle zur Verfügung,
wo man das Alter des Users abfragen kann, überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber ich sehe es generell kritisch, ja.
Genau, sehe ich genauso.
Ich sehe es generell kritisch, die Entwicklung, wenn man die sich mal weltweit anguckt, von Altersverifikation, Social Media Verbot für Jugendliche, teilweise irgendwelche Chatkontrollen, Klarnamen, Pflicht und was es nicht alles gibt, sehe ich allgemein kritisch.
Es ist ja immer das gleiche Schema, es wird gesagt, man möchte die Kinder beschützen, man möchte da besser gegen Terrorismus vorgehen können und sonst was und es werden irgendwelche Möglichkeiten geschaffen, die dann immer weiter ausgebaut werden, so nach dem Motto, ey, jetzt haben wir eine Möglichkeit zur Altersverifikation, können wir jetzt noch irgendwelche anderen Kontrollmechanismen einbauen und das wird gemacht, das hat man oft genug gesehen,
dass zweckgebundene oder Sachen angekündigt wurden, dass sie ganz klar zweckgebunden sind.
Zum Beispiel die Daten während Corona, die Restaurants, wer die Restaurants besucht hat,
haben sie gesagt, dass ganz klar, dass wir nur zum Nachverfolgen von Infektionsketten und sowas verwendet.
Und ein paar Monate später oder ein paar Wochen später kam die bayerische Polizei um die Ecke und hat gesagt,
ach ja, wir hätten da auch gerne Zugriff. Das ist jetzt für sich genommen nichts Schlimmes.
Aber man sieht, man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, wenn was angekündigt wird mit, wird nur dafür verwendet, dass es dabei auch bleibt.
Und deswegen finde ich es fragwürdig.
Und bin mir da auch nicht sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, solche Sachen einzuführen.
Also, wenn man sich das anguckt, eher nicht.
Ja, aber wo ist das Problem?
Ganz ehrlich, wenn das irgendwelche Seiten einführen, wo man größere Aktionen machen muss, da gehen die Leute halt zu anderen Seiten.
Richtig, richtig.
Deswegen sage ich ja auch immer, wenn es um die Diskussionen geht, ja, Passwörter, Passwortmanager, ich habe einen Passwortmanager, der synkt mit Cloud.
oder ja, ich uploade das ja, aber der Anbieter sagt, er uploadet das nur verschlüsselt
oder manche Leute ja, ja, ich verschlüssel das selbst, bevor ich die Sachen in die Cloud synke.
Es gibt, sobald die Daten raus sind, kann immer was passieren.
Das Beste ist, die Daten erst gar nicht rauszugeben.
Wisst ihr denn, mal angenommen, ihr seid wirklich Security bewusst, ja, und sagt,
hey, ich würde gerne Sachen in die Cloud synchen,
dass ich Zugriff von unterwegs habe
oder Zugriff von mehreren Rechnern an mehreren Standorten drauf habe,
synche ich das Ganze in die Cloud, aber ich verschlüssel das vorher selbst.
Das ist ja mit, sagen wir mal, mit so das Sicherste, was du machen kannst.
Du verschlüsselst die Sachen on the fly, lokal,
und dann werden die verschlüsselten Dateien erst in die Cloud hochgeladen.
So, das ist, sicherer kannst du es nicht machen.
Aber trotzdem, überlegt euch mal,
Ja, wer sagt euch denn, dass der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, das ist jetzt ein bisschen Kek-Alu, ja, gebe ich zu, ein bisschen Kek-Alu schwingt mit, okay?
Aber wer sagt euch denn, dass der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, den ihr heute benutzt, in 10, 15 Jahren immer noch sicher ist?
Vielleicht gibt es ja wirklich irgendwelche
Grundlegenden Sicherheitsprobleme
Bei dem Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
Den ihr verwendet
Ja
Und es gibt Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die wurden nie geknackt
Muss man auch dazu sagen, sowas wie 3DES
Oder 3DES, oder wie man es genau ausspricht
Wurden nie geknackt
Aber die Rechner wurden irgendwann so schnell
Dass man es gar nicht mehr knacken musste
sondern einfach durchprobieren konnte.
Ja, also
ein Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
würde ich sagen, gilt ja als
nur dann als geknackt,
wenn er, also wenn man
die
Anzahl der Versuche, die notwendig sind
im Vergleich zu Blutforce durchprobieren
deutlich reduzieren kann.
Dann sehe ich den als geknackt an.
Ja, den Algorithmus an sich.
Wenn die Rechner einfach nur schnell genug
sind, ja, dann ist das auch geknackt, aber nicht
die eigentliche Logik dahinter.
die ist nicht geknackt.
Es reicht einfach nicht mehr von der Schlüssellänge her.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Deswegen am besten ist,
wenn es nicht sein muss,
den Kram einfach erst gar nicht irgendwo hochladen.
Und wenn ihr der Meinung seid,
ihr braucht Offside-Backup,
das immer eine gute Idee ist.
Also Offside Backup ist prinzipiell
ja keine schlechte Idee.
Vielleicht
tut es ja auch
die Festplatte,
also die verschlüsselte, die vollverschlüsselte
Festplatte
im
Stall im Garten
oder so. Das wird dann
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht abbrennen, wenn
euer Haus abbrennt.
Aber wenn ihr es Cloud-mäßig Offsite backuppen wollt, dann ist selbst verschlüsseln mit AES
ordentlichem Schlüssel das sicherste was ihr machen könnt.
Und das ist schon ganz schön keck Alu, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass AES mit einem ordentlichen
Schlüssel bald nicht mehr sicher ist.
Also die Chancen sehe ich jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass AES 128, glaube ich, AES 128, glaubst du, sogar freigegeben ist für Top-Secret-Akten bei den Amis.
Also, so von wegen, morgen ist das Ganze knackbar, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Wenn das Haus abbrennt, hast du erstmal andere Probleme, aber richtig beschissen, wenn du dich dann nirgends wo einloggen kannst.
Deswegen ist so ein Offsite-Backup, und sei es nur, dass es im Stall liegt, nicht verkehrt.
Oder zumindest vielleicht auf dem verschlüsselten USB-Stick euren Passwortsafe im Rucksack haben oder sowas.
Sodass es nicht mit dem Haus abbrennt.
Zugang zu den Accounts
ist
immer doof, wenn man sie nicht mehr hat
da ist ja alles mögliche dabei
von der Bank, von der Versicherung, von der Krankenkasse
alles mögliche
also da ist das ganze digitale Leben drin
Deine Meinung, dass SSL
nur noch 50 Tage gültig ist
bei DigiCert
Ja, so kann doch Digi's heute machen, wie sie lustig sind
Bei
Überall? Okay
Naja
Achja
Aber das ist doch schon, das ist schon ein Jahr her
Und er hat so nichts getan
Ahja
Interessant
Das wusste ich gar nicht
Es gibt doch so viele Zertifikate, die ein Jahr und länger gültig sind.
Und wie ist das mit Kleinzertifikaten?
Ja gut, wenn ich eigene Kleinzertifikate ausstelle, die kann ich ja gültig machen, wie ich lustig
bin.
Ja, die kann ich ja machen, wie ich lustig bin.
wo ich die CA betreibe im Endeffekt.
Da kann ich ja machen, was ich will.
Aber, na gut, sagen wir mal ehrlich,
wenn so Sachen wie bei Let's Encrypt
zum Beispiel, ja, wenn ihr da einmal im Monat
erneuern müsst, ist ja eigentlich auch kein Problem.
Wenn man das automatisiert hat.
Das ist schon ein bisschen eklig, aber
ah ja.
Aber das ist interessant, das habe ich überhaupt nicht mitbekommen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das hat irgendwie bei uns noch keiner so richtig mitbekommen.
Das wird bestimmt auf der Arbeit ein bisschen Stress verursachen.
Jetzt nicht bei mir.
Ich habe da wenig mit zu tun, mit Zertifikatsmanagement-Kram.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand aktuell
AES knacken kann
Die meisten Probleme gibt es, wenn die Passwörter schlecht sind
Da rettet dich kein Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
Wenn dein Passwort sackt
Oder wenn dein Schlüssel sackt
Das ist ja auch das hauptsächliche Problem.
Und wenn du dein PC ordentlich verschlüsselt hast,
wenn du das mit Lux oder Linux oder mit Veracrypt unter Windows,
explizit sage ich jetzt mal nicht Bitlocker,
da kann eigentlich keiner wirklich was machen.
Aktuellen Stand der Technik.
Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand aktuell wirklich AES knacken kann.
Mit einem ordentlichen Schlüssel.
Die was?
Wer ist das denn?
Was soll denn dieses...
Für wen soll denn dieses Emoji stehen?
Für die China-Chinesen oder was?
Ich weiß.
Du meinst nur mein SSH-Key, ne?
Mein 10 Jahre alten SSH-Key.
Aber das war...
Da hatte ich doch letztes Mal nachgeguckt.
Das war doch nur in ganz speziellen Fällen so.
Hatten wir...
Das hatten wir doch schon mal im Stream.
ZFS.
Ja, ja, das war aber nur in ganz speziellen Fällen so.
Das hatten wir doch letztens in dem Stream sogar mal.
Guck mal mal.
Lux, Key, Dairy, Fate, Function.
Schreibt man das so?
Die sind allgemein angreifbar mit PCs die viel RAM haben.
Aha.
Also der Inventor von Lux sagt, so schlimm ist es gar nicht.
Wenn man ein ordentliches Passwort hat.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt noch Zeit.
die Programmierstelle.
Das haben wir eigentlich jetzt geschafft. Funktioniert.
Mal kurz gucken,
ob ich noch irgendwas übersehen habe. Also wenn ihr noch
irgendwas geschrieben habt, was ich nicht gesehen habe, dann
könnt ihr es nochmal mit
AdWub los schreiben. Chat, hat irgendjemand eine
Stellenanzeige, die wir uns
zusammen angucken wollen?
Oder eins,
zwei? Wir machen vielleicht am
Wochenende dann noch richtigen Stellenanzeigen-Streamer.
Wir könnten uns ja heute schon mal welche angucken.
Meinung zu Talescale.
Ehrlich gesagt,
keine Ahnung.
Ich hab Talescale selbst noch nie
benutzt, noch nie verwendet.
Keine Ahnung.
Vom Ansatz her, dass du quasi so ein...
Also, ich weiß ja nicht mal, wie es richtig funktioniert.
Aber so vom Ansatz her, was ich in Videos
gesehen hab, dass du dann quasi
kein Public Port mehr hast,
sondern die so eine Art
VPN-Mesh oder irgendwie sowas bauen.
immer eine muss halt cloudflare trusten vom ansatz her dass du da keine offenen
ports mehr für vpn brauchst du eigentlich ganz nice aber ich kann ich
keine ahnung ich habe es noch nie benutzt
ist das da wo du arbeitest oder wie kommst du da so schnell drauf
dann halte ich mich auch mit geflaggt bis zurück
wobei wenn die stellenanzeige gut es gibt ja auch nichts zu flamen
Okay, dann gucken wir
Komm, wir gucken mal
Demando
Wir sind ihre IT-Macher.
Okay, das geht ja schon gut los.
Okay.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Erstmal den Dark-Mode ausmachen.
Das interessiert die Webseite überhaupt nicht.
Ah, jetzt. Okay.
Also, wir sind die IT-Macher.
Werde ein IT-Macher.
Fachkräfte.
Boah, du rufst an.
Guck mal, Azubi stellst.
SAP im Morgen-KS, Alter.
Was ist denn I?
MWD kenne ich ja.
Aber was ist I?
MWD, wie gehabt, männlich-weiß-deutsch.
Invers?
Keine Ahnung.
Ah
Inter
Okay
Trainee zur SAP Anwendungsberatung
Oh, da kriegst du Anfälle
Nein, please, kein SAP
Aber wer Bock drauf hat, ne? Also warum nicht
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Informationssicherheitsbeauftragter
SAP, gibt es da auch irgendwas, wozu ich was sagen kann?
HANA
Das sehe ich immer nur, wenn irgendwas
Bauchschmerzen verursacht
Dann hat das meistens was mit SAP HANA zu tun
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist. Ich weiß nur, dass das irgendwelche SAP-Geschichten sind.
Da kannst du irgendwie so eigene Anwendungen drin bauen oder so.
Muss ganz merkwürdig und Paintschamp sein.
Linux-Server-Administrator. Ein Linux-Frontend-Administrator.
Wie darf man sich denn das vorstellen?
Das interessiert mich jetzt. Was ist ein Linux-Frontend-Administrator?
werde ein IT-Macher.
Ich mach mal ein bisschen größer.
Linux Frontend-Administrator.
Bei IT-Prozessen sind wir Partner
und okay, bla bla bla bla bla, zur Verstärkung unserer Fast.
IT-Macher,
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter, die
Okay.
Dein Job bei uns.
Verwaltung und
Support der Arbeitsplätze unter Linux.
Moment. Troubleshooting Deepak im Linux-Desktop-Umfeld.
Leute, das Ja des Linux-Desktops ist endlich hier.
Die meinen das ernst? Ich dachte an Webfrontends.
Die meinen wirklich Linux-Desktop-Arbeitsplätze.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist doch schon mal ein Pluspunkt, oder?
Dass es da sowas gibt.
Entwicklung von Client Standards, Images und Rollout Prozessen,
Mitwirkung bei der Automatisierung von Client Management Aufgaben,
zum Beispiel durch Scripting,
LDAP Benutzerverwaltung,
Weiterentwicklung, Softwareverteilung auf den Linux Clients,
Standardisierung und Konfiguration,
Aktualisierung Linux Clients,
Einrichtung von Drucker,
Ah, der Drucker, Netzwerk Ressourcen,
abgeschlossene Ausbildung, Systemintegration
Erfahrung mit Linux Desktop und LibreOffice
Aha
Ähm, Kenntnis in
Single Sign-On und LDAP-Integration
Da wird es bei mir schon immer aufhören
Ja, aber
nur 1, 2 heute
Es sei denn, ihr habt noch mehr
Weil wir sind mit Programmierstells durch
jetzt nach 4 Stunden, da habe ich gesagt, komm, ich habe jetzt noch so viel Zeit
Wir machen einfach
Warum kann ich eigentlich nicht rechts klicken auf der Seite?
Da habe ich eigentlich schon mal gesagt, ich hasse Seiten, die Rechtsklick sperren.
Das regt mich immer richtig auf, wenn Rechtsklick gesperrt ist auf Webseiten.
Ganz schlimm.
Ich meine, es bringt auch überhaupt nichts.
Außer, dass es nervig ist.
Ausgeprägte Methodenkompetenz in Projektmanagement, Analyse und Konzeption und Beratung.
Ja, Moment mal.
Warum musst du denn ausgeprägte Methoden, was auch immer das genau bedeuten soll, Kompetenz haben, wenn du ein Linux-Frontend-Administrator bist?
Du bist für Linux-Clients zuständig, was hat das jetzt mit Projektmanagement zu tun?
Oder was, ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was Methodenkompetenz überhaupt bedeuten soll, um ehrlich zu sein.
Was ist Methodenkompetenz?
Methoden ist die Fähigkeit, Aufgaben und Probleme durch gezielte Technik, Strategie und Arbeitstechnik effizient zu lösen.
Hä?
Okay, was auch immer.
Methodenkompetenz.
Also wenn da schon mal Projektmanagement drinsteht, finde ich das schon mal fragwürdig, weil das Linux Frontend Admin
Und ich behaupte einfach mal, die richtig guten, nicen Linux-Leute, das sind jetzt nicht die besten Projektmanager.
Führerscheinklasse B.
Darauf kannst du dich freuen.
Okay, Möglichkeit zur persönlichen und fachlichen Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung.
Das finde ich auch immer geil, wenn die das so als Benefits reinschreiben.
Ich bin der Meinung, das sollte so eines der ureigensten Interessen des Arbeitgebers sein, dass die Leute Möglichkeit haben, fachlich qualifizieren und weiterzubilden, weil wer will ja auch noch, dass sie in zwei Jahren noch durchblicken.
Fortbildung, Schulung inklusive Zertifizierung, auch eher was, was den Arbeitgeber selbst interessiert, aber manche Leute mögen ja gerne Zertifikate zu machen, also warum nicht, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Eigenverantwortliches Arbeiten innerhalb eines professionellen Teams.
Das klingt jetzt sehr standardmäßig.
Vielfältige Möglichkeiten zum Einbringen von Ideen.
Sagen auch viele.
Ein interessantes und anspruchsvolles Tätigkeitsfeld in einem etablierten oder mit einem zertifizierten Rechenzentrum.
Äh, ja, bla bla.
attraktive lage innerhalb des it hotspots pre park in kaiserslautern mit guter anwendung
zauber das ist tatsächlich ein plus finde ich schon ob die anbindung jetzt wirklich so gut
ist kann ich natürlich beurteilen ich habe kaiserslautern mit glauben die neben war ich
noch nie flache hier erschienen so viel okay das erzählen auch immer viele ja ganz ehrlich
die Stellenanzeige ist jetzt nichts
äh
herausragendes, würde ich mal sagen.
Aber immerhin, ich meine, das ist halt so
das meiste davon ist so 0815, bla bla.
Es ist nicht so krasses
Selbstbeweihräuchere,
wie manche haben, ja. Manche Stellenanzeigen
haben ja gefühlt die erste
Seite, nur wie geil der Arbeitgeber
ist.
Ja. Ja, das finde ich auch
blöd, dass so wenige
hinschreiben, wie es mit
der Gehalts...
Da steht nichts zum Gehalt. Wie so Gehaltsrange
sagen wir mal. Oder mal so grob
eine Hausnummer hinschreiben.
Weil wenn die gut ist,
dann sorgt das für sehr viele Bewerbungen.
So, was haben wir
jetzt noch? Was haben sie sonst noch?
Ist am Mitte des Jahres Pflicht?
Inwieweit ist es denn eigentlich
am Mitte des Jahres Pflicht?
Weil wenn es einfach nur Pflicht ist, eine Range
hinzuschreiben, dann schreiben die
30.000 bis 150.000.
Nein, es ist der Range.
Dann bist du dann genauso schlau wie vorher.
Ja.
Ja, Uint Min Value bis Uint Max Value schreiben die hin.
Okay, jetzt gibt es noch einen Lux-Server-Administrator.
die wollen erfahrung administration und wartung von linux servern und
betriebssystem ja gut und betriebssystem linux ist schon klar dass linux da
drauf ist als betriebssystem auf linux server
uns gleich mal angucken
eine richtung von linux klein infraschunkel und zentralen server
diensten die haben copy paste das vom vom vom frontend administrator oder oder
ach nee die meinen wenn server als klein auf andere zugreifen oder whatever keine
ahnung installation konfiguration aktualisieren linux servern ja sollte
klar sein bei linux admin ist verwaltung von netzwerkdiensten dns dhcp und dhcp
CP, äh, NFS,
Samba, Web-Server,
Mail-Server, Mail-Server ist
abfuck hoch 10.
Sicherheitsmanagement,
Firewalls, Benutzerrechte, SSH-Zugänge,
Updates, ja, ziemlich, ziemlich Standard-Zeug.
Virtualisierung, Containerverwaltung,
zum Beispiel
KVM, Docker und
Kubernetes.
Schon sehr unterschiedliche
Bereiche.
Aber
ist auch, das sag ich auch immer wieder, ist in der
heutigen Zeiten nicht verkehrt, sich ein bisschen mit
Containerisierung
auszukennen.
Und das einfach Standard
in vielen Bereichen ist.
Aber das sind halt
drei sehr unterschiedliche Dinger.
KVM ist Vollvirtualisierung,
also quasi sowas wie VMWare
im Endeffekt.
Und das, was auch Proxmox verwendet
oder was man auf dem Desktop mit
Workmanager unter Linux teilweise verwendet.
Docker, sagen wir mal,
hauptsächlich oder ursprünglich gedacht
Eigentlich um dieses Problem zu beheben bei Entwicklern.
Hier tut auf meiner Kiste, tut woanders nicht.
Es gibt Leute, die lassen ihre Produktion unter Docker laufen.
Aber für mich ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt im Enterprise Umfeld das Tool der Wahl
für produktive Anwendungen und Deployments.
Aber man sollte sich auf jeden Fall mit Docker auskennen, weil da hängt ja noch viel drumherum dran.
Die ganze Image, wie Container-Images aufgebaut sind, wie man einen Docker-File erstellt und sowas, das bringt einem ja bei Kubernetes dann auch was.
ja und im business enterprise umfeld wenn es darauf ankommt dass man eine anwendung
laufen lässt beispielsweise in der managed cloud umgebung oder dass man eine anwendung
besonders gut skalieren will oder dass man ein portal bereitstellen will wo entwickler sich
selbst darum kümmern können allerdings sich nicht um die infrastruktur kümmern müssen
drunter und sowas. Also im Enterprise-Umfeld
ist Kubernetes eigentlich so das Ding,
der Wahl für als
Container-Orchestrator.
So, Planung und Umsetzen
der Migration, Optimierung von Servern, Domain-Strukturen.
Okay, aber passt
irgendwie. Fehleranalyse bei Systemproblemen.
Gut, das sollte eigentlich, finde ich, das ist
eigentlich so mit, das zentrale Ding
von einem Linux-Server-Admin.
Das dürfte
einen nicht unerheblichen Teil
der Arbeitszeit ausmachen.
Troubleshooting und Fehleranalyse bei Systemproblemen.
Von OpenShift
habe ich keinen Blasenschimmer.
Weil ihr es gerade im Chat davon habt.
Okay, fundierte
Kenntnisse in verschiedenen...
Okay.
Ich finde immer so, dein Job bei uns
und dein Profil, das überschneidet sich
bei vielen immer so ein bisschen.
Fundierte Kenntnisse in verschiedenen Linien.
Zum Beispiel Debian, Ubuntu.
Hätten sie nicht Debian und Red Hat nehmen können oder sowas?
Weil Debian und...
Okay, es stimmt nicht.
Ubuntu hat noch ein ganz eigenes Ökosystem drumherum,
was Canonical sich da so aus den Fingern gesaugt hat.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, dass Ubuntu immer noch ein Debian ist.
Debian glücklicherweise nicht unbedingt ein Ubuntu.
Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich an Snap und an...
Netplan denke. Also Snap ist ja der neueste Trend seit ein paar Jahren bei Ubuntu, um Pakete zu installieren.
Das sind dann containerisierte Anwendungen, die so aussehen wie normale Pakete, aber keine normalen Pakete sind.
Und Netplan ist Netzwerkkonfiguration in YAML-Files. Finde ich auch nicht so dolle.
Was ich übrigens auch merkwürdig finde ist, dass Debian kein CLI-Config-Tool für Netzwerkkarten hat
Witzig eigentlich, ne?
Bei Debian musst du immer noch, und das finde ich besser als Netplan, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen
ETC Network Interfaces oder du kannst auch Netplan unter Debian machen
Du kannst auch Network Manager machen oder Cloud Init oder irgendwas, ja
Aber was ich nicht verstehe ist
Systemd Network D
Ja, da gibt es ja zig Varianten, was du machen kannst
Ich glaube Cloud Init
Macht standardmäßig Systemd Network D
Dann hast du dann einen Eintrag
Wo DHCP dahinter steht
Rufbereit, ich habe heute Rufbereitschaft
Aber ich muss mal kurz gerade in Teams gucken
Aber es war
Nichts mehr seit heute Morgen
Exzellent
Easy Money
Easy Life
nmc leides network manager taste standardmäßig eigentlich nicht auf server drauf wird ein
bisschen komisch dass es quasi kein netzwerk terminal interface terminal tui gibt für etc
network interfaces standardmäßig bei dem jan obwohl die ja im installer im installer haben
die ja so was ja aber nm2 ist für network manager network manager hast du einen standard mehr sie
nicht dabei oder installiert da eigentlich normalerweise nicht auf server kannst du
machen aber meistens hat man das nicht okay was haben wir das noch erfahrung mit virtualisierung
network man das default brenner zumindest mal 10 sie ist immer ich habe kaum red hat
10 installiert ich finde das übrigens gar nicht schlecht dass das default ist ich bin
nämlich das ganze network manager ecosystem was es da auch unter anderem an kommandozeilen clients
gibt und so ein ganz nice finde ich finde ich gut wir haben auf der arbeit hauptsächlich red hat das
meiste ist nur Red Hat 8, weil Business Enterprise und lahm as fuck beim umstellen.
Arch by the way, ja klar was sonst. Also ich, ich papp privat Arch auf dem Desktop,
Debian auf dem Server, fertig. Wir haben auf der Arbeit weder
einmal Linux noch Hockey-Linux. Wir haben tatsächlich
Pepo Burn Money
alles Red Hat
lizenziert.
Was meint ihr, was das kostet? Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist eine rhetorische Frage.
Keine Ahnung, was das kostet. Das ist teuer wie Sau.
Ja, Red Hat 8
ist glücklicherweise noch eine Weile supported.
Wir sind teilweise auch schon am umstellen,
aber das meiste ist nur Red Hat 8.
Aber das dauert. Wie gesagt, ich bin
mal in der Versicherung und die
haben da Systeme. Die haben noch
Solaris.
Allerdings
haben die keine echten Solaris-Kisten
mehr, sondern die haben irgendeine
von Oracle
haben die irgendeine
einen Solaris-Emulator
oder sowas.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Das ist so ein Fake-Solaris.
Weil die hat ein altes
Solaris-Zeug, was nur auf Solaris läuft
und jetzt haben sie irgendwie einen Solaris-Emulator,
der so tut, als ist er Solaris,
aber ist es gar nicht.
Frag nicht, keine Ahnung, Alter.
Also Erfahrung, Virtualisierung, Containertechnik, Automatisierung.
Ja, das passt wunderbar.
Hohes Maß, okay, bla bla bla bla.
Ausgeprägte Methoden kommen.
Schau, wie der Projekt.
Was wollen die eigentlich bei ihren Admins mit Projektmanagement?
Die allerwenigsten Admins sind gute Projektmanager.
Und auch die allerwenigsten Projektmanager sind gute Admins.
Wir hatten mal, also eines der ersten Server, an dem ich tatsächlich dran war, war eine Sun Solaris Kiste.
Bei uns waren noch diese weißen Kisten.
Ne, 19 Zoll Bauweise war die.
Ja, so ein bisschen in die Richtung, aber eigentlich sahen die ein bisschen anders aus.
Ja, ist auch gut.
Ist auch wurscht.
Also eines der ersten Kisten, da stand auch noch Fatsun vorne drauf.
Und ich belehne mir nicht, ich belehne mir ein, die waren eher grau vorne als blau.
Aber es kann auch sein, dass ich das durcheinanderbringe.
So hellgrau und nicht blau.
Aber das kann auch sein, wie gesagt, dass ich das durcheinanderbringe.
Zumindest.
Ähm, zumindest
Ähm
War da eine Checkpoint
Firewall drauf
Hatte jemand mal die Ehre mit Checkpoint
1 oder wie dieses Ding heißt
Zu arbeiten
Firewall 1 heißt es glaube ich, oder?
Firewall 1
Ja, das Ding
Alter, genau das Ding
Hahaha
Warum KS, Alter
Hatte da mal jemand die Ehre mit?
Mal gucken, ob es da noch schönere Bilder davon gibt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
So modern, so modern.
Ja!
So sah das damals aus.
Genau so, Chat.
Genau so.
Ja.
Genau so sah das damals aus.
Sieht aus wie ein Atari Programm.
Naja, das kommt ja auch schon aus grauer Vorzeit.
Checkpoint Firewall 1 war, soweit ich weiß, die allererste Stateful Firewall, die es gegeben hat.
Guck hier.
Genau, das war die erste Stateful Firewall.
Stateful Package Inspection.
So.
Mitte der 1990er Jahre.
Je nach wirtschaftlicher Betrachtungsweise
ist sie dies heute immer noch.
Mon KS, Alter.
So viele Leute haben noch...
Genau.
Wir hatten irgendeine Solaris-Kiste, wo das drauf war.
Ne ne ne ne
Linux konnte, es gab damals schon IP Tables
Das war 2007 oder so
Irgendwie so in dem Dreh
Ja
Und was haben wir hier sonst noch
Ne haben wir, der Rest ist das gleiche
So und der F-Programmer meint
Den hier können wir uns auch nochmal angucken
War es damals noch IP Chains?
Doch, doch, doch, das war schon IP Tables.
Bin ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher, dass das 2007 rum schon IP Tables war.
Initial Release 2001.
Also, gibt's schon ein bisschen.
Gibt's die Webseite noch?
Tatsächlich.
Gibt's immer noch.
News von 2000, richtig neu, ne?
So, dann wollen wir mal gucken.
Der RF-Programmer hat noch was geschrieben.
Codewerk.
Junior OT.
OT?
Security Engineer.
Was ist denn OT?
Das würde mich schon mal nicht nehmen,
weil ich weiß, was die Jobbezeichnung bedeutet.
Operation Technology. Aha.
Codewerk steht für Technik, Begeisterung,
Innovation und Zuverlässigkeit mit flachen
mit flachen
Hierarchien, Freiraum, okay, blablabla.
Du erstellst
Security-Konzepte und
Architekturen von Komponenten
im Bahn- und Industrie-
MonkaS.
Hatten wir nicht ein passendes...
Moment.
Ja.
Aber die meinen damit nicht die Bahn, oder?
Hoffe ich mal.
Cyberresilience Act.
Risiko- und Bedrohungsanalyse durch.
Penetration Tests.
Schwachstellen.
Softwarekomponenten.
Du implementierst Softwarekomponenten.
Also viel breitflächiger hätte man es ja eigentlich kaum beschreiben können, oder?
Okay.
Alles.
Du hast Kenntnis in IEC 62443
Das ist für mich ein SSH-Port
TS 50701
What?
Du kennst dich mit C, C++
oder Rust aus
Excellent
Wir sind ja
Chat, wir sind ja eigentlich die wahren
C++ und Rust Experten hier
Da kann ja nichts schief gehen
Du hast praktische Erfahrung im Pentesting
in dir, weil er soll
Hab ich nicht
Aber ich will mich ja eh nicht bewerben
Also ich bin, nicht, dass das einer falsch
versteht, ne? Oder hallo Chef, falls
du zuguckst, ich bin happy da, wo ich bin
Ich glaub nicht, dass er zuguckt
Ich will nicht weg
Am wichtigsten ist, wenn du arbeitest,
gerne mit anderen zusammen bist, neugierig und offen
gegenüber neuen Themen.
Abwechslungsreiche Aufgaben,
Mitentwicklung,
einen modernen Arbeitsplatz.
Das ist ja auch immer
dehnbar, was sie da drunter verstehen.
Das stand bei mir, witzigerweise,
so oder so ähnlich,
stand es damals, als ich meine Ausbildungsstelle
gesucht hab,
stand das auch in der Stellenbeschreibung
drin. Da stand auch sowas drin wie,
ich glaub, da stand nicht moderner Arbeitsplatz,
da stand irgendwie sowas wie,
oh, keine Ahnung, irgendwie ein
irgendwas mit
technologisch toll ausgestattet
oder irgendwas. Sowas in der Richtung
stand bei mir auch drin. Und wisst ihr, was
Wisst ihr, was ich damals als Rechner gekriegt habe?
Als ich angefangen habe bei der Ausbildung.
Ich habe einen ollen, selbst zusammengeschraubten Alternate Rechner gekriegt.
Die haben das billigste Gehäuse bei Alternate bestellt.
Und haben alte Hardware reingestopft.
Da war unter anderem eine ATI Grafikkarte drin, wo sich der Lüfter nicht mehr gedreht hat.
Das war der Rechner, den ich am Anfang gekriegt habe bei meiner Ausbildung.
Okay, ja.
Aber immerhin kommen sie hier auf den Punkt.
Kann ich leider nicht viel zu sagen.
Ist nicht mein Bereich.
Ich glaube, dass das ATI war.
Warte mal. Wann wurde
ATI von AMD
gekauft?
Ja, dann war das noch
eine ATI-Grafikkarte, die ich hatte.
Hast du noch eine zweite
gepostet?
Moment.
Wo?
Da?
Ne.
Ah, Junior Fullstack-Entwickler.
Oh, die suchen die Junior-Entwickler.
Das finde ich schon mal sehr nice.
Das ist ja gerade wohl recht schwierig,
da was zu finden.
Das ist gut. Das finde ich nice.
Das heißt, die sind nicht auf diesem komischen Trip.
Junior-Entwickler braucht keiner mehr,
seit man Vibe-Coden kann.
Wo ist Murnau?
Nie gehört.
Am Staffelsee, weiß ich auch nicht, wo das ist
Wo ist das?
Äh
In Bayern irgendwo?
Hinter München
Alter, das ist ja am Arsch der Welt, oder?
Das ist ja fast Italien schon
Ja, oder?
Ja, guck mal.
Das ist hinter München.
Hier unten ist Italien.
Guck mal, das...
Ja, okay, da ist doch Österreich dazwischen.
Wen juckt's?
Das ist ja fast schon Italien.
So.
Wartet mal.
Das ist mir zu hell.
Ah, exzellent.
Meinen die auch Junior oder Juniorbezahlung?
Wahrscheinlich beides.
Die meinen Junior und mit Juniorbezahlung.
Okay, also.
Du bringst Wissen.
Du verantwortest die Konzeption,
weiterentwicklung und warte vor allem im front und becken bis auf full stack entwickler
modellierung aufbau sowie implementierung von datenbanksystem okay du wirkst bei design
konzept erstellung und entwicklung von user interfaces mit da sie meine
in full stack meinen die aber ernst
Design stellst
Datenbank stellst
Frontend und Backend stellst
Du testest deine
Wie? Was ist mit denen los?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Verstehe ich nicht
Weird Champ, oder?
diese Basis bringst du auf jeden Fall mit.
Okay, man soll was gelernt haben in der Richtung, okay.
Du bist ein Full-Stack-Development-Allrounder, oder willst du das werden?
Dich zeichne in analytischem Strukturiertes Denken sowie eine selbstständige Arbeitsweise aus.
Du kennst dich in Programmiersprachen wie Node.js, C-Sharp, Python, Rust aus und bist offen.
Hey, da könnte ich ja sogar punkten mit.
Okay, vielleicht Python ist nicht so wahnsinnig, ja.
Aber JavaScript kenne ich mich aus, C Sharp kenne ich mich gut aus, Python, ja geht so und Rust, placingly fast, written in Rust.
Aber es ist eine wilde Mischung, oder? Ziemlich wilde Mischung.
Du hast bereits mit Frameworks und Technologien wie Angular, React, NestJS, ASP.NET
Da sieht man, dass es kein .NET Entwickler geschrieben hat, diese Stellenanzeigen. Da muss ASP.NET Core stehen. Die können da nichts dafür, die Benahmung von Microsoft ist scheiße. Aber ASP.NET ist das alte ASP.NET. Das ist das auf .NET Framework 4.8 Basis.
ASP.NET Core ist das neue ASP.NET auf .NET Core Basis, was allerdings nicht mehr .NET Core heißt,
sondern nach .NET Core 3 in .NET 5 umbenannt wurde. .NET 4 gab es nicht, weil ihnen da die
Ähnlichkeit zu groß war zwischen .NET Framework 4.8 und .NET 4. Deswegen wurde aus .NET Core 4
.NET 5. Und .NET 5 ist keine Weiterentwicklung von .NET Framework 4.8. Alles klar, Chat?
Microsoft-Benahmung beste.
Du verstehst nur Bahnhof, es versteht niemand, was Microsoft mit der Benahmung macht. Keiner versteht das.
Also ich kann es erklären, aber ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Du hast erste Erfahrungen mit Infrastrukturen wie Docker, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, gibt es ja auch wieder 50 verschiedene Aussprachen.
oder Ansible, sowie Protokollen
wie HTTP, GAPC,
TLS,
MQTT,
AMQ, heißt das nicht
AMQP?
Heißt das nicht AMQP eigentlich?
Ja, es heißt
AMQP.
Ich wollte es
doch gerade sagen, Alter.
Was ist AMQT? Gibt es das überhaupt?
Ne, das gibt es nicht.
Siehste?
Hätte vielleicht die Stellenanzeige noch mal einer Probe lesen sollen, da weiß, wovon er spricht.
Du hast dich in Themen wie Requirement Engineering einzuarbeiten.
Oh je.
Du hast idealerweise bereits mit Tools wie Figma, also die meinen das wirklich ernst, mit Frontend-Stells, gearbeitet und interessierst dich für UI, UX-Design.
Du verfügst über sehr gute Englisch und Deutsch und Englischkenntnis, Wort und Schrift.
Und am wichtigsten für uns zu arbeiten ist, okay, das hatten sie bei den anderen auch, das bieten wir.
Okay, moderner Arbeitsplatz mit guter Verkehrskommunikation, anspruchsvolle...
Zugang zu Wissen und Know-how in innovativen Zukunfts...
Aha.
Wachstumsmöglichkeiten, überdurchschnittliche Bezahlung.
Aha, das würde mich jetzt natürlich interessieren, wie die überdurchschnittliche Bezahlung und die flexiblen Homeoffice-Regelungen aussieht.
Kurze Entscheidungswege und Möglichkeiten, einen Beitrag mit deinem Alter in die Zukunft zu machen, nachhaltig zu gestalten.
Ja, ich meine, es ist halt ein bisschen wilde Mischung, wer betet.
Letztendlich kann man sagen, ist halt Fullstack.
Ob da jetzt wirklich Frontend-Design, Webdesign noch dazugehören sollte?
Naja.
Aber warum nicht?
Kannst ja mal reinschreiben.
In der Regel ist es ja eh so, was sie da reinschreiben, die suchen ja niemand, der 100% davon erfüllt.
Oder vielleicht schwebt ihnen das vor, aber in der Regel ist es nicht so, dass einer 100% das erfüllt.
Obstkorb haben sie keinen.
Gibt keinen Obstkorb.
Was haben wir hier?
Okay.
Kammer öffnen.
Aktuelle Stellenangebote.
Die Webseite ist komisch.
Das liegt an meinem Darkreader.
Ähm.
Ich kenne die.
Der Name sagt mir was.
Die betreiben Rechenzentren, oder?
Die kenne ich.
Ich weiß.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Irgendwie sagt mir der Name was.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Nicht Noris Bank.
Die hier, Rechenzentren, die kenn ich.
Ne, ne, ich kenn die hier, Norris Networks, das kenn ich, das sagt mir irgendwas.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo und wann ich mal was mit denen zu tun hab, aber das sagt mir was.
Ja, genau, hier, Schwalbach in Frankfurt.
Deswegen sagt mir das was.
Oder Schwalbach bei Frankfurt.
Genau, die bauen da gerade ein neues Rechenzentrum.
Okay.
Deswegen habe ich von denen letztens was gehört.
Ja, ja.
So.
Äh.
Chat.
Die Webseite suckt.
Da kann man nicht zurück.
Ah.
Webseite können auf jeden fall schneller sein standort
remote
hof
Die remote
Aktualisieren bestimmt nur support stellt leute
Senior it systems engineer vor mw data center virtualisieren it systems schwerpunkt nsxt
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was NSXT ist.
Software Defined
Network.
Okay.
Systems Engineering Linux. Okay, wenigstens eine Sache,
womit ich ein bisschen auskenne.
Ja.
Moment.
Dark Reader muss aktiviert werden.
Was ist eigentlich diese leere Navigationsleiste hier links?
Bietet Unternehmen Lösungen in den Bereichen IT-Outsourcing, Cloud-Services, Network und Security und Data Center?
Bla bla bla.
Das überspringe ich meistens.
ähm
IT Systems
Engineering, Linux, MWD, Design
und Implementation, aha
die Verantwortung der Abteilung
Service Integration
wie auch immer
liegt in der technischen Entwicklung
Implementierung von, Moment, der Satz
ist mir zu kompliziert, warte mal
die Verantwortung der Abteilung
Service Integration
liegt in der technischen
Entwicklung und Implementierung
von Lösungen und Produkten auf der
Plattform und Applikationen.
Was? Den Satz check ich schnell.
Moment. Was? Sowie die
Integration der Services in die jeweilige
Betriebs-
Da musst du
den Satz musst du
erstmal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Chat ist klar,
was Sache ist, oder?
Okay, deine Aufgaben Planung, Bereitstellung hochverfügbarer IT-Systeme unter Linux in komplexen IT-Landschaften.
Ja, das passt auch gut dabei.
Technische Konzipierung und praktische Umsetzung von spannenden Kundenprojekten im Managed Linux Bereich.
Okay, ja, macht Sinn.
Ob die spannend sind, kommt drauf an.
Das ist im Auge des Betrachters.
Beratung unserer Kunden und Inhouse-Betriebsteams um...
Soll das nicht zu Best Practices?
Um Best Practices?
Okay, wie auch immer.
Deine Talente.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossenes Studium der Informatik.
Okay, die übliche.
Erfahrung mit Linux-basierter Infrastruktur
und Werkdatenbankdiensten in komplexen IT-Umgebungen.
Infrastrukturen.
Passt.
Bei dem Titel passt's.
Fundierte Kenntnisse um Config Management.
Puppet.
Boah, ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt, ne?
Da mach ich einen großen Bogen drum.
Ich hab das jahrelang mitbetreut.
Und
ich hätte keinen Bock mehr auf Puppet.
Ein Vorteil, den ich sehe, Puppet vs.
Ansible. Puppet hat
einen viel besseren Trial Run Modus,
wo du gucken kannst, was er machen würde,
bevor er was macht.
Aber ansonsten ist Puppet Pains Champ.
Und kein Mensch
verwendet es mehr so richtig.
Ansible hat sich da einfach
durchgesetzt. Ansible für
Config, Terraform für Infrastruktur
Provisionierung.
Das ist so das Etablierte.
Vielleicht auch Open Tofu mittlerweile
als Terraform Fork, aber das läuft
bei mir alles unter Terraform.
Alternativ mit Skriptsprachen
wie
Perl.
Moment, Moment.
Meine Maus buggt, aber da muss ich jetzt erst
nochmal noch dazu sagen.
No, God!
Kein Perl, please.
Erfahrungen im Umgang mit Container-Anwendungen, zum Beispiel...
Ja gut, ganz ehrlich, das muss heute eigentlich schon sein, wenn du in dem Bereich aktiv bist.
Also du kannst als Linux... Ich meine, du kannst immer, ja, auch als Linux-Admin komplett dran vorbei sein im Kopf mit Containerisierung.
Das geht immer.
Aber eigentlich ist es schon
Also es ist
Sehr von Vorteil, wenn du dich mit
Containerisierung im Betreib von
Containern auskennst
Ja, es gibt immer noch ein paar Hardcore Linux Leute
Die sagen, von dem Scheiß will ich nichts wissen
Aber es ist halt nachgefragt
Ja, und was bringt es dir, wenn du der krasse Linux
Skript der Hackerman bist
Aber alles nur noch als Container ausgeliefert wird
Oder als
Container verpackt werden soll.
Also ich finde, das kannst du eigentlich
kaum noch voneinander trennen.
Du musst dich da eigentlich mit auskennen.
Das heißt nicht, du musst jetzt super Experte
in allem sein musst, aber du solltest schon mal
ein Docker-File erstellt haben
und wissen, was ein Multistage-Bild
ist oder sowas.
Und auch schon mal einen
Docker-Container gestartet haben, reinexact
haben. Solche
Dinger, ja. Also ein bisschen Ahnung solltest du schon haben.
Und vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen mit dem Kubernetes-Cluster
herumgespielt haben, ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Weil gerade Kubernetes
ist ein Fass ohne Boden.
Kubernetes ist so ein
typisches Ding, nach zwei,
drei Tagen, wenn du dich da als Einsteiger
damit beschäftigst, denkst du so,
ey, so kompliziert ist es doch
eigentlich gar nicht. Aber dann machst
du das Fass weiter auf und stellst fest,
es gibt eigentlich niemand,
der da einen kompletten, wirklich
großen Durchblick hat.
Es gibt da so viele Sachen,
Ich sag mal, Moment hier. Cloud
Native, wie heißen die nochmal?
Foundation?
Äh,
Landscape.
Pass mal auf.
Und das ist bei weitem
nicht alles, Leute.
Das ist bei weitem nicht alles,
was zum Thema, ähm,
Kubernetes. Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist bei weitem nicht alles.
Das ist nur, was die Clouds,
ihr Cloud Native Computing
Foundation da
Tracked.
Das ist...
Also, jede Kachel hier ist ein eigenes Projekt.
Witzigerweise sind hier auch Sachen drin,
die es gar nicht mehr gibt, ne?
Das ist deprecated mittlerweile.
Aber gut, was auch immer.
Also, das ist richtig heftig.
Das ist ein Fass ohne Boden, Alter.
Ich glaube, das hier ist...
Zeigt das ganz eindrucksvoll, ne?
Okay, Chat, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, was ich davon überhaupt kenne.
Also gehen wir mal hier, Container, Containerumfeld, okay, gehen wir mal gucken.
Also Crossplane kenne ich.
Crossplane ist so eine Art, ich nenne es mal Terraform-Alternative, die aber komplett im Kubernetes-Cluster läuft.
Du kannst Custom-Resource-Definitions anlegen, die dann unter der Haube Sachen professionieren.
Also du kannst quasi in Kubernetes
Jammer Ressourcen
definieren, die unter anderem halt auch noch außerhalb
von Kubernetes angelegt werden,
wie zum Beispiel eine Datenbank. Oder du kannst
es für deinen Entwickler einfacher machen,
indem du eine Custom-Ressource definierst,
die aber unter der Haube schon
Service, Ingress, sorry,
Gateway und
Application-Sachen anlegt und sowas. Aber
Crossplane kenne ich. Keda kenne
ich auch. Ist das irgendwelche
Scaling-Geschichten? Weiß
ich jetzt aber nicht genau.
K-Native kenne ich, das ist so Function as a Service Geschichte
Serverless, Application Layer, genau
Kubernetes selbst, gut, container orchestration
Fluid
Ist das nicht irgendwas mit Logging oder sowas?
Elastic Data Abstraction, okay
Sowas in der Richtung, ja
Kamada hab ich noch nie gehört, keine Ahnung was das ist
Multicluster
Kuponiertes Orchestration, keine Ahnung
Chat, habt ihr das schon mal gehört?
Ach Logima Fluent D
Nicht Fluid, stimmt, jetzt bring ich die Sachen auch noch
Durcheinander, Kamada hab ich noch nie gehört
Cubeflow kenn ich auch
Das sagt mir irgendwas
Ähm
Genau
Mir wär's nicht eingefallen, hätt ich's
Nicht gelesen
KI-Stells, genau
Ähm, Volcano
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht
Cloud Native Batch System
Kein Pass, ne
Was im Cloud, ja gut, WebAssembly Gedöns
Hab ich aber noch nie was mitgemacht
Äh, Mesos
Kenn ich auch, ich weiß grad nicht mehr genau
Was es ist
War das
Oh, was war
Mesos nochmal
War das, das war kein
Kubernetes Distribution, oder
Was war Mesos nochmal?
Apache Mesos. Message Queue? War das eine Message?
Ach ne, das ist die
Ist das die Apache Kubernetes Alternative
da gewesen?
Keine Ahnung, noch nie was mitgemacht.
Das hier erkenne ich noch nicht mal, was das ist.
Okay, Amazon.
Backend AI.
Ich habe noch nie gehört.
Kenne ich?
Weiß ich aber auch gerade gar nicht genau.
Ich kann ja auch nicht lesen.
China Mobile Cloud. Okay, alles klar.
China Chinesen Zeug.
keine ahnung keine ahnung cluster pd ja keine ahnung cosi stack das kenne ich so
kenne ich auch keine ahnung keine ahnung keine ahnung keine ahnung ist das nicht
Irgend so eine Config-Sprache?
Irgend so eine Templating-Config-Sprache?
Oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung.
Das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Das kenne ich auch.
Aber wüsste ich auch nicht, was es ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Cube Admiral?
das kenne ich
gibt kenne ich auch
habe ich schon mal gehört
habe ich auch schon mal glaube ich gehört
keine ahnung dass es hätte ich auch
Prozent
keine Ahnung
das ist auch Funktion erste Service gedöhnt ist
Prozent
die KMH schon mal gehört
Prozent keine Ahnung keine Ahnung keine Ahnung
keine Ahnung
Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht.
Ja, also da seht ihr mal.
Das ist, ich verdiene damit indirekt mein Geld.
Aber ich habe auch von, das ist ein Riese.
Das ist wirklich komplett Fass ohne Boden.
Okay, Envoy kenne ich.
Wir machen jetzt nicht weiter.
Hat ja keinen Sinn.
Ist hier Linkerd?
Linkerd.
Konsul.
Traffic.
Ja.
ETCD.
Core DNS.
ist. Ja, aber das ist
wirklich ein Riesending, Alter.
Du denkst nach zwei, drei Tagen
so schwierig ist es doch gar nicht. Und dann
machst du das Fass auf und stellst fest
Fuck, Alter, Leute, ich hab keinen Plan.
Und das geht dann auch nie weg. Das bleibt
für immer so.
Weil da ändert sich ja öfters mal was dran.
Vielleicht nicht so schnell wie im AI-Umfeld, okay?
Cube Green
ist Pots automatisch zu scalen und nur zu
bestimmten Teilen. Nicht schlecht, ja.
Kann das auch zu bestimmten Uhrzeiten?
Weil, keine Ahnung.
Äh, Moment, wir wollten eigentlich noch
Stellenanzeige fertig gucken, oder?
Lul.
Eigenständiges,
strukturiertes, lösungsorientiertes
Arbeiten.
Qualitätsbewusstsein, Teamfähigkeit,
blablabla. Deine Benefits,
jetzt kommt's. Unbefristeter
arbeitsvertrag und flexible arbeitszeiten arbeiten an verschiedenen standort möglichen oder auch zu
100 prozent remote das ist natürlich ein hochwertiges equipment ich glaube sowas in
der richtung stand in meiner damals azubi stellenanzeige ja irgendwie sowas hochwertige
arbeits bei irgendwie sowas haben sie da rein laptop und firmen die auch zur privaten nutzung
da muss ich sagen mache ich mittlerweile nicht mehr beim alten arbeitgeber hatte ich ja ein
handy also ich habe damals iphone für alle was regelmäßig aktualisiert wurde
das habe ich für die firma und privat benutzt erster nachteil war man hat
permanent eigentlich auf das arbeits handy drauf geguckt du hast also mal
abends um 21 uhr wenn du mal aufs klo musste ist noch gelesen dass du den
teams nachricht hat das und so was wobei ich das an sich nicht für sich
allein genommen gar nicht so schlimm fand ja warum ich das dann gemacht also
warum ich jetzt zwei Handys am Start habe.
Mein Arbeitgeber erlaubt auch private iPhone-Nutzung.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Handys am Start,
ein privates iPhone und ein iPhone von der Firma.
Weil das einfach ein richtiger Akt ist,
das zu trennen wieder,
wenn du es zu lange zusammen benutzt hast.
Was das für ein Akt war,
bis ich mir ein privates Handy eingerichtet habe,
mit allem drauf und dran,
und bloß die Handynummer umgezogen habe und so Zeug.
Das war ein Riesenakt,
deswegen mache ich das nicht mehr.
Und Firmenlaptop, ja gut, den würde ich theoretisch sogar, wenn ich mal unterwegs bin, vielleicht sogar mitnehmen und benutzen, aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe gar keinen Anwendungszweck für einen Laptop zur Zeit.
Individuelle Förderung, Inhouse, okay.
Kinderbetreuungskostenzuschuss pro Monat pro Kind, Corporate Benefit.
Das ist jetzt meistens nicht so geil, aber das könnte durchaus sehr nice sein.
Wenn es auch oben drauf kommt.
Attraktive Firmen-Events inklusive...
Ah, Chat.
Für wen von euch ist es ein Benefit?
Oder wer sagt auch eher, geh mal weg mit großartigen Firmen-Events?
Also ich kenne auch ein paar bei mir auf der Arbeit, die feiern das richtig mit Firmen-Events.
Aber ich bin ja eher Kellerkind.
Ich will keine Firmen-Events.
Ja, also für mich ist es auch kein allzu großer Benefit.
Gesundheitsmanagement, zum Beispiel kostenlose Massage.
Jobrad leasing. Jobrad finde ich
ist irgendwie so eine unsinnige Sache.
Das lohnt sich nur, wenn du es wirklich
komplett durchziehst.
Auch wenn es zwischendurch los werden wird.
Fahrrad kaufen, besser.
Attraktiver Zuschuss zum
Deutschland-Ticket.
So teuer ist das Deutschland-Ticket
doch jetzt auch nicht. Das könnte man doch auch übernehmen.
Komplett, oder?
Die 63 Euro oder was es dann kostet.
Was hältst du von Dudeskultur? Ist mir am liebsten.
Auf sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, blablabla, hab ich keinen Bock. Das ist mir lieber.
Bei uns ist es tatsächlich von, im Endeffekt von der Putzfrau bis zum Vorstand.
Ob die Leute es wirklich machen beim Vorstand, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab glaube ich noch nie einen gesehen, so face to face vom Vorstand.
Was macht eigentlich der Austausch?
Ich war vor zwei Tagen zuletzt rennen.
Ich müsste mal wieder.
Welcome Day.
Direkter Ansprechpartner und strukturierte...
Ja, das ist gut.
Ich meine, streng genommen ist das auch so im ureigensten Interesse des Arbeitgebers,
dass die Leute gut eingearbeitet werden.
Aber es ist trotzdem gut.
Weil...
Nur weil du dich mit der Technik auskennst,
heißt es noch lange nicht, dass du dich auskennst,
wie diese Technik beim jeweiligen Arbeitgeber eingesetzt wird.
Und dementsprechend sind feste Ansprechpartner gerade am Anfang sehr nice.
Getränke for free, das ist gut.
Frisches Obst an allen Standorten.
Wunderbar, der Obstkorb ist gesichert.
Aber Gehaltsvorstellungen schreiben sie auch nicht.
Du musst deine Gehaltsvorstellungen schreiben.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt die letzte Stellenanzeige an.
Und zwar die hier.
Obstkorb.
Das sind wir.
Cloud Operator.
Ich find's auch blöd, wenn da nie das Gehalt dasteht.
Aber gut, die denken halt, vielleicht kriegen sie da einen, der richtig nice ist, aber wenig haben möchte.
Die wollen sich das immer noch so offen halten.
wenn sie das nicht einschreiben
so er weiter im
wo haben wir denn den Browser
doch angeblich hier haben sogar die
in die US Posten habe ich zugemacht
wir hätten vor allem aus Post von Tagesschau gepostet das bald gesagt also
so gut
eingeschrieben werden soll
wobei ich da halt mich echt Frage wie das läuft ob dann einer wirklich
reinschreibt. 30k bis 200k.
So, Range steht drinnen.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Die Senec.
Einer der führenden Anbieter
innovativer Stromspeicher- und
Energielösung für Privathaushalte.
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Das finde ich immer anstrengend,
wenn erst die erste Seite
Selbstlobreisung ist.
Nun möchtest
auch du Teil von etwas ganz
großem werden.
Also in der Regel ist mein hauptsächliches
Anliegen, warum ich mir einen Job suche,
dass ich Geld verdiene.
Wenn man das da aber sagt, gucken sie wahrscheinlich
blöd. Und was
bringt sie zu uns?
Ja, ich will Geld verdienen. Ich will nicht unter der Brücke
schlafen müssen. Was? Du siehst dich nicht
als Teil des großen Ganzen.
Wobei es nicht
verkehrt ist. Nicht falsch verstehen.
Es ist durchaus nicht verkehrt, wenn man sich mit dem Arbeitgeber identifizieren kann und wenn man die Sachen gerne macht, die man da macht.
Besser als andersrum.
Auf ab welchem Gehalt würdest du auf eine Beamtenstelle verzichten, abseits von deiner aktuellen Arbeitsstelle?
Ich bin kein Beamter. Keine Ahnung, hab ich mir nie Gedanken darüber gemacht. Kein Plastenschimmer.
Max würde auch Dronensysteme hosten.
Ja, jetzt kein Problem mit.
Wenn es passen...
Also, ich bin bis zum gewissen Grad natürlich käuflich.
Ja, ist kein Problem.
Wenn die jetzt sagen, Max,
wir bezahlen dir 500k,
komm zu uns,
wir betreiben Infrastruktur,
wo mit Drohnen gesteuert werden,
wo Leute abgeschossen werden, würde ich sagen, das mache ich.
Da hätte ich tatsächlich wenig Schmerzen mit.
Wer weiß, wie es ist, wenn man dann erstmal da ist, ja?
Vielleicht kriegt man dann doch seine Gewissensbisse über kurz oder lang.
Aber so Bauchgefühl-mäßig würde ich jetzt erstmal sagen, wahrscheinlich wäre es mir wurscht.
Weil ich meine ganz im Ernst, wenn man, ich meine, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen doofer Vergleich,
Aber wenn man bei einer Versicherung oder sowas arbeitet und dafür Systeme bereitstellt, wo der Außendienst irgendwelche Omas bescheißen kann, ja, ist jetzt auch bestimmt moralisch nicht das Beste.
Aber Chat, meinst du mal ernsthaft?
Ich weiß, es lässt sich immer einfach sagen
Boah, das ist ja moralisch fragwürdig und sonst was
Würde jemand von euch
Wenn jetzt mal angenommen irgendein Rüstungsunternehmen
Kommt auf euch zu
Und sagen hier, super Arbeitsplatz
Und sagen wir mal, der Arbeitsplatz wäre auch so von dem
Was ihr euch vorstellt, wirklich super
Von dem, was die einsetzen, von den Technologien
Ja, fester Arbeitsplatz, langfristiger Vertrag, also unbefristeter Vertrag.
Ihr kommt gut hin, ihr habt eine gute Homeoffice-Regelung, es ist alles super.
Und sie geben euch eine halbe Million im Jahr.
Und du wüsstest dafür aber, dass du Infrastruktur betreiben musst, die für Drohnenangriffe benutzt wird.
Würdet ihr das machen oder nicht?
und muss letztendlich jeder selbst wissen
Also ich würde es wahrscheinlich machen.
Man kann sich ja zur Not immer noch
einreden, man steht auf der Seite von den Guten.
Wenn man dann
Gewissensbisse kriegt.
Muss aber jeder selbst wissen.
Es sieht dann auch immer ein bisschen anders aus.
Wenn man es dann wirklich macht.
Ja.
Wenn man es dann wirklich macht,
kann das durchaus sein, dass man dann Probleme kriegt
mit der Zeit.
Ich denke, aktuell würde ich es wahrscheinlich machen.
So, also was haben die hier sonst noch?
Aufbau und Pflege modularer Terraform-Stacks.
Okay, wann ist was?
Cloud Operator, aha, stimmt.
Aufbau und Pflege modularer Terraform-Stacks, Modules, Providers für Azure, AWS, Landing Zones, Netzwerk, Security, Kubernetes und Plattformdienste.
Okay, eigentlich ganz interessant.
quasi ein hauptberuflicher Terraform-Schreiber.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile auch eher
Jammel-Engineer, würde ich sagen.
Also da sehe ich mich.
Und nochmal, ich suche nichts Neues,
weil immer die Frage kommt,
ja, ich bin happy da, wo ich bin.
C-I-C-D
Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery,
Pipelines für Validierung, Linting,
Policy Checks, Drift Erkennung.
Ach, das ist auch sowas.
Wir hatten es doch vorhin von Crossplane.
Crossplane ist da auch richtig nice drin.
Was Drift Erkennung angeht.
Man Terraform auch, wenn du es regelmäßig ausführst.
TerraMate.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Was ist TerraMate?
Ist das was, was man googeln kann?
Oder was passiert dann?
Okay.
TerraMade CLI.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Open Tofu Unterstützung.
Keiner, kenne ich nicht.
Qualitätsstandards.
Immutable Patterns.
Testbarkeit.
Docs as Code.
Moment.
Was soll das jetzt bedeuten?
Heißt das, mein Code
ist self-documenting?
Oder was ist mit
Docs as Code gemeint?
Documentation
that you should write documentation
that you should be writing
documentation with the same tools as code.
Ach so, dass du die Sachen
in den Markt... Okay, das finde ich
dann wieder gut. Immutable
Patterns, kommt man am Ende nicht
drumherum, wenn es um
Kubernetes und Container
Orchestrierung geht, weil am besten
funktioniert das Ganze, wenn
die Container so
wenig State wie möglich haben. Es geht
nicht immer, ja. Manchmal
brauchst du einen Logical, äh, kein
Logical Volume.
Was heißt es ausgeschrieben?
PVC?
Physical Volume?
Nee, was?
PVC, was heißt es nochmal ausgeschrieben?
Persistent!
persistent volume jetzt habe ich meine güte sagt immer nur pvc ja persistent volume genau meine güte
Manchmal kommst du nicht drum herum aber am besten ist wenn das ganze keinen states in den containern hat
Bereitstellung von self service katalog terraform los geht ab sie
inklusive klarer guard rails und abgestufter genehmigungsprozessor
Prozessor, das haben sie auch nice geschrieben.
Enablement für
you build it, you run it, inclusive templates.
Okay, das ist dann
sowas wie, wenn du so
ein Portal hast,
beispielsweise, für Entwickler,
unter anderem
können da auch
Crossplane,
Custom Resource Definitions drunter sein,
wo die Entwickler quasi
relativ einfach ihre Anwendungen
hosten können, ohne dass sie sich mit der
Infrastruktur drunter beschäftigen müssen.
Das ist so ein bisschen kleiner Trend der letzten Jahre gewesen.
Hast du Crossplane schon mal produktiv eingesetzt?
Nee.
Oder naja.
Okay, also ich persönlich habe das noch nicht vom Scratch aufgesetzt
oder damit großartig im Businessumfeld was gemacht.
Wir haben aber mittlerweile Crossplane
auf der Arbeit.
Das heißt, ich habe damit schon was zu tun.
aber es ist nicht, dass ich dafür verantwortlich bin.
Unter anderem ist das bei uns mit ein Teil von genau so einer Developer-Plattform.
Im Sinne von, you build it, you run it.
Ja, genau.
Also, das kommt noch immer mehr auf uns zu in Zukunft.
Ist aber was, was ich mega nice finde.
Ich freue mich richtig auf Cross-Playing-Geschichten,
weil ich das vom Ansatz her geil finde.
also das Crossplane Projekt. Ein paar Probleme gibt es soweit ich weiß bei
Crossplane. Zum Beispiel, dass es immer noch keinen Tri-Run Modus gibt. Weiß nicht
wie man da am besten drumherum werkelt, aber das gibt es immer noch nicht. Oder
doch oder nicht. Okay, naja, 4.
Okay, Landing Zone Konzept mit Trennung von Death Stage Brot, Least Privilege, Segregation of Duties.
Jetzt werden aber die Buzzwords gedroppt, Alter.
Least Privilege ist bei uns auch immer mehr und mehr im Kommen.
Was teilweise richtig der Anfang ist.
Bei uns gibt es teilweise ganz abgedrehte Dinger.
Da gibt es Sachen, da kommst du nur von der Windows-Kiste drauf und auf diese Windows-Kiste kommst du nur über einen RDP-Proxy.
Ne, das muss ich anders sagen. Also, nochmal.
Es gibt eine Kiste, da kommst du nur von der Windows-Kiste aus drauf.
Auf diese Windows-Kiste musst du über irgendeinen Remote-RDP-Management-Portal
und der generiert dir deine RDP-Session oder sowas
und du kriegst einen File, das kannst du öffnen mit deinem lokalen RDP-Client.
Und das geht dann über einen RDP-Proxy
und der RDP-Proxy, der zeichnet auf,
was du auf diese High-Secure-Kiste klickst.
Das heißt, wenn dann irgendwas da schief läuft oder du irgendwas anstellst oder sonst was,
dann können die später einen Video-Feed angucken von deiner RDP-Session.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug, ey.
Es ist weniger Poggers, es ist teilweise echt abfuck.
Was ist auf der Maschine? Bitcoins?
Nee, aber teilweise Secrets und Schlüssel und sowas.
Bei uns in der Versicherung ist das sogar Aufsichtsvorschrift,
dass das bei manchen bestimmten Infrastruktursystemen passieren muss,
mit so einer Aufzeichnung.
So, durchgängige Logs und Traces mit Ringen, OpenSearch, OpenTelemetry, Prometheus, Grafana, gut, das ist ja der Standard.
Was auch angesagt ist, ist Victoria Metrics, weil das noch mehr Sachen sich einverleiben kann.
Ah, da kommt wahrscheinlich noch Greylock oder Loki oder irgendwie sowas dabei.
Alerting, Alert Manager, Opsgenie.
Moment, Opsgenie? Ist Opsgenie nicht out of things mittlerweile?
wird das nicht mehr das ist doch eingestellt oder end of life der verkauf endet am 4 juni
der support am 5 april 2027 sagt das ist eingestellt
Alert Manager
Lass mich mal was sagen
Ich find Alert Manager suckt
Ich mag Alert Manager nicht
Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen
Ich finde, also so geil
Prometheus zum Metriken sammeln ist
Und so cool Grafana für Grafen ist
Wenn man damit klassisches Monitoring auch abbilden will,
also was weiß ich, SSH-Port ist down,
Festplatten-Schwellwert über 75% und sowas.
Ich finde das eklig.
Ja, Alert-Manager tut,
aber es gibt da auch keine gescheite Übersicht.
Also manchmal hätte man halt gern so eine klassische Ansicht,
wie man es beispielsweise bei Zappix oder Nagios oder so hatte.
Hier, Alert reingekommen, da und da, jetzt bestätigen.
ist er halt nicht.
Wo man halt auch wiederum sieht, dass es eben nicht für
klassisches Monitoring gedacht ist,
sondern als Metrix Collection
und dann Analyse mit den
Metrix machen und nicht unbedingt
klassisches Monitoring da auch noch mit rein
zwängen.
Sinnvollen
Schwellen, Runbooks, SLU,
SLA Definition.
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich, dass
dass das ein Service Level Agreement ist.
Karma Dashboard
kenne ich. Das sieht
ganz wild aus, wenn man es
wenn da ein paar Sachen drin sind.
Genau hier, das da ist das.
Das sieht furchtbar wild aus,
Karma Dashboard.
Da kann mir keiner sagen, dass das übersichtlich ist
im Vergleich zu
Zabbix Alert Overview.
So,
Chat.
Ganz ernst,
ganz im ernst wo blickst du eher durch wann und wo was passiert das noch eine
lords schon bestätigt ist da in der übersicht oder da in ernsthaft chat ich
weiß ihr sagt jetzt um mich zu triggern natürlich hier blickt man viel besser
durch warum ist das so bunte verpackt also ausschaut aber ich bin der meine
So eine klassische Operating Monitor Übersicht ist immer noch, wenn man jetzt keine Metriken und Auswertungen machen will, einfach nur sehen will, ey, dann ist was passiert.
Das hat sich schon jemand angeguckt und wurde bestätigt.
Der Alert ist so und so oft nochmal aufgedreht.
Finde ich das einfach besser?
Pira, das kenne ich gar nicht.
Nach was soll ich da zoomen?
GitHub.
Making SLO.
naja, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind
was ist eigentlich nochmal SLO?
SLA ist Service Level Agreements und das ist
Service Level Operations
oder was ist SLO?
Hira
kenn ich nicht, was ist das?
Object
Making SLOs with Prometheus
manageable
was?
Das sieht aus
wie Uptime Robot
Was ist das?
Was genau ist jetzt ein SLO dabei?
Das checke ich jetzt nicht so ganz.
How many requests per second?
Da gibt es eine Demo-Page.
Okay, das ist schon mal...
Okay, das ist eher so eine Management-Übersicht, ne?
Dass sie gucken können, ah, okay, Anwendung XY ist so und so viel verfügbar und sowas.
aber das ersetzt immer noch nicht so diesen klassischen ist diese klassische übersicht
wie man es beispielsweise man agios oder zabix hat 20 30 alert xy aufgetreten von diesem und
diesem host oder von diesem und diesem träger jawohl ist acknowledged jawohl ist jetzt fünf
mal aufgetreten in den letzten 10 Minuten.
Aber das ist schon mal ganz okay,
muss ich sagen.
Damit kannst du zumindest schon mal
besser
irgendwelche Leute
überzeugen, die nicht so technikaffin
sind, wie mit nem
wie mit dem Standard Linux
Server Grafana Dashboard.
Das macht die schon...
Schalten die schon komplett ab.
Dafür ist auch Opsgenie oder nicht...
Jaja, Opsgenie gibt es aber nicht mehr.
Opsgenie ist...
Deswegen steht ja da Opsgenie...
Wird ja nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
JSM Operations, das kenne ich nicht.
Was ist das?
Jira Service Management
Achso, das meint, es macht sich irgendwelche Tickets
Ja, aber trotzdem
Also selbst wenn du ein Ticket kriegst
Das ist ja durchaus okay
Dass du ein Incident kriegst oder sowas
Pro kritischem Alert
Wo du dann auch reinschreiben kannst
Hier, wir haben uns eingeloggt
Haben festgestellt, da und da
Und hier, da ist was vollgelaufen
Das haben wir gelöscht, alles schön und gut
Aber einfach so eine Übersicht über Alerts
das ist aufgetreten. Aha, wir haben es gesehen.
Acknowledged.
Finde ich jetzt immer noch
eine sinnvolle Übersicht.
Ja, und was
Leuten, die in irgendeinem Operation Center
oder so sitzen, auch am meisten bringt.
Das neue Tool
von Atlassian ist Optionie-Ersatz.
Okay, wie heißt das?
Die haben ja so viel.
Confluence.
Rovo.
Jira Service Management.
Das da?
Moment, wir sollten die Seite vielleicht mal ein bisschen weniger hässlich machen.
Meinst du das?
Ja, das geht in die Richtung.
So halbwegs.
Das geht in die Richtung.
Aber man kann es auch kompliziert machen.
Man kann sich auch
50 Tools anschaffen, um so eine Übersicht
zu erstellen, wie man früher in Zappix und Nagios
hatte.
Was ich nur sagen will
mit dem Ganzen, so cool,
das ist mit Prometheus und Grafana, wenn man so klassische Operation-Übersicht haben will,
dann ist der Fehler aufgetreten, ist acknowledged, ist vielleicht nochmal aufgetreten innerhalb von 5 Minuten
und wird deswegen nicht alertet und sowas.
Da sind so klassische Monitoring-Tools immer noch nicht verkehrt,
weil man da in Grafana, in Prometheus sehr viel drumherum basteln muss.
Prometheus sammelt ja letztendlich nur Zahlen ein.
Ja, Prometheus haben Metriken, sind Zahlen. Also, was du in Prometheus zum Beispiel gar nicht so einfach machen kannst, ist wie, ähm, letzter, äh, letzter User, letzter eingeloggter User. Das kannst du in Prometheus nicht machen.
Du kannst den Prometheus tricksen, so nach dem Motto, last login time und dann als Label die User und sowas.
Aber Prometheus selbst ist nur Metriken, nur Zahlen.
Also alles, was du nicht gescheit in Metriken abbilden kannst.
Ja, oder wenn du sagen willst, okay, ähm, dieser User, äh, Prime by User, es hat sich jetzt der User Blub eingeloggt.
Und das ist ein Alert, so.
Da kannst du dir einen Alert-Manager danach zusammenbauen.
Aber man merkt dann teilweise schon, okay, solange es nicht wirklich um Metrik und Zahlen geht, ist das oftmals nicht so ganz passend.
Kennst du Splunk? Ja.
Ganz viel Log-Auswertungsstelz machen.
Haben wir auch auf der Arbeit.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Was labern die hier denn schon wieder von AI und das ganze Zeug?
Also ich hätte halt einfach gerne
ein Dashboard
Kann das bestimmt auch
aber sieht man jetzt hier nicht
So ein popliches Dashboard
Achtung, Bling, Alert
Was auf einen Blick siehst, aha
SSH-Port ist down.
Wie gesagt, kannst du alles nachbauen
mit anderen Monitoring-Tools, aber ich finde
die klassischen Monitoring-Sachen,
sowas wie Nagios
oder, sagen wir mal, Tabix
oder PRTG
oder was es da für Windows-Sachen gibt,
das hat durchaus auch noch seine
Daseinsberechtigung.
Immer noch Riesen-Check-MK-Enjoyer.
Du? Ich ja nicht.
Cisco Prime kenne ich nicht.
So, jetzt lass uns mal kurz gucken, was sonst noch so dasteht.
You build it, you run. Das hatten wir.
Multi-Account-Subscription.
Landing. Okay, das hatten wir.
Durchgehend. Alert-Hapira.
Transparenz über Kosten
und Kostentreiber.
Open Coast. Wir haben auch
so ein Kostenanalyse-Tool. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie es heißt, es ist manchmal
ganz praktisch, wenn
Leute mal wieder,
also ich zum Beispiel,
irgendwelche
3, 4 Terabyte großen
SSDs geklont haben
und vergessen haben zu löschen,
dann sagt das, oh gucke mal,
ihr verschenkt gerade 700 Euro.
Wollt ihr das nicht löschen?
Boah, hier haben sie aber auch alles drin
an Wörtern
Tagging, Allocation, Forecasting, Budgets
und Optimierung, Right Sizing
äh, AI, keine Ahnung
Saving Plans, Scaling Policies
Bam
Reporting und Empfehlung für Teams
Showback, Chargeback
Wo passend?
Was?
Achso, also quasi denen sagen
Ey, guck mal, ihr habt da noch eine alte
SSD rumliegen, die 700 Euro kostet
Policy as Code
Quiverno, das sagt mir was
Das kenn ich, das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor
Der Name
Erdung, Verschlüsselung
KMS, ja
Logging, Revision, Cloud, Trail
Noch nie gehört
Auditfähigkeit entlang definierter Kontrollen
Zum Beispiel ISO 27001
nahe Baseline. Was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das bedeuten soll.
Okay, Secrets Management, Schwachstellenmanagement,
Change-Kontrollen und Notfallprozesse,
Backup für S3,
Cloud-Services, Cross-Region-Strategien,
dokumentierte RT...
Was ist das? Return to Operation
oder sowas?
Was heißt das nochmal genau?
Regelmäßige Restore...
Velero kenne ich auch. Das ist so ein Backup-Tool für
Kubernetes-Cluster.
BCDR Runbooks.
Was ist
BCDR?
Business Continuity and Disaster
Recovery. Alles klar.
Technische Runbooks,
Playbooks, ADRs.
Leute, please, macht doch mal ein bisschen weniger
Abkürzungen, Mann.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich alle
Abkürzungen hat? Was für ADRs, Alter?
American Disposal
No, das ist wieder was anderes.
Entschuldigung.
Enablement für Teams. Klare
Übergabepunkte.
Definition of ready done.
Da hat sich aber auch irgendein
Management-Leute richtig ausgelassen
drin.
Mindestens drei Jahre Erfahrung in Cloud
Operations. AWS Azure.
Hätte ich schon gelitten? Okay, Azure
habe ich drei Jahre Erfahrung. Das ist aber
schon lange her. Jetzt ein paar Jahre.
Aktuell ist es hauptsächlich Google.
dafür kenne ich mich recht gut mit Terraform und ja auch mit GitLab CICD aus
fundierte Kenntnisse in Kubernetes, AKS, EKS
letztendlich
haste da eingesehen, haste alle gesehen, ein bissl unterschiedliches Zeug drum herum
wusstet ihr das Google einen eigenen Ingress hat
so dass man eigentlich gar keinen Ingress installieren muss
auch wenn Ingress nicht mehr angesagt ist und alle jetzt nur noch
API machen sollen. Helm Deployments, sonst was. Praxis in Observability, jetzt hatten
wir ja schon mal. Runbook getrieben im Betrieb. Sicherer Umgang mit Access, okay, IAM, bla bla bla.
FinOps Grundlagen, Kostenanalyse, Forecasting, Right Sizing. Boah, das klingt ja hier richtig
hier cloud native alles erfahrung mit der compliance in regulären regulierten umfeldern ich
habe keine ahnung auf basis von welchen dingen da bei uns reguliert ist aber ich kenne mich in
regulierten umfeldern aus scripting peisen bash geht basierte arbeitsweise infrastructure und
dac es sehr gut deutsch bereitschaft zu on call in geregelten rahmen ja wenn das ordentlich kohle
gibt idealerweise zertifizierung terraform zertifizierung okay erfahrung mit agro cd
habe ich haben wir sogar im stream schon mal verwendet walds kenne ich auch packer weil
sie jetzt kann ich idealerweise kritis erfahrung im energiesektor und einschimmer
okay mal gucken was sie sind ja schon relativ speziell was die haben wollen ja und auch recht
sagen wir mal, breit gefächert
so im
Cloud-Betrieb. Guck mal, was die bieten.
Wettbewerbsfähiges Gehalt.
Das ist ja auch
sehr nichtssagend, ja.
Unbefristeter Arbeitstag mit 30 Tagen Urlaub.
Ja gut, müssen sie.
Monatliche Kinderzulage.
Okay, 100 Euro pro Kind.
Maximal 200. Ah, okay.
Wenn du jetzt 8 Kinder hast, gibt's auch nicht
800.
monatlichen zuschuss in höhe von 30 ganz ehrlich bezahlt als deutschland ticket oder scheiß doch
drauf die paar euro sollten sie doch haben flexible arbeitszeiten kleid sein mobiles
arbeiten okay vergünstigte mitglied ja das ist alles jetzt so team events wie nix getränke obst
Der Obstkorb ist auch am Start.
Anfängsreihe Aufgaben und Raum für Eigeninitiative.
Bla, bla. Ja gut.
Die Benefits finde ich jetzt tatsächlich...
Gut, wenn ich Kinder hätte, wäre das ein kleiner Bonus.
Ziemlich Standard.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Einen HBA-Controller noch zusätzlich kühlen.
Die haben doch oftmals
einen Passivkühler oben drauf.
Und wenn du ein bisschen Airflow hast, reicht das.
Du willst ja nicht den komplett passiv gekühlten Server haben.
So, Chat.
Ich muss jetzt meine Tablette nehmen.
Fällt mir hier gerade auf.
So
Alles klar
Chat, ich geh jetzt Abendessen
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart
4 Stunden Progestells
1,5 Stunden noch ein bisschen so rumgeguckt
Exzellenter Stream
Wem es gefallen hat und nicht gefollowt hat
Würde ich mich sehr freuen, wenn ihr mir ein Follow
da lasst und im nächsten Stream
wieder mit am Start seid
Danke an die ganzen Subs
Ich guck nochmal nach, ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab
Neat Twitch habe ich übersehen.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was gibt es zu futtern? Toastbrot.
Und dann würde ich sagen, Chat,
sehen wir uns wahrscheinlich
morgen früh.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.